Hi, I'm Beau with Free Code Camp. This course
is taught by Dr. Linda green. She teaches
at the University of North Carolina at Chapel
Hill, and she has been teaching calculus two
for many years to undergraduate students,
we recommend using a paper and pencil so you
can follow along at home. Let's start.
Hi, I'm Beau with Free Code Camp. This course
is taught by Dr. Linda green. She teaches
at the University of North Carolina at Chapel
Hill, and she has been teaching calculus two
for many years to undergraduate students,
we recommend using a paper and pencil so you
can follow along at home. Let's start.
This video introduces the idea of finding
the area between two curves. Let's start with
some review. in calculus one, you approximate
the area between a curve and the x axis by
dividing it up into tall skinny rectangles.
You represented the width of one of these
rectangles using the symbols delta x, here
delta x means a small distance along the x
axis or a small change in x values. You picked
out an x value called a sample point from
each of these little sub intervals along the
x axis, one sample point for each rectangle.
The sample point on the x axis for rectangle
number i is denoted by x i star. You use the
sample points and the function f to figure
out the height of each rectangle. The height
of rectangle number i is given by the functions
value on the sample point f of x star. From
this, you calculate the area of each rectangle,
the area of a rectangle is base times height.
So the area of the first rectangle is delta
x times f of x one star, the area of the second
rectangle is delta x times f of x two star.
And the area of rectangle number i is going
to be its base delta x times its height, f
of x i star, and so on, if there are n rectangles,
than the last rectangle will have base delta
x and height f of x and star. So the approximate
area under the curve is given by adding up
all these areas of all these rectangles. In
sigma notation, this can be written as sigma,
the psalm from i equals one to n, the number
of rectangles of the area of the rectangle,
delta x times f of x i star. The exact area
is then given by the limit of these approximating
areas, as the number of rectangles goes to
infinity. That's the limit as n goes to infinity
of this
Riemann sum
This video introduces the idea of finding
the area between two curves. Let's start with
some review. in calculus one, you approximate
the area between a curve and the x axis by
dividing it up into tall skinny rectangles.
You represented the width of one of these
rectangles using the symbols delta x, here
delta x means a small distance along the x
axis or a small change in x values. You picked
out an x value called a sample point from
each of these little sub intervals along the
x axis, one sample point for each rectangle.
The sample point on the x axis for rectangle
number i is denoted by x i star. You use the
sample points and the function f to figure
out the height of each rectangle. The height
of rectangle number i is given by the functions
value on the sample point f of x star. From
this, you calculate the area of each rectangle,
the area of a rectangle is base times height.
So the area of the first rectangle is delta
x times f of x one star, the area of the second
rectangle is delta x times f of x two star.
And the area of rectangle number i is going
to be its base delta x times its height, f
of x i star, and so on, if there are n rectangles,
than the last rectangle will have base delta
x and height f of x and star. So the approximate
area under the curve is given by adding up
all these areas of all these rectangles. In
sigma notation, this can be written as sigma,
the psalm from i equals one to n, the number
of rectangles of the area of the rectangle,
delta x times f of x i star. The exact area
is then given by the limit of these approximating
areas, as the number of rectangles goes to
infinity. That's the limit as n goes to infinity
of this Riemann sum
of areas.
A limit of a Riemann sum like this is by definition,
an integral. So we can rewrite this using
the integral sign as the integral of f of
x dx. And the bounds of integration here,
based on our picture are from x equals a 2x
equals b. Notice that when we convert the
limit of a Riemann sum to integral notation,
the sample points x vystar just become our
variable x, and the delta x becomes our dx.
Now that we've reviewed these ideas of calculating
the area under a curve, we're going to use
these same ideas to calculate the area between
two curves. To compute the area between two
curves, y equals f of x and y equals g of
x, in between the x values of a and b, we
can again divide up the region and a tall
skinny rectangles as shown in this picture.
Once again, let's let delta x be the width
of each rectangle. And let's let x i star
represent a sample point in the ife interval.
So x sub i star is a point on the x axis that
lives in the rectangle number i. Now if we
want to compute the area of one of these tall
skinny rectangles, as always, the area of
a rectangle is the base times the height.
The base of any of these rectangles is given
by delta x. But the height is different for
each rectangle. If I focus on in on rectangle
number, I assume this is rectangle number
i right here. It stretches all the way up
to F of the sample point f of x by star and
it stretches all the way down. To add g of
that x, y star. So the height of that rectangle
is the gap between f of x and g of x at that
sample point. In other words, it's the difference,
f of x sub i star minus g of x, y star. Now
that we have an expression for the area of
one of these rectangles, we can add up all
those areas as before, to get an expression
for the approximate area between the curves,
it's just the sum of these areas. And as before,
we can get the exact area. By making these
rectangles skinnier and skinnier. By taking
more of them, we take the limit as the number
of rectangles goes to infinity of this Riemann
sum. And as always, the limit of a Riemann
sum is given by the integral where the exabyte
stars a sample points just become our variable
x, and the delta x becomes our dx, let's put
in our bounds of integration, we're told that
x goes between A and B, and we have an expression
for the area between our two curves. Actually,
this formula only works if f of x is greater
than or equal to g of x on the interval from
a to b. That inequality guarantees that this
expression, f of x i star minus g of x i star
will be a positive number, we want a positive
height for our rectangle, so that will get
a positive area. If instead, f of x is less
than or equal to g of x, then you'll need
to switch around your subtraction and take
the integral of g of x minus f of x dx instead,
in order to get a positive area. One way to
remember what to do is just to write the integral
as the integral from a to b of the top y value
minus the bottom y value, dx. Remembering
that you'll need to replace the top y value
and the bottom y value with functions of x
before you can integrate.
A limit of a Riemann sum like this is by definition,
an integral. So we can rewrite this using
the integral sign as the integral of f of
x dx. And the bounds of integration here,
based on our picture are from x equals a 2x
equals b. Notice that when we convert the
limit of a Riemann sum to integral notation,
the sample points x vystar just become our
variable x, and the delta x becomes our dx.
Now that we've reviewed these ideas of calculating
the area under a curve, we're going to use
these same ideas to calculate the area between
two curves. To compute the area between two
curves, y equals f of x and y equals g of
x, in between the x values of a and b, we
can again divide up the region and a tall
skinny rectangles as shown in this picture.
Once again, let's let delta x be the width
of each rectangle. And let's let x i star
represent a sample point in the ife interval.
So x sub i star is a point on the x axis that
lives in the rectangle number i. Now if we
want to compute the area of one of these tall
skinny rectangles, as always, the area of
a rectangle is the base times the height.
The base of any of these rectangles is given
by delta x. But the height is different for
each rectangle. If I focus on in on rectangle
number, I assume this is rectangle number
i right here. It stretches all the way up
to F of the sample point f of x by star and
it stretches all the way down. To add g of
that x, y star. So the height of that rectangle
is the gap between f of x and g of x at that
sample point. In other words, it's the difference,
f of x sub i star minus g of x, y star. Now
that we have an expression for the area of
one of these rectangles, we can add up all
those areas as before, to get an expression
for the approximate area between the curves,
it's just the sum of these areas. And as before,
we can get the exact area. By making these
rectangles skinnier and skinnier. By taking
more of them, we take the limit as the number
of rectangles goes to infinity of this Riemann
sum. And as always, the limit of a Riemann
sum is given by the integral where the exabyte
stars a sample points just become our variable
x, and the delta x becomes our dx, let's put
in our bounds of integration, we're told that
x goes between A and B, and we have an expression
for the area between our two curves. Actually,
this formula only works if f of x is greater
than or equal to g of x on the interval from
a to b. That inequality guarantees that this
expression, f of x i star minus g of x i star
will be a positive number, we want a positive
height for our rectangle, so that will get
a positive area. If instead, f of x is less
than or equal to g of x, then you'll need
to switch around your subtraction and take
the integral of g of x minus f of x dx instead,
in order to get a positive area. One way to
remember what to do is just to write the integral
as the integral from a to b of the top y value
minus the bottom y value, dx. Remembering
that you'll need to replace the top y value
and the bottom y value with functions of x
before you can integrate.
Let's look at an example. We want to find
the area between the curve y equals x squared
plus x and y equals three minus x squared.
x squared plus x is a parabola pointing upwards.
So that must be the red curve here, while
three minus x squared is a parabola pointing
downwards. So that must be this blue curve.
We know that area is given by the integral
from our starting x value to our ending x
value of our top y values minus our bottom
y values, all integrated with respect to x,
our top y values are given by the equation
three minus x squared, and our bottom y values
are given by the equation x squared plus x.
Now we still need to figure out the values
of a and b, the bounds of integration. And
from the graph, it looks like a should be
maybe about negative one and a half, and B
should be about one, since that's where the
green area starts and ends in the horizontal
direction. But to find exact values of a and
b, the easiest thing to do is to set these
two equations equal to each other and solve
for x. So I'll set three minus x squared equal
to x squared plus x, I can add x squared to
both sides to get to x squared plus x minus
three equals zero. This factors into 2x plus
three, and x minus one, and therefore x has
to equal negative three halves and or x equals
one, just like we thought from the graph.
So we can finish doing our setup, our bounds
of integration are from negative three halves
to one, and I can simplify my integrand here.
This is three minus x squared minus x squared
minus x. Or in other words, the integral from
negative three halves to one of minus 2x squared
minus x plus three dx. This integrates to
minus 2x cubed over three my minus x squared
over two plus 3x, evaluated between one and
negative three halves. Now I just need to
plug in my bounds of integration and then
simplify to get 125 20 fourths as the area.
Let's look at an example. We want to find
the area between the curve y equals x squared
plus x and y equals three minus x squared.
x squared plus x is a parabola pointing upwards.
So that must be the red curve here, while
three minus x squared is a parabola pointing
downwards. So that must be this blue curve.
We know that area is given by the integral
from our starting x value to our ending x
value of our top y values minus our bottom
y values, all integrated with respect to x,
our top y values are given by the equation
three minus x squared, and our bottom y values
are given by the equation x squared plus x.
Now we still need to figure out the values
of a and b, the bounds of integration. And
from the graph, it looks like a should be
maybe about negative one and a half, and B
should be about one, since that's where the
green area starts and ends in the horizontal
direction. But to find exact values of a and
b, the easiest thing to do is to set these
two equations equal to each other and solve
for x. So I'll set three minus x squared equal
to x squared plus x, I can add x squared to
both sides to get to x squared plus x minus
three equals zero. This factors into 2x plus
three, and x minus one, and therefore x has
to equal negative three halves and or x equals
one, just like we thought from the graph.
So we can finish doing our setup, our bounds
of integration are from negative three halves
to one, and I can simplify my integrand here.
This is three minus x squared minus x squared
minus x. Or in other words, the integral from
negative three halves to one of minus 2x squared
minus x plus three dx. This integrates to
minus 2x cubed over three my minus x squared
over two plus 3x, evaluated between one and
negative three halves. Now I just need to
plug in my bounds of integration and then
simplify to get 125 20 fourths as the area.
In this video, we saw that the area between
two curves in between the x values of a and
b can be given by the integral from a to b
have the top y values minus the bottom y values.
dx, were the top y values and bottom y values
are functions of x. More specifically, if
the top curve is given by y equals f of x,
and the bottom curve is y equals g of x, then
this integral is the integral from a to b
of f of x minus g of x, dx. In this video,
we'll calculate the volumes of solids of revolution.
A solid of revolution is a three dimensional
object that can be formed by rotating a region
of the plane around an axis. volumes formed
by rotating a region of the plane around a
line are called solids of revolution. In this
figure on the left, this three dimensional
object is formed by rotating a region of the
plane shaped like this, around the x axis,
the solid on the right can be formed by rotating
a crescent shaped region of the plane like
this, again, around the x axis. If we slice
these two solids of revolution, using planes
perpendicular to the x axis, on the left side,
our cross sections look like disks.
In this video, we saw that the area between
two curves in between the x values of a and
b can be given by the integral from a to b
have the top y values minus the bottom y values.
dx, were the top y values and bottom y values
are functions of x. More specifically, if
the top curve is given by y equals f of x,
and the bottom curve is y equals g of x, then
this integral is the integral from a to b
of f of x minus g of x, dx. In this video,
we'll calculate the volumes of solids of revolution.
A solid of revolution is a three dimensional
object that can be formed by rotating a region
of the plane around an axis. volumes formed
by rotating a region of the plane around a
line are called solids of revolution. In this
figure on the left, this three dimensional
object is formed by rotating a region of the
plane shaped like this, around the x axis,
the solid on the right can be formed by rotating
a crescent shaped region of the plane like
this, again, around the x axis. If we slice
these two solids of revolution, using planes
perpendicular to the x axis, on the left side,
our cross sections look like disks.
A disc here means the inside of a circle.
The figure on the right is different because
it's hollow inside. And when we slice it by
planes perpendicular to the x axis, we get
cross sections that are shaped like washers.
A washer here means the region in between
two concentric circles. So for solids of revolution,
the cross sections can have the shape of a
disk, or the shape of a washer. The area of
a disk is given by the familiar formula, pi
r squared, where r is the radius. And the
area of a washer can be written as pi times
r outer squared minus pi times our inner squared,
where our outer is the radius of the big circle,
and our inner is the radius of the little
circle. This formula works because the area
of the washer is just the area of the larger
circle minus the area of the inside smaller
circle. Now we know that the volume of any
solid that can be sliced into cross sections
using planes perpendicular to the x axis is
given by v is the integral from x equals a
to x equals B of the area of the cross section
at point x, integrated dx. If our cross sections
are disks, this formula becomes the integral
of pi r squared dx, where the radius R is
a function of x. If instead, the cross sections
look like washers, then the volume formula
becomes the integral of pi r outer squared
minus pi r inner squared dx. Again, our outer
and our inner are functions of x here. These
formulas work when they solid a revolution
is formed by rotating a region around the
x axis or any horizontal line. When we rotate
around a horizontal line, then our cross sectional
discs or washers are perpendicular to the
x axis and are thin in the x direction. So
it makes sense to integrate dx. If instead,
we want to rotate around the y axis or a vertical
line, then our disk or wash our cross sections
are going to be perpendicular to the y axis
and are going to be thin in the y direction.
So when rotating around the y axis or a vertical
line, we'll need to do our integral with respect
to y. Our cross sectional area will be a function
of y will integrate d y and our bounds of
integration will have to be Y values, our
formulas will look pretty much the same. We'll
just have to calculate our Radia and bounds
of integration in terms of y instead of x.
As our first example, let's consider the region
bounded by the curve y equals a cube root
of x, the x axis and the line x equals eight.
We want to find the volume of the solid of
revolution found by rotating this region around
the x axis. or cross sections here are going
to be discs. And these discs are thin in the
extraction. So we're going to be integrating
dx, our smallest x value is zero, and our
largest is eight. So those are our bounds
of integration. And we want to integrate pi
times the radius squared dx. Now the radius
of our disks is given by the y coordinate
on this curve. So we can write r is equal
to y, which is equal to the cube root of x
according to our equation. So we can rewrite
the volume as the integral from zero to eight
of pi times the cube root of x squared dx,
I can pull out the PI and rewrite this integral
using exponents and integrate and then evaluate
using bounds of integration to get three fifths
pi times eight to the five thirds minus zero.
Now, eight to the five thirds means eight
to the 1/3 raised to the fifth power, eight
to the 1/3 is two and two to the fifth is
32. So this expression simplifies to three
fifths pi times 32, or 96/5
A disc here means the inside of a circle.
The figure on the right is different because
it's hollow inside. And when we slice it by
planes perpendicular to the x axis, we get
cross sections that are shaped like washers.
A washer here means the region in between
two concentric circles. So for solids of revolution,
the cross sections can have the shape of a
disk, or the shape of a washer. The area of
a disk is given by the familiar formula, pi
r squared, where r is the radius. And the
area of a washer can be written as pi times
r outer squared minus pi times our inner squared,
where our outer is the radius of the big circle,
and our inner is the radius of the little
circle. This formula works because the area
of the washer is just the area of the larger
circle minus the area of the inside smaller
circle. Now we know that the volume of any
solid that can be sliced into cross sections
using planes perpendicular to the x axis is
given by v is the integral from x equals a
to x equals B of the area of the cross section
at point x, integrated dx. If our cross sections
are disks, this formula becomes the integral
of pi r squared dx, where the radius R is
a function of x. If instead, the cross sections
look like washers, then the volume formula
becomes the integral of pi r outer squared
minus pi r inner squared dx. Again, our outer
and our inner are functions of x here. These
formulas work when they solid a revolution
is formed by rotating a region around the
x axis or any horizontal line. When we rotate
around a horizontal line, then our cross sectional
discs or washers are perpendicular to the
x axis and are thin in
the x direction. So it makes sense to integrate
dx. If instead, we want to rotate around the
y axis or a vertical line, then our disk or
wash our cross sections are going to be perpendicular
to the y axis and are going to be thin in
the y direction. So when rotating around the
y axis or a vertical line, we'll need to do
our integral with respect to y. Our cross
sectional area will be a function of y will
integrate d y and our bounds of integration
will have to be Y values, our formulas will
look pretty much the same. We'll just have
to calculate our Radia and bounds of integration
in terms of y instead of x. As our first example,
let's consider the region bounded by the curve
y equals a cube root of x, the x axis and
the line x equals eight. We want to find the
volume of the solid of revolution found by
rotating this region around the x axis. or
cross sections here are going to be discs.
And these discs are thin in the extraction.
So we're going to be integrating dx, our smallest
x value is zero, and our largest is eight.
So those are our bounds of integration. And
we want to integrate pi times the radius squared
dx. Now the radius of our disks is given by
the y coordinate on this curve. So we can
write r is equal to y, which is equal to the
cube root of x according to our equation.
So we can rewrite the volume as the integral
from zero to eight of pi times the cube root
of x squared dx, I can pull out the PI and
rewrite this integral using exponents and
integrate and then evaluate using bounds of
integration to get three fifths pi times eight
to the five thirds minus zero. Now, eight
to the five thirds means eight to the 1/3
raised to the fifth power, eight to the 1/3
is two and two to the fifth is 32. So this
expression simplifies to three fifths pi times
32, or 96/5
pie.
As our next example, let's consider the region
in the first quadrant bounded by two curves,
the curve y equals the cube root of x and
y equals 1/4 times x. We'll start by rotating
this region around the x axis to get this
sort of hollow base shape. Notice that our
cross sections this time are shaped like washers,
where the outer circle of the washer is swept
out by the curve y equals cube root of x,
and the inner circle is swept out by the curve
y equals 1/4 X. We know our volume is given
by the integral of pi times our outer squared
minus pi times our inner squared. And since
our washers are thin in the x direction, we
know we'll need to integrate dx, our bounds
of integration are just our lowest x value
of zero, and our largest x value, which is
where these two curves intersect, which is
an x value of eight. We can confirm that the
two curves intersect when x equals eight by
setting them equal to each other. And solving
for x, dividing both sides by x to the 1/3.
And multiplying both sides by four gives us
four equals x to the two thirds. And raising
both sides to the three halves power gives
us x equals four to three halves, or x equals
eight.
As our next example, let's consider the region
in the first quadrant bounded by two curves,
the curve y equals the cube root of x and
y equals 1/4 times x. We'll start by rotating
this region around the x axis to get this
sort of hollow base shape. Notice that our
cross sections this time are shaped like washers,
where the outer circle of the washer is swept
out by the curve y equals cube root of x,
and the inner circle is swept out by the curve
y equals 1/4 X. We know our volume is given
by the integral of pi times our outer squared
minus pi times our inner squared. And since
our washers are thin in the x direction, we
know we'll need to integrate dx, our bounds
of integration are just our lowest x value
of zero, and our largest x value, which is
where these two curves intersect, which is
an x value of eight. We can confirm that the
two curves intersect when x equals eight by
setting them equal to each other. And solving
for x, dividing both sides by x to the 1/3.
And multiplying both sides by four gives us
four equals x to the two thirds. And raising
both sides to the three halves power gives
us x equals four to three halves, or x equals
eight.
This confirms we have the correct bound of
integration here. Now we need to figure out
a formula for the outer radius as a function
of x and a formula for the inner radius. Also,
This confirms we have the correct bound of
integration here. Now we need to figure out
a formula for the outer radius as a function
of x and a formula for the inner radius. Also,
since the outer circle is swept out by the
curve y equals cube root of x, the outer radius
is just given by the y coordinate of this
curve as a function of x, that's the cube
root of x. Now the inner radius is given by
the y coordinate of this line, and the y coordinate
of this line as a function of x is 1/4 x.
So we set up an equation for the volume of
our solid and I routine computation gives
us a volume of 128 fifteenth's times pi. Now
let's switch gears and rotate this region
around the y axis instead. Our cross sections
are still washers, but this time the washers
are thin in the y direction. So we're going
to be integrating with respect to y. Our bounds
of integration are also y values and start
at the minimum y value of zero and the maximum
Y value of two, that corresponds to this intersection,
where x equals eight, and y, which is the
cube root of x, or 1/4 times x is then equal
to two. For this problem, we need our our
outer and our inner to the functions of y.
From the picture, we see that our outer is
actually the x coordinate on this line. The
line has the equation y equals 1/4 x. And
so x is equal to four y. So that gives us
our outer as a function of y. defined our
inner, we can do the same sort of thing using
the x coordinate of the curve, y equals cube
root of x. But writing that x coordinate in
terms of y, we have y equals the cube root
of x means that x is equal to y cubed. And
so our inner is equal to y cubed as a function
of y. putting this all together, we have an
equation for volume. We can simplify this
and integrate to get an answer of 512 pi over
21. In this video, we calculated the volumes
of solids of revolution, using the disk and
the washer methods, and the following formulas.
One way to calculate the volume of a loaf
of bread is to slice it into slices, and calculate
the volume of each slice separately. That's
the idea to keep in mind as we cover this
topic, on volumes using cross sections. A
lot of three dimensional objects are kind
of like loaves of bread, and can be naturally
sliced into slabs or slices like this. Let's
suppose we've sliced our object into n slabs,
we'll call them s one s two through sn in
this picture, and is seven, here's s one,
here's s two, here's s3, and so on, we'll
assume we've sliced in such a way that each
slice is the same thickness, we'll call that
thickness delta x. Well, the volume of the
solid is just the sum of the volumes of the
slices. And sigma notation, we can write this
as the sum from i equals one to n, the number
of slabs volume of s by the I slab. Now the
volume of the slab is approximately its cross
sectional area times its width. By cross sectional
area of the slab, I mean the area of the front
or the back part of the slice, where you might
spread peanut butter. Well, now, as you've
noticed from making peanut butter sandwiches,
the area of the front of the slice might be
slightly different from the area of the back
of the slice. So what we'll do is for each
interval, I, each slab will just pick a sample
point x vystar, that's in that I've interval,
it could be on the left endpoint, or it could
be on the right endpoint, or it could be in
the middle somewhere. And we'll just look
at the cross sectional area, I'll call it
a at x, y star that represents the area if
I were to go karate chop right at that x y
star and figure out the cross sectional area
at that point.
since the outer circle is swept out by the
curve y equals cube root of x, the outer radius
is just given by the y coordinate of this
curve as a function of x, that's the cube
root of x. Now the inner radius is given by
the y coordinate of this line, and the y coordinate
of this line as a function of x is 1/4 x.
So we set up an equation for the volume of
our solid and I routine computation gives
us a volume of 128 fifteenth's times pi. Now
let's switch gears and rotate this region
around the y axis instead. Our cross sections
are still washers, but this time the washers
are thin in the y direction. So we're going
to be integrating with respect to y. Our bounds
of integration are also y values and start
at the minimum y value of zero and the maximum
Y value of two, that corresponds to this intersection,
where x equals eight, and y, which is the
cube root of x, or 1/4 times x is then equal
to two. For this problem, we need our our
outer and our inner to the functions of y.
From the picture, we see that our outer is
actually the x coordinate on this line. The
line has the equation y equals 1/4 x. And
so x is equal to four y. So that gives us
our outer as a function of y. defined our
inner, we can do the same sort of thing using
the x coordinate of the curve, y equals cube
root of x. But writing that x coordinate in
terms of y, we have y equals the cube root
of x means that x is equal to y cubed. And
so our inner is equal to y cubed as a function
of y. putting this all together, we have an
equation for volume. We can simplify this
and integrate to get an answer of 512 pi over
21. In this video, we calculated the volumes
of solids of revolution, using the disk and
the washer methods, and the following formulas.
One way to calculate the volume of a loaf
of bread is to slice it into slices, and calculate
the volume of each slice separately. That's
the idea to keep in mind as we cover this
topic, on volumes using cross sections. A
lot of three dimensional objects are kind
of like loaves of bread, and can be naturally
sliced into slabs or slices like this. Let's
suppose we've sliced our object into n slabs,
we'll call them s one s two through sn in
this picture, and is seven, here's s one,
here's s two, here's s3, and so on, we'll
assume we've sliced in such a way that each
slice is the same thickness, we'll call that
thickness delta x. Well, the volume of the
solid is just the sum of the volumes of the
slices. And sigma notation, we can write this
as the sum from i equals one to n, the number
of slabs volume of s by the I slab. Now the
volume of the slab is approximately its cross
sectional area times its width. By cross sectional
area of the slab, I mean the area of the front
or the back part of the slice, where you might
spread peanut butter. Well, now, as you've
noticed from making peanut butter sandwiches,
the area of the front of the slice might be
slightly different from the area of the back
of the slice. So what we'll do is for each
interval, I, each slab will just pick a sample
point x vystar, that's in that I've interval,
it could be on the left endpoint, or it could
be on the right endpoint, or it could be in
the middle somewhere. And we'll just look
at the cross sectional area, I'll call it
a at x, y star that represents the area if
I were to go karate chop right at that x y
star and figure out the cross sectional area
at that point.
Now we can go back and write our volume as
the cross sectional area at x star times delta
x the thickness of the slice. Now this is
just an approximation of volume, because this
expression here gives you the volume as if
the slices are very regular, and have the
same area from one side to the other. But
it's a good approximation if the slices are
thin. And in fact, we can calculate the exact
volume by taking the limit as the slices get
thinner and thinner. Or in other words, as
the number of slices goes to infinity. What
we have here is the limit of a Riemann sum.
And therefore, we can rewrite it as an integral
where the x i star becomes our variable x
and the delta x becomes r dx. For the bounds
of integration, we'll just use the abstract
x values of a and b for a real problem. We
would fill these in based on In the context
of the problem, this gives us an abstract
expression for the volume of a three dimensional
object. But in practice, in order to compute
volumes like this, we'll first need a formula
for a of x, the cross sectional area as a
function of x. As an example, let's try to
find the volume of a solid whose base is an
ellipse given by this equation, and whose
cross sections perpendicular to the x axis
are squares. First, let me graph the base,
it looks like an ellipse that's thinner in
the extraction than in the y direction. So
something like this. Now sitting above this
base, are a bunch of squares. And the squares
are oriented in such a way that they're perpendicular
to the x axis. So they're oriented sort of
like this, I'll try to draw a square here,
that's supposed to be coming out of the picture
here. And here's another square, again, coming
out of the picture. Here's a slightly better
picture that I drew using Mathematica. It's
tilted. So we're looking at it from below,
where you can see the ellipse here. And you
can see the square cross sections, the x axis
is going in this direction, that's x and the
y axis is in that direction. This picture
is actually an approximation of the solid,
where they're only about eight or 10 slices,
each one's kind of sick and has the same area
on the front and the back. better picture
of the solid is this one. Here, the slices
are infinitely thin, but they're still square
shaped. And they're still oriented in such
a way that they're perpendicular to the x
axis. Now we know that volume is given by
the integral from a to b of area as a function
of x dx. On our lips, the minimum x value
is negative two, and the maximum x value is
two. So I can write those in for my bounds
of integration. Also, I know that the area
of a square is just the side length squared.
So I can write my cross sectional area as
s of x squared, where s of x is the side length
of the square as a function of x. Notice that
for different x values, my side lengths are
different. But my side length is always twice
the y value twice the distance from the x
axis to the y value on the ellipse. So I'll
rewrite my formula as two times y as a function
of x squared. I can simplify this a little
bit as the integral of four times y of x squared,
dx. Now all I need to do is find a formula
for y as a function of x. And since I've got
this equation up here, relating y and x, all
I have to do is solve for y in terms of x.
In fact, I can get by solving for y squared,
since I've really got y squared in my formula.
solving for y squared, I have y squared over
nine is equal to one minus x squared over
four, which means that y squared is equal
to nine times one minus x squared
Now we can go back and write our volume as
the cross sectional area at x star times delta
x the thickness of the slice. Now this is
just an approximation of volume, because this
expression here gives you the volume as if
the slices are very regular, and have the
same area from one side to the other. But
it's a good approximation if the slices are
thin. And in fact, we can calculate the exact
volume by taking the limit as the slices get
thinner and thinner. Or in other words, as
the number of slices goes to infinity. What
we have here is the limit of a Riemann sum.
And therefore, we can rewrite it as an integral
where the x i star becomes our variable x
and the delta x becomes r dx. For the bounds
of integration, we'll just use the abstract
x values of a and b for a real problem. We
would fill these in based on In the context
of the problem, this gives us an abstract
expression for the volume of a three dimensional
object. But in practice, in order to compute
volumes like this, we'll first need a formula
for a of x, the cross sectional area as a
function of x. As an example, let's try to
find the volume of a solid whose base is an
ellipse given by this equation, and whose
cross sections perpendicular to the x axis
are squares. First, let me graph the base,
it looks like an ellipse that's thinner in
the extraction than in the y direction. So
something like this. Now sitting above this
base, are a bunch of squares. And the squares
are oriented in such a way that they're perpendicular
to the x axis. So they're oriented sort of
like this, I'll try to draw a square here,
that's supposed to be coming out of the picture
here. And here's another square, again, coming
out of the picture. Here's a slightly better
picture that I drew using Mathematica. It's
tilted. So we're looking at it from below,
where you can see the ellipse here. And you
can see the square cross sections, the x axis
is going in this direction, that's x and the
y axis is in that direction. This picture
is actually an approximation of the solid,
where they're only about eight or 10 slices,
each one's kind of sick and has the same area
on the front and the back. better picture
of the solid is this one. Here, the slices
are infinitely thin, but they're still square
shaped. And they're still oriented in such
a way that they're perpendicular to the x
axis. Now we know that volume is given by
the integral from a to b of area as a function
of x dx. On our lips, the minimum x value
is negative two, and the maximum x value is
two. So I can write those in for my bounds
of integration. Also, I know that the area
of a square is just the side length squared.
So I can write my cross sectional area as
s of x squared, where s of x is the side length
of the square as a function of x. Notice that
for different x values, my side lengths are
different. But my side length is always twice
the y value twice the distance from the x
axis to the y value on the ellipse. So I'll
rewrite my formula as two times y as a function
of x squared. I can simplify this a little
bit as the integral of four times y of x squared,
dx. Now all I need to do is find a formula
for y as a function of x. And since I've got
this equation up here, relating y and x, all
I have to do is solve for y in terms of x.
In fact, I can get by solving for y squared,
since I've really got y squared in my formula.
solving for y squared, I have y squared over
nine is equal to one minus x squared over
four, which means that y squared is equal
to nine times one minus x squared
over four.
Now I plug this into my volume equation. And
I get the integral from negative two to four
times nine, one minus x squared over four
dx. I'll pull out the four times nine that's
36. and integrate. Plugging in values and
simplifying, we get a final answer of 96.
Now, how would this problem be different if
we used cross sections that were perpendicular
to the y axis instead of the x axis? Well,
for one thing, our picture would look a little
bit different. Since our squares would now
be running in the other direction. Since our
squares are now fin in the y direction, instead
of the extraction, it makes sense to have
the width of a slab B delta y, and to compute
our volume as an integral with respect to
y. Our bounds of integration now and they
also need to be Y values. So they run from
the minimum y value of negative three to the
maximum y value of three. And our cross sectional
area should also be written in terms of y.
area is still side length squared. But now
our side length is actually twice our x value,
instead of twice our y value. And we can write
our x value squared in terms of our y value
as four times one minus y squared over nine.
Therefore, our area, which is our side length
squared, which is 2x, quantity squared, or
4x squared, is going to be equal to 16 times
one minus y squared over nine, we'll need
to calculate our volume by taking the integral
from negative three to three of 16 times one
minus y squared over nine d y. If we integrate
this, we get an answer of 64. a different
answer from the answer to our first problem,
and it makes sense that we get a different
answer, because we now have a different three
dimensional object with a different shape
and a different volume. In this video, we
saw that if we divided three dimensional objects
into slices, then the volume of the three
dimensional object is the integral of the
cross sectional area, dx. In this video, I'll
derive a formula to calculate the length of
a curve given as a function y equals f of
x. For a curve like this one that's made up
of a bunch of straight line segments, it's
easy to calculate the length just by using
the distance formula to find the length of
each line segment. The distance formula says
the distance between two points x one, y one,
and x two, y two is given by the square root
of x two minus x one squared plus y two minus
y one squared. Applying this formula to the
first line segment, connecting the points
one, two, and two, three, we get a length
of the square root of two minus one squared
plus three minus two squared, which is the
square root of two, the length of the next
line segment can be calculated similarly,
and the next piece has length two, we don't
even need the distance formula for that one.
And the last line segment has a length of
the square to five. If we add up all the lengths
of these four line segments, we get a total
length of the curve of two times the square
root of five, plus the square root of two
plus two,
Now I plug this into my volume equation. And
I get the integral from negative two to four
times nine, one minus x squared over four
dx. I'll pull out the four times nine that's
36. and integrate. Plugging in values and
simplifying, we get a final answer of 96.
Now, how would this problem be different if
we used cross sections that were perpendicular
to the y axis instead of the x axis? Well,
for one thing, our picture would look a little
bit different. Since our squares would now
be running in the other direction. Since our
squares are now fin in the y direction, instead
of the extraction, it makes sense to have
the width of a slab B delta y, and to compute
our volume as an integral with respect to
y. Our bounds of integration now and they
also need to be Y values. So they run from
the minimum y value of negative three to the
maximum y value of three. And our cross sectional
area should also be written in terms of y.
area is still side length squared. But now
our side length is actually twice our x value,
instead of twice our y value. And we can write
our x value squared in terms of our y value
as four times one minus y squared over nine.
Therefore, our area, which is our side length
squared, which is 2x, quantity squared, or
4x squared, is going to be equal to 16 times
one minus y squared over nine, we'll need
to calculate our volume by taking the integral
from negative three to three of 16 times one
minus y squared over nine d y. If we integrate
this, we get an answer of 64. a different
answer from the answer to our first problem,
and it makes sense that we get a different
answer, because we now have a different three
dimensional object with a different shape
and a different volume. In this video, we
saw that if we divided three dimensional objects
into slices, then the volume of the three
dimensional object is the integral of the
cross sectional area, dx. In this video, I'll
derive a formula to calculate the length of
a curve given as a function y equals f of
x. For a curve like this one that's made up
of a bunch of straight line segments, it's
easy to calculate the length just by using
the distance formula to find the length of
each line segment. The distance formula says
the distance between two points x one, y one,
and x two, y two is given by the square root
of x two minus x one squared plus y two minus
y one squared. Applying this formula to the
first line segment, connecting the points
one, two, and two, three, we get a length
of the square root of two minus one squared
plus three minus two squared, which is the
square root of two, the length of the next
line segment can be calculated similarly,
and the next piece has length two, we don't
even need the distance formula for that one.
And the last line segment has a length of
the square to five. If we add up all the lengths
of these four line segments, we get a total
length of the curve of two times the square
root of five, plus the square root of two
plus two,
we can use the same process to approximate
the length of any curve by dividing it up
into n small pieces, and approximate the length
of one small curved piece with a straight
line segment. And using the distance formula
to calculate the length of these line segments,
in this picture, the curve is divided up into
nine sub intervals. I'll label the corresponding
points on the x axis, x zero for a x 1x, two,
all the way through x eight and x nine is
B. And I can label the points on my curve.
So here's the sixth point P six has x coordinates
xx, and then y coordinate will be f of x x,
since my curve is given by the equation y
equals f of x. More generally, I have N sub
intervals. And I'll label an arbitrary point
piece of I. The point before it is then a
piece of i minus one. And the length of the
ice segment is given by the distance between
P sub i and P sub i minus one. So that's the
square root of x sub i minus x sub i minus
one squared plus f of x sub i minus f of x
sub i minus one squared by the distance formula.
The total length of the curve can be approximated
by adding the lengths of all these line segments
up. So that's the sum from i equals one to
N for the N line segments of these lengths.
This is starting to look a little bit like
a Riemann sum because of the Sigma sign, but
it's missing the delta x That I usually have
out here. So I'm going to use a trick, I'm
going to multiply each term of this expression
by x sub i minus x sub i minus one divided
by x sub i minus x sub i minus one. This doesn't
change the value of my expression, but it
does introduce a delta x over delta x into
my equation, because delta x represents the
width of a sub interval. And that's equal
to x by minus x, y minus one, I'm going to
suck the factor in the denominator inside
the square root sign, notice I have to square
it, when I pull it inside the square root
sign. Now I'm going to rewrite my fraction
inside the square root sign. Now this first
fraction is just one, and the second fraction
can be rewritten with a single squared sign.
And the second expression should look familiar
to you. It's the expression for the slope
of a secant line. At effects, I n x i minus
one are very close to each other, the slope
of that secant line is very close to the slope
of a tangent line for at a point in that interval.
In fact, you might recall that the mean value
theorem says that the slope of the secant
line is actually exactly equal to the slope
of a tangent line. For some point, I'll call
it x i star in that interval. So I'll rewrite
my expression for the approximate length of
the curve. And since x i minus x i minus one
can be written as delta x, I have a Riemann
sum here. So if I want to find the exact arc
length, I just need to take the limit of this
Riemann sum. This is the limit as the number
of intervals goes to infinity. We know that
the limit of a Riemann sum is given by an
integral. So the arc length is given by the
integral of the square root of one plus f
prime of x squared dx, starting from the first
x value of A to the last x value of b. And
so we've derived a formula for arc length.
Sometimes, this formula is also written with
the alternative notation of dydx, instead
of f prime of x. Let's use the arc length
formula to find the length of the curve y
equals x to the three halves between x equals
one and x equals four. That's this section
of the curve drawn.
we can use the same process to approximate
the length of any curve by dividing it up
into n small pieces, and approximate the length
of one small curved piece with a straight
line segment. And using the distance formula
to calculate the length of these line segments,
in this picture, the curve is divided up into
nine sub intervals. I'll label the corresponding
points on the x axis, x zero for a x 1x, two,
all the way through x eight and x nine is
B. And I can label the points on my curve.
So here's the sixth point P six has x coordinates
xx, and then y coordinate will be f of x x,
since my curve is given by the equation y
equals f of x. More generally, I have N sub
intervals. And I'll label an arbitrary point
piece of I. The point before it is then a
piece of i minus one. And the length of the
ice segment is given by the distance between
P sub i and P sub i minus one. So that's the
square root of x sub i minus x sub i minus
one squared plus f of x sub i minus f of x
sub i minus one squared by the distance formula.
The total length of the curve can be approximated
by adding the lengths of all these line segments
up. So that's the sum from i equals one to
N for the N line segments of these lengths.
This is starting to look a little bit like
a Riemann sum because of the Sigma sign, but
it's missing the delta x That I usually have
out here. So I'm going to use a trick, I'm
going to multiply each term of this expression
by x sub i minus x sub i minus one divided
by x sub i minus x sub i minus one. This doesn't
change the value of my expression, but it
does introduce a delta x over delta x into
my equation, because delta x represents the
width of a sub interval. And that's equal
to x by minus x, y minus one, I'm going to
suck the factor in the denominator inside
the square root sign, notice I have to square
it, when I pull it inside the square root
sign. Now I'm going to rewrite my fraction
inside the square root sign. Now this first
fraction is just one, and the second fraction
can be rewritten with a single squared sign.
And the second expression should look familiar
to you. It's the expression for the slope
of a secant line. At effects, I n x i minus
one are very close to each other, the slope
of that secant line is very close to the slope
of a tangent line for at a point in that interval.
In fact, you might recall that the mean value
theorem says that the slope of the secant
line is actually exactly equal to the slope
of a tangent line. For some point, I'll call
it x i star in that interval. So I'll rewrite
my expression for the approximate length of
the curve. And since x i minus x i minus one
can be written as delta x, I have a Riemann
sum here. So if I want to find the exact arc
length, I just need to take the limit of this
Riemann sum. This is the limit as the number
of intervals goes to infinity. We know that
the limit of a Riemann sum is given by an
integral. So the arc length is given by the
integral of the square root of one plus f
prime of x squared dx, starting from the first
x value of A to the last x value of b. And
so we've derived a formula for arc length.
Sometimes, this formula is also written with
the alternative notation of dydx, instead
of f prime of x. Let's use the arc length
formula to find the length of the curve y
equals x to the three halves between x equals
one and x equals four. That's this section
of the curve drawn.
Here's the general formula for arc length.
And since dydx, for our curve is three halves
x to the one half, we get that arc length
is the integral from one to four of the square
root of one plus three halves x to the one
half squared dx. After simplifying a little
bit, we can use use substitution to rewrite
this. So we get the integral from 13 fourths,
to 10 of the square root of u times four ninths
do which integrates to u to the three halves
divided by three halves, times four ninths,
evaluated between 10 and 13 fourths, which
after some computation works out to 1/27 times
at the square root of 10 minus 13, the squared
of 13 or approximately 7.6 units, which seems
about right, based on the graph, taking into
account the fact that this scale here is by
twos on the y axis. In this video, we found
the formula for the arc length of a curve.
If the curve stretches from x equals a to
x equals b, then the arc length is given by
the integral from a to b of the square root
of one plus f prime of x squared dx. This
video introduces the idea of work from physics
and the key role of integration in doing work
calculations. If a constant force f is applied
to move an object a distance d, then the work
done to move the object is defined to be work
equals force times distance, or in symbols,
w equals F times d. The units of force can
be given in metric units, or in bold fashion,
English units. Since force is mass times acceleration,
the units of force are going to be units of
mass, which are kilograms, times units of
acceleration, meters per second squared. This
collection of units is also called a Newton.
In English units, force is given typically,
in terms of pounds. Now the units of work
since work is force times distance, and distance
in metric units is in meters. That gives units
for work of kilograms meters squared per second
squared, or we can write it work as Newton
meters. And these collection of units is also
given its own name, which is the joule. If
we're using English units for work, work again
is force times distance. So the units become
pounds times feet are usually this is written
instead, as a foot pound. Now, if I give you
my weight in pounds, I weigh about 140 pounds.
Those pounds are already and I get it a force.
So that 140 pounds, my weight is also telling
the force of gravity on my body. But if I
tell you instead, that my mass is 63.5 kilograms,
well, that's a unit of mass not a unit of
force. So if I want to know the force, due
to gravity on my body, I'm gonna have to multiply
that 63.5 by the acceleration due to gravity,
which is 9.8 meters per second squared. That
product works out to be 622.3 kilogram meters
per second squared. Notice that we're now
have the right units for force, we could also
say, that's the force of gravity on my body
is 622.3 Newtons.
Here's the general formula for arc length.
And since dydx, for our curve is three halves
x to the one half, we get that arc length
is the integral from one to four of the square
root of one plus three halves x to the one
half squared dx. After simplifying a little
bit, we can use use substitution to rewrite
this. So we get the integral from 13 fourths,
to 10 of the square root of u times four ninths
do which integrates to u to the three halves
divided by three halves, times four ninths,
evaluated between 10 and 13 fourths, which
after some computation works out to 1/27 times
at the square root of 10 minus 13, the squared
of 13 or approximately 7.6 units, which seems
about right, based on the graph, taking into
account the fact that this scale here is by
twos on the y axis. In this video, we found
the formula for the arc length of a curve.
If the curve stretches from x equals a to
x equals b, then the arc length is given by
the integral from a to b of the square root
of one plus f prime of x squared dx. This
video introduces the idea of work from physics
and the key role of integration in doing work
calculations. If a constant force f is applied
to move an object a distance d, then the work
done to move the object is defined to be work
equals force times distance, or in symbols,
w equals F times d. The units of force can
be given in metric units, or in bold fashion,
English units. Since force is mass times acceleration,
the units of force are going to be units of
mass, which are kilograms, times units of
acceleration, meters per second squared. This
collection of units is also called a Newton.
In English units, force is given typically,
in terms of pounds. Now the units of work
since work is force times distance, and distance
in metric units is in meters. That gives units
for work of kilograms meters squared per second
squared, or we can write it work as Newton
meters. And these collection of units is also
given its own name, which is the joule. If
we're using English units for work, work again
is force times distance. So the units become
pounds times feet are usually this is written
instead, as a foot pound. Now, if I give you
my weight in pounds, I weigh about 140 pounds.
Those pounds are already and I get it a force.
So that 140 pounds, my weight is also telling
the force of gravity on my body. But if I
tell you instead, that my mass is 63.5 kilograms,
well, that's a unit of mass not a unit of
force. So if I want to know the force, due
to gravity on my body, I'm gonna have to multiply
that 63.5 by the acceleration due to gravity,
which is 9.8 meters per second squared. That
product works out to be 622.3 kilogram meters
per second squared. Notice that we're now
have the right units for force, we could also
say, that's the force of gravity on my body
is 622.3 Newtons.
Now that we familiarize ourselves with units
a bit, let's do some examples. As our first
example, how much work is done to lift a two
pound book off the floor onto a shelf that's
five feet high? Well, we know that work is
force times distance, and two pounds is already
a unit of force. And distance is five feet.
So the work done is 10 foot pounds. Now let's
do the same problem in metric units. The two
pound book is actually a naught point nine
kilogram book, and we're lifting it off the
floor onto a shelf that's about 1.5 meters
high. Well, work is still force times distance.
But now the force is point nine kilograms
times the acceleration due to gravity 9.8
meters per second squared, times our distance
of 1.5 meters. That gives us a product of
13.23 kilograms meters squared per second
squared, or in other words, 13.23 jewels.
In the previous two examples, force was constant,
so we could just multiply force by distance
to get work. Now let's consider the case where
force is not constant. Let's say a particle
moves along the x axis from a point x equals
a to a point x equals b. According to a force,
F of x, that's a function of x and varies
with x. How much work is done in moving a
particle although the force is not constant,
on the whole interval from a to b, if we divide
up that interval, into a bunch of little sub
intervals, each of width delta x, then on
any particular sub interval The force is going
to be approximately constant, it's not going
to change a whole lot on a tiny little sub
interval. As usual, let's pick a sample point
exabyte star in the eye sub interval for each
little sub interval. exabytes star could be
the left endpoint of the sub interval, the
right endpoint or any point in the middle.
Now, on the AI sub interval, the force is
approximately constant is approximately equal
to f at EXA biostar. Therefore, the work on
that I sub interval is approximately equal
to this constant f x sub i star times the
distance that the particle is going on that
sub interval, that that distance is just the
length of the sub interval delta x. Instead
of thinking of the big picture of the particle
going all the way from A to B, I'm thinking
of it going just along the first sub interval
with the approximately constant force at a
distance of delta x. And then it's going to
go the second sub interval, again, the forces
approximately constant times the distance
of delta x. And then we'll do some more work
getting along the third sub interval, another
proximately, constant force times delta x.
And so on each little tiny bit of the way,
I'll get another little chunk of work. And
then I can get the entire amount of work by
adding all those little chunks of work up.
So the total work done is going to be the
sum from i equals one to n, where n is the
number of sub intervals of the work done on
each sub interval, which is f of x sub i star
times distance delta x. I should say this
is approximately the total work, in order
to get the actual total work, we'll need to
take a limit as we use more and more skinnier
and skinnier subintervals. So the limit as
n goes to infinity of this Riemann sum, the
limit of a Riemann sum is an integral. So
we've got the integral of the force f of x,
dx, and we'll integrate between the minimum
x value of a and the maximum x value of b.
And that's our formula for work.
Now that we familiarize ourselves with units
a bit, let's do some examples. As our first
example, how much work is done to lift a two
pound book off the floor onto a shelf that's
five feet high? Well, we know that work is
force times distance, and two pounds is already
a unit of force. And distance is five feet.
So the work done is 10 foot pounds. Now let's
do the same problem in metric units. The two
pound book is actually a naught point nine
kilogram book, and we're lifting it off the
floor onto a shelf that's about 1.5 meters
high. Well, work is still force times distance.
But now the force is point nine kilograms
times the acceleration due to gravity 9.8
meters per second squared, times our distance
of 1.5 meters. That gives us a product of
13.23 kilograms meters squared per second
squared, or in other words, 13.23 jewels.
In the previous two examples, force was constant,
so we could just multiply force by distance
to get work. Now let's consider the case where
force is not constant. Let's say a particle
moves along the x axis from a point x equals
a to a point x equals b. According to a force,
F of x, that's a function of x and varies
with x. How much work is done in moving a
particle although the force is not constant,
on the whole interval from a to b, if we divide
up that interval, into a bunch of little sub
intervals, each of width delta x, then on
any particular sub interval The force is going
to be approximately constant, it's not going
to change a whole lot on a tiny little sub
interval. As usual, let's pick a sample point
exabyte star in the eye sub interval for each
little sub interval. exabytes star could be
the left endpoint of the sub interval, the
right endpoint or any point in the middle.
Now, on the AI sub interval, the force is
approximately constant is approximately equal
to f at EXA biostar. Therefore, the work on
that I sub interval is approximately equal
to this constant f x sub i star times the
distance that the particle is going on that
sub interval, that that distance is just the
length of the sub interval delta x. Instead
of thinking of the big picture of the particle
going all the way from A to B, I'm thinking
of it going just along the first sub interval
with the approximately constant force at a
distance of delta x. And then it's going to
go the second sub interval, again, the forces
approximately constant times the distance
of delta x. And then we'll do some more work
getting along the third sub interval, another
proximately, constant force times delta x.
And so on each little tiny bit of the way,
I'll get another little chunk of work. And
then I can get the entire amount of work by
adding all those little chunks of work up.
So the total work done is going to be the
sum from i equals one to n, where n is the
number of sub intervals of the work done on
each sub interval, which is f of x sub i star
times distance delta x. I should say this
is approximately the total work, in order
to get the actual total work, we'll need to
take a limit as we use more and more skinnier
and skinnier subintervals. So the limit as
n goes to infinity of this Riemann sum, the
limit of a Riemann sum is an integral. So
we've got the integral of the force f of x,
dx, and we'll integrate between the minimum
x value of a and the maximum x value of b.
And that's our formula for work.
Let's look at a physical example. How much
work is required to lift 1000 kilograms satellite
from the Earth's surface to an altitude of
two times 10 to the six meters above the Earth's
surface. We're given that the gravitational
force is F equals g times capital M times
lowercase m divided by r squared, where m
is the mass of the Earth, lowercase m is the
mass of the satellite, r is the distance between
the satellite and the center of the earth,
and g is the gravitational constant. We're
also given numbers for the radius of the Earth,
the mass of the Earth, and the gravitational
constant. This problem is different from the
problem of lifting the calculus book. When
we lifted a book over just a few meters, the
force of gravity was essentially constant
over such a small distance. So we could use
the equation work equals force times distance.
But in this problem, since we're moving the
satellite a larger distance, the force of
gravity changes with distance. And so we need
to use work as the integral of this force
with respect to distance. The distance variable
in this problem is R. So I'll rewrite this
using the equation for force and integrate
with respect to Dr.
Let's look at a physical example. How much
work is required to lift 1000 kilograms satellite
from the Earth's surface to an altitude of
two times 10 to the six meters above the Earth's
surface. We're given that the gravitational
force is F equals g times capital M times
lowercase m divided by r squared, where m
is the mass of the Earth, lowercase m is the
mass of the satellite, r is the distance between
the satellite and the center of the earth,
and g is the gravitational constant. We're
also given numbers for the radius of the Earth,
the mass of the Earth, and the gravitational
constant. This problem is different from the
problem of lifting the calculus book. When
we lifted a book over just a few meters, the
force of gravity was essentially constant
over such a small distance. So we could use
the equation work equals force times distance.
But in this problem, since we're moving the
satellite a larger distance, the force of
gravity changes with distance. And so we need
to use work as the integral of this force
with respect to distance. The distance variable
in this problem is R. So I'll rewrite this
using the equation for force and integrate
with respect to Dr.
I'm starting at the Earth's surface. So that's
a distance of 6.4 times 10 to the six meters
from the center of the earth, since that's
the earth radius. And I'm ending at a height
of two times 10 to the six meters above the
Earth's surface. So that's a distance r of
6.4 plus two, or 8.4 times 10 to the six meters
from the earth center. My only variable for
this integral is R. So let me pull out the
constants. And I'll rewrite the one over r
squared as r to the minus two. Now I can integrate
an R to the minus two becomes r to the minus
one over minus one Rewrite one more time and
substitute in for R to get a preliminary answer
of negative GE, capital M lowercase n times
negative 3.72024 times 10 to the minus eight.
Now I still need to plug in for capital G,
capital M and lowercase m, my negatives cancel
here. And I have G is 6.67 times 10 to the
minus 11. capital M, the mass of the Earth
is six times 10 to the 24, and lowercase and
the mass the satellite was 1000 kilograms.
Multiplying all these numbers together, gives
us a final answer of approximately 1.5 times
10 to the 10th. jewels. To put this number
in perspective, this is about the same amount
of work done by a car in a year, or by the
human heart beating for about 400 years. In
this video, we saw that for a constant force
work is just equal to the force times distance.
But for a variable force work is equal to
the integral of force with respect to distance.
This video introduces the idea of an average
value of a function. To take the average of
a finite list of numbers, we just add the
numbers up and divide by n, the number of
numbers. In summation notation, we write the
sum from i equals one to n of Q i all divided
by n. But defining the average value of a
continuous function is a little different.
Because a function can take on infinitely
many values on an interval from a to be, we
could estimate the average value of the function
by sampling it at a finite Li many evenly
spaced x values. I'll call them x one through
x n. And let's assume that they're spaced
a distance of delta x apart, then the average
value of f at these sample points is just
the sum of the values of f divided by n, the
number of values are in summation notation,
the sum from i equals one to n of f of x i
all divided by n. This is an approximate average
value of f, since we're just using n sample
points. But the approximation gets better
as the number of sample points n gets bigger
and bigger. So we could define the average
as the limit as n goes to infinity of the
sample average. I'd like to make this look
more like a Riemann sum. So I need to get
delta x in there. So I'm just going to multiply
the top and the bottom by delta x. And notice
that n times delta x is just the length of
the interval b minus a. Now as the number
of sample points goes to infinity, delta x,
the distance between them goes to zero. So
I can rewrite my limit as the limit as delta
x goes to zero of the sum of FX II times delta
x divided by b minus a. Now the limit of this
Riemann sum in the numerator is just the integral
from a to b of f of x dx. And so the average
value of the function is given by the integral
on the interval from a to b divided by the
length of the interval.
I'm starting at the Earth's surface. So that's
a distance of 6.4 times 10 to the six meters
from the center of the earth, since that's
the earth radius. And I'm ending at a height
of two times 10 to the six meters above the
Earth's surface. So that's a distance r of
6.4 plus two, or 8.4 times 10 to the six meters
from the earth center. My only variable for
this integral is R. So let me pull out the
constants. And I'll rewrite the one over r
squared as r to the minus two. Now I can integrate
an R to the minus two becomes r to the minus
one over minus one Rewrite one more time and
substitute in for R to get a preliminary answer
of negative GE, capital M lowercase n times
negative 3.72024 times 10 to the minus eight.
Now I still need to plug in for capital G,
capital M and lowercase m, my negatives cancel
here. And I have G is 6.67 times 10 to the
minus 11. capital M, the mass of the Earth
is six times 10 to the 24, and lowercase and
the mass the satellite was 1000 kilograms.
Multiplying all these numbers together, gives
us a final answer of approximately 1.5 times
10 to the 10th. jewels. To put this number
in perspective, this is about the same amount
of work done by a car in a year, or by the
human heart beating for about 400 years. In
this video, we saw that for a constant force
work is just equal to the force times distance.
But for a variable force work is equal to
the integral of force with respect to distance.
This video introduces the idea of an average
value of a function. To take the average of
a finite list of numbers, we just add the
numbers up and divide by n, the number of
numbers. In summation notation, we write the
sum from i equals one to n of Q i all divided
by n. But defining the average value of a
continuous function is a little different.
Because a function can take on infinitely
many values on an interval from a to be, we
could estimate the average value of the function
by sampling it at a finite Li many evenly
spaced x values. I'll call them x one through
x n. And let's assume that they're spaced
a distance of delta x apart, then the average
value of f at these sample points is just
the sum of the values of f divided by n, the
number of values are in summation notation,
the sum from i equals one to n of f of x i
all divided by n. This is an approximate average
value of f, since we're just using n sample
points. But the approximation gets better
as the number of sample points n gets bigger
and bigger. So we could define the average
as the limit as n goes to infinity of the
sample average. I'd like to make this look
more like a Riemann sum. So I need to get
delta x in there. So I'm just going to multiply
the top and the bottom by delta x. And notice
that n times delta x is just the length of
the interval b minus a. Now as the number
of sample points goes to infinity, delta x,
the distance between them goes to zero. So
I can rewrite my limit as the limit as delta
x goes to zero of the sum of FX II times delta
x divided by b minus a. Now the limit of this
Riemann sum in the numerator is just the integral
from a to b of f of x dx. And so the average
value of the function is given by the integral
on the interval from a to b divided by the
length of the interval.
Notice the similarity between the formula
for the average value of a function and the
formula for the average value of a list of
numbers, the integral for the function corresponds
to the summation sign for the list of numbers.
And the length of the interval B minus A for
the function corresponds to n, the number
of numbers in the list of numbers. Now let's
work an example. For the function g of x equals
one over one minus 5x. On the interval from
two to five. We know that the average value
of G is given by the integral from two to
five of one over one minus 5x dx divided by
the length of that interval. I'm going to
use use of the tuition to integrate. So I'm
going to set u equal to one minus 5x. So d
u is negative five dx. In other words, dx
is negative 1/5 times do. Looking at my bounds
of integration, when x is equal to two, u
is equal to one minus five times two, which
is negative nine. And when x is equal to five,
u is equal to negative 24. substituting into
my integral, I get the integral from negative
nine to negative 24 of one over u times negative
1/5. Do and that's divided by three. Now dividing
by three is same as multiplying by 1/3. And
as I integrate, I'm going to pull the negative
1/5 out, and then take the integral of one
over u, that's ln of the absolute value of
u, evaluated in between negative 24 and negative
nine. The absolute value signs are important
here, because they prevent me from trying
to take the natural log of negative numbers.
To evaluate, I get negative 1/15 times ln
of 24 minus ln of nine, I can use my log rules
to simplify and get negative 1/15 ln of 24
over nine, that's negative 1/15 ln of eight
thirds, and as a decimal, that's approximately
negative 0.0654. So I found the average value
of G. Now my next question is, does g ever
achieve that average value, in other words,
is there a number c in the interval from two
to five for which GFC equals its average value?
Well, one way to find out is just to set GSC
equal to GS average value. In other words,
set one over one minus five c equal to negative
1/15 ln of eight thirds, and try to solve
for C. There are lots of ways to solve this
equation. But I'm going to take the reciprocal
of both sides, subtract one from both sides
and divide by negative five. This simplifies
to three over ln of eight thirds, plus 1/5.
What which is approximately 3.25. And that
x value does lie inside the interval from
two to five. So we've demonstrated that g
does achieve its average value over the interval.
But in fact, we could have predicted this
to be true. Gs average value has to lie somewhere
between GS minimum value and maximum value
on this interval. And since G is continuous
on the interval from two to five, it has to
achieve every value that lies in between as
minimum and maximum, including its average
value. The same argument shows that for any
continuous function, the function must achieve
its average value on an interval. And this
is known as the mean value theorem for integrals.
Namely, for any continuous function f of x
on an interval from a to b, there has to be
at least one number c, between A and B, such
that f of c equals its average value, or,
in symbols, f of c equals the integral from
a to b of f of x dx divided by b minus a.
This video gave the definition of an average
value of a function, and stated the mean value
theorem for integrals. If we rewrite the formula
for average value a little, then we can see
a geometric interpretation for average value.
The area of the box with height the average
value
Notice the similarity between the formula
for the average value of a function and the
formula for the average value of a list of
numbers, the integral for the function corresponds
to the summation sign for the list of numbers.
And the length of the interval B minus A for
the function corresponds to n, the number
of numbers in the list of numbers. Now let's
work an example. For the function g of x equals
one over one minus 5x. On the interval from
two to five. We know that the average value
of G is given by the integral from two to
five of one over one minus 5x dx divided by
the length of that interval. I'm going to
use use of the tuition to integrate. So I'm
going to set u equal to one minus 5x. So d
u is negative five dx. In other words, dx
is negative 1/5 times do. Looking at my bounds
of integration, when x is equal to two, u
is equal to one minus five times two, which
is negative nine. And when x is equal to five,
u is equal to negative 24. substituting into
my integral, I get the integral from negative
nine to negative 24 of one over u times negative
1/5. Do and that's divided by three. Now dividing
by three is same as multiplying by 1/3. And
as I integrate, I'm going to pull the negative
1/5 out, and then take the integral of one
over u, that's ln of the absolute value of
u, evaluated in between negative 24 and negative
nine. The absolute value signs are important
here, because they prevent me from trying
to take the natural log of negative numbers.
To evaluate, I get negative 1/15 times ln
of 24 minus ln of nine, I can use my log rules
to simplify and get negative 1/15 ln of 24
over nine, that's negative 1/15 ln of eight
thirds, and as a decimal, that's approximately
negative 0.0654. So I found the average value
of G. Now my next question is, does g ever
achieve that average value, in other words,
is there a number c in the interval from two
to five for which GFC equals its average value?
Well, one way to find out is just to set GSC
equal to GS average value. In other words,
set one over one minus five c equal to negative
1/15 ln of eight thirds, and try to solve
for C. There are lots of ways to solve this
equation. But I'm going to take the reciprocal
of both sides, subtract one from both sides
and divide by negative five. This simplifies
to three over ln of eight thirds, plus 1/5.
What which is approximately 3.25. And that
x value does lie inside the interval from
two to five. So we've demonstrated that g
does achieve its average value over the interval.
But in fact, we could have predicted this
to be true. Gs average value has to lie somewhere
between GS minimum value and maximum value
on this interval. And since G is continuous
on the interval from two to five, it has to
achieve every value that lies in between as
minimum and maximum, including its average
value. The same argument shows that for any
continuous function, the function must achieve
its average value on an interval. And this
is known as the mean value theorem for integrals.
Namely, for any continuous function f of x
on an interval from a to b, there has to be
at least one number c, between A and B, such
that f of c equals its average value, or,
in symbols, f of c equals the integral from
a to b of f of x dx divided by b minus a.
This video gave the definition of an average
value of a function, and stated the mean value
theorem for integrals. If we rewrite the formula
for average value a little, then we can see
a geometric interpretation for average value.
The area of the box with height the average
value
is the same as the area under the curve. This
video gives two proofs of the mean value theorem
for integrals. the mean value theorem for
integrals says the for continuous function
f of x, defined on an interval from a to b,
there's some number c between A and B, such
that f of c is equal to the average value
of f. The first proof that I'm going to give
us is the intermediate value theorem. Recall
that the intermediate value theorem says that
if we have a continuous function f defined
on an interval, which I'll call x 1x, two.
If we have some number l in between f of x
one and f of x two, then f has to achieve
the value l somewhere between x one and x
two Keeping in mind the intermediate value
theorem, let's turn our attention back to
the mean value theorem for integrals. Now,
it's possible that our function f of x might
be constant on the interval from a to b. But
if that's true, then our mean value theorem
for integrals holds easily. Because f AF is
just equal to that constant, which is equal
to f of c for any c between A and B. So let's
assume that f is not constant. Well, like
continuous function on a closed interval has
to have a minimum value and a maximum value,
which I'll call little m, and big M. Now,
we know that F's average value on the interval
has to be between its maximum value and its
minimum value. If you don't believe this,
consider the fact that all of us values on
the interval have to lie between big M and
little m. And if we integrate this inequality,
we get little m times b minus a is less than
or equal to the integral of f is less than
or equal to big M times b minus a. Notice
that the first and the last integrals, were
just integrating a constant. Now if I divide
all three sides by b minus a, I can see that
little m is less than or equal to the average
value of f is less than or equal to big M
as I wanted. Now, I just need to apply the
intermediate value theorem with F average
as my number L and little m and big M as my
values of f of x one and f of x two. The intermediate
value theorem says that F average is achieved
by f of c for some C in between my x one and
x two. And therefore, for some C in my interval
a b. And that proves the mean value theorem
for integrals. Now I'm going to give a second
proof for the mean value theorem for integrals.
And this time, it's going to be as a corollary
to the regular mean value theorem for functions.
Recall that the mean value theorem for functions,
says that if g of x is continuous on a closed
interval, and differentiable on the interior
of that interval, then there's some number
c in the interval, such that the derivative
of g at C is equal to the average rate of
change of G, across the whole interval from
a to b. Let's keep the mean value theorem
for functions in mind, and turn our attention
back to the mean value theorem for integrals.
I'm going to define a function g of x to be
the integral from a to x of f of t dt, where
F is the function given to us in the statement
of the mean value theorem for integrals. Notice
that g of A is just the integral from a to
a, which is zero. Well, g of B is the integral
from a to b of our function. Now, by the fundamental
theorem of calculus, our function g of x is
continuous and differentiable on the interval
a, b, and g prime of x is equal to f of x.
is the same as the area under the curve. This
video gives two proofs of the mean value theorem
for integrals. the mean value theorem for
integrals says the for continuous function
f of x, defined on an interval from a to b,
there's some number c between A and B, such
that f of c is equal to the average value
of f. The first proof that I'm going to give
us is the intermediate value theorem. Recall
that the intermediate value theorem says that
if we have a continuous function f defined
on an interval, which I'll call x 1x, two.
If we have some number l in between f of x
one and f of x two, then f has to achieve
the value l somewhere between x one and x
two Keeping in mind the intermediate value
theorem, let's turn our attention back to
the mean value theorem for integrals. Now,
it's possible that our function f of x might
be constant on the interval from a to b. But
if that's true, then our mean value theorem
for integrals holds easily. Because f AF is
just equal to that constant, which is equal
to f of c for any c between A and B. So let's
assume that f is not constant. Well, like
continuous function on a closed interval has
to have a minimum value and a maximum value,
which I'll call little m, and big M. Now,
we know that F's average value on the interval
has to be between its maximum value and its
minimum value. If you don't believe this,
consider the fact that all of us values on
the interval have to lie between big M and
little m. And if we integrate this inequality,
we get little m times b minus a is less than
or equal to the integral of f is less than
or equal to big M times b minus a. Notice
that the first and the last integrals, were
just integrating a constant. Now if I divide
all three sides by b minus a, I can see that
little m is less than or equal to the average
value of f is less than or equal to big M
as I wanted. Now, I just need to apply the
intermediate value theorem with F average
as my number L and little m and big M as my
values of f of x one and f of x two. The intermediate
value theorem says that F average is achieved
by f of c for some C in between my x one and
x two. And therefore, for some C in my interval
a b. And that proves the mean value theorem
for integrals. Now I'm going to give a second
proof for the mean value theorem for integrals.
And this time, it's going to be as a corollary
to the regular mean value theorem for functions.
Recall that the mean value theorem for functions,
says that if g of x is continuous on a closed
interval, and differentiable on the interior
of that interval, then there's some number
c in the interval, such that the derivative
of g at C is equal to the average rate of
change of G, across the whole interval from
a to b. Let's keep the mean value theorem
for functions in mind, and turn our attention
back to the mean value theorem for integrals.
I'm going to define a function g of x to be
the integral from a to x of f of t dt, where
F is the function given to us in the statement
of the mean value theorem for integrals. Notice
that g of A is just the integral from a to
a, which is zero. Well, g of B is the integral
from a to b of our function. Now, by the fundamental
theorem of calculus, our function g of x is
continuous and differentiable on the interval
a, b, and g prime of x is equal to f of x.
And by the mean value theorem for functions,
we know that g prime of c has to equal g of
b minus g of a over b minus a, for some number
c and the interval a b, if we substitute in
the three facts above, into our equation below,
we get f of c is equal to the integral from
a to b of f of t dt minus zero over b minus
a, which is exactly the conclusion that we
wanted to reach. This shows that the mean
value theorem for integrals really is the
mean value theorem for functions where our
function is an integral. And this completes
the second proof of the mean value theorem
for integrals. So now I've proved the mean
value theorem for integrals in two different
ways. And I've used a lot of the great theorems
of calculus along the way. In this video,
we'll learn a technique of integration called
inner By parts. integration by parts is based
on the product rule for taking derivatives.
Recall that the product rule says that when
you take the derivative of a product of two
functions, that's equal to the derivative
of the first function times the second function,
plus the first function times the derivative
of the second function. If we rearrange this
formula, by solving for this last term, we
get f of x times g prime of x is equal to
f of x g of x prime minus f prime of x g of
x. Now let's integrate both sides of this
equation with respect to x. The integral of
a difference is the difference of the integrals.
So I can break up this right hand side into
two integrals. Now the integral of the derivative
of f times g is just equal to f times g, by
the fundamental theorem of calculus. And I
carry the rest of the formula down. And now
I have a formula relating the integral of
f times g prime to the integral of f prime
times G. This formula allows us to rewrite
something that might be tricky to integrate,
in terms of something that's hopefully easier
to integrate. Although I've written this formula,
using indefinite integrals with no bounds
of integration, it would be just as easy to
put on bounds of integration. Now, the fundamental
theorem tells us that the integral of the
derivative is the original product of functions
evaluated from A to B. There's another version
of this formula that might be a little easier
to remember. If we let u equal f of x, and
v equal g of x, then do is equal to f prime
of x dx using differential notation, and dv
is equal to g prime of x dx. In this notation,
we can rewrite the formula as the integral
of u times dv is equal to u times v minus
the integral of v, d U. since V is our G of
X, and D, u is our f prime of x dx. Again,
we can include bounds of integration, if we're
working with definite integrals. This will
be our key formula for this section. and integrating
using this formula is called integration by
parts. Let's use integration by parts to find
the integral of x e to the x dx. Or for formula
for integration by parts, says the integral
of u dv is equal to u times v minus the integral
of the do. So we need to split up our inner
grand x e to the x dx into the part that we're
going to call you, and a part that we're going
to call dv. One natural way to split it up
is to let u equal x and dv equal e to the
x dx. But another option might be to make
u equal to e to the x and dv equal to x dx
bar, we might decide to make you be the whole
product, x e to the x and leave dv as just
dx.
And by the mean value theorem for functions,
we know that g prime of c has to equal g of
b minus g of a over b minus a, for some number
c and the interval a b, if we substitute in
the three facts above, into our equation below,
we get f of c is equal to the integral from
a to b of f of t dt minus zero over b minus
a, which is exactly the conclusion that we
wanted to reach. This shows that the mean
value theorem for integrals really is the
mean value theorem for functions where our
function is an integral. And this completes
the second proof of the mean value theorem
for integrals. So now I've proved the mean
value theorem for integrals in two different
ways. And I've used a lot of the great theorems
of calculus along the way. In this video,
we'll learn a technique of integration called
inner By parts. integration by parts is based
on the product rule for taking derivatives.
Recall that the product rule says that when
you take the derivative of a product of two
functions, that's equal to the derivative
of the first function times the second function,
plus the first function times the derivative
of the second function. If we rearrange this
formula, by solving for this last term, we
get f of x times g prime of x is equal to
f of x g of x prime minus f prime of x g of
x. Now let's integrate both sides of this
equation with respect to x. The integral of
a difference is the difference of the integrals.
So I can break up this right hand side into
two integrals. Now the integral of the derivative
of f times g is just equal to f times g, by
the fundamental theorem of calculus. And I
carry the rest of the formula down. And now
I have a formula relating the integral of
f times g prime to the integral of f prime
times G. This formula allows us to rewrite
something that might be tricky to integrate,
in terms of something that's hopefully easier
to integrate. Although I've written this formula,
using indefinite integrals with no bounds
of integration, it would be just as easy to
put on bounds of integration. Now, the fundamental
theorem tells us that the integral of the
derivative is the original product of functions
evaluated from A to B. There's another version
of this formula that might be a little easier
to remember. If we let u equal f of x, and
v equal g of x, then do is equal to f prime
of x dx using differential notation, and dv
is equal to g prime of x dx. In this notation,
we can rewrite the formula as the integral
of u times dv is equal to u times v minus
the integral of v, d U. since V is our G of
X, and D, u is our f prime of x dx. Again,
we can include bounds of integration, if we're
working with definite integrals. This will
be our key formula for this section. and integrating
using this formula is called integration by
parts. Let's use integration by parts to find
the integral of x e to the x dx. Or for formula
for integration by parts, says the integral
of u dv is equal to u times v minus the integral
of the do. So we need to split up our inner
grand x e to the x dx into the part that we're
going to call you, and a part that we're going
to call dv. One natural way to split it up
is to let u equal x and dv equal e to the
x dx. But another option might be to make
u equal to e to the x and dv equal to x dx
bar, we might decide to make you be the whole
product, x e to the x and leave dv as just
dx.
Whatever choice we make, we need a u times
dv to be our entire integrand here, and we
need dx to be part of dv in order to use proper
differential notation. Let's try using the
first choice first. If u is equal to x, then
d u is equal to dx. And if dv is e to the
x dx, then we can find V by integrating this
and the integral of e to the x dx is e to
the x. plugging into our integration by parts
formula, we have the integral of u dv that's
x, e to the x dx is equal to u times v x into
dx minus the integral of vdu. That's e to
the x dx. Well, this is looking very promising,
because I know how to integrate e to the x
dx. It's just e to the x plus a constant of
integration. And so integration by part has
allowed us to compute our integral, let's
check our answer by taking the derivative
of what we got the derivative of x, e to the
x minus e to the x plus C is going to be the
derivative of x, that's one, times e to the
x plus x times the derivative of e to the
x, which is dx, minus the derivative of iliacs,
which is again, the x plus the derivative
of C, which is just zero. And since this term
and this term cancel out, we're left with
x e to the x, which is exactly what we started
out with as our integrand. So we've checked
that our work is correct. Notice that in order
to take the derivative of our answer, we ended
up having to use the product rule. And that's
no coincidence, because the formula for integration
by parts is really just the product rule used
in reverse. So we were successful in computing
this integral using our first choice of u
and dv. But before we leave this problem,
let's see what would have happened if we used
a different choice. Instead, if we used you've
equal to either the X and dv equal to x dx,
if we done that, then we would have gotten
do to be either the x dx, and we would have
computed V by integrating x dx two that get
x squared over two. plugging this into our
formula for integration by parts, we would
get the integral of udv, that's e to the x
times x dx is equal to u times v, that's e
to the x times x squared over two, minus the
integral of vdu. That's x squared over two
times e to the x, dx. Now in order to go any
further, we need to be able to compute the
integral of x squared over two times e to
the x dx. dividing by two poses no problem,
that's just a constant, but the integral of
x squared e to the x that's more complicated
than the integral of e to the x times x that
we started with. So we're going the wrong
direction here. And this turns out to be a
poor choice of u and dv. I'll let you check
that the third choice of u and dv that I suggested
also ends up making things more complicated
instead of simpler. So the first choice turned
out to be the best choice for you, and dv.
integration by parts works by replacing an
integral of the form u dv by the equivalent
expression, u times v minus the integral of
vdu. That's hopefully easier to compute. There
are a lot of trig identities that come in
handy when you're doing calculus. But the
good news is, if you're willing to do a little
bit of algebra, there are only a few that
you really have to memorize. In this video,
I'll tell you my three favorite trig identities,
and show you how to derive a bunch more with
very little effort from these three. So I'm
going to tell you the three trig identities
that I think everybody should know. Fortunately,
all three of them are very easy to remember.
The first one is the Pythagorean identity.
That's the identity that says sine squared
of theta plus cosine squared of theta is equal
to one. That one's easy to remember, because
it's really just the Pythagorean theorem for
triangles in the context of the unit circle.
Whatever choice we make, we need a u times
dv to be our entire integrand here, and we
need dx to be part of dv in order to use proper
differential notation. Let's try using the
first choice first. If u is equal to x, then
d u is equal to dx. And if dv is e to the
x dx, then we can find V by integrating this
and the integral of e to the x dx is e to
the x. plugging into our integration by parts
formula, we have the integral of u dv that's
x, e to the x dx is equal to u times v x into
dx minus the integral of vdu. That's e to
the x dx. Well, this is looking very promising,
because I know how to integrate e to the x
dx. It's just e to the x plus a constant of
integration. And so integration by part has
allowed us to compute our integral, let's
check our answer by taking the derivative
of what we got the derivative of x, e to the
x minus e to the x plus C is going to be the
derivative of x, that's one, times e to the
x plus x times the derivative of e to the
x, which is dx, minus the derivative of iliacs,
which is again, the x plus the derivative
of C, which is just zero. And since this term
and this term cancel out, we're left with
x e to the x, which is exactly what we started
out with as our integrand. So we've checked
that our work is correct. Notice that in order
to take the derivative of our answer, we ended
up having to use the product rule. And that's
no coincidence, because the formula for integration
by parts is really just the product rule used
in reverse. So we were successful in computing
this integral using our first choice of u
and dv. But before we leave this problem,
let's see what would have happened if we used
a different choice. Instead, if we used you've
equal to either the X and dv equal to x dx,
if we done that, then we would have gotten
do to be either the x dx, and we would have
computed V by integrating x dx two that get
x squared over two. plugging this into our
formula for integration by parts, we would
get the integral of udv, that's e to the x
times x dx is equal to u times v, that's e
to the x times x squared over two, minus the
integral of vdu. That's x squared over two
times e to the x, dx. Now in order to go any
further, we need to be able to compute the
integral of x squared over two times e to
the x dx. dividing by two poses no problem,
that's just a constant, but the integral of
x squared e to the x that's more complicated
than the integral of e to the x times x that
we started with. So we're going the wrong
direction here. And this turns out to be a
poor choice of u and dv. I'll let you check
that the third choice of u and dv that I suggested
also ends up making things more complicated
instead of simpler. So the first choice turned
out to be the best choice for you, and dv.
integration by parts works by replacing an
integral of the form u dv by the equivalent
expression, u times v minus the integral of
vdu. That's hopefully easier to compute. There
are a lot of trig identities that come in
handy when you're doing calculus. But the
good news is, if you're willing to do a little
bit of algebra, there are only a few that
you really have to memorize. In this video,
I'll tell you my three favorite trig identities,
and show you how to derive a bunch more with
very little effort from these three. So I'm
going to tell you the three trig identities
that I think everybody should know. Fortunately,
all three of them are very easy to remember.
The first one is the Pythagorean identity.
That's the identity that says sine squared
of theta plus cosine squared of theta is equal
to one. That one's easy to remember, because
it's really just the Pythagorean theorem for
triangles in the context of the unit circle.
If I draw a right triangle with angle theta
on a unit circle, it's hi partners has length
one, because a unit circle means a circle
of radius one. The base of this triangle has
length cosine of theta, because by definition,
cosine of theta is the x coordinate of the
point on the unit circle at angle theta. Similarly,
the height of the triangle is sine of theta,
because sine of theta means the y coordinate
on the unit circle. So by the Pythagorean
theorem for right triangles, we know that
sine theta squared plus cosine theta squared
equals one, which is exactly the bit beggary
and identity. The second identities that everybody
should know are the even and odd identities.
I guess technically, these are two different
identities but they go together, so I'm counting
them as one. The even identity says that cosine
of negative theta is equal to cosine of Beta.
In other words, cosine is an even function.
And the identity says that sine of negative
theta is equal to negative sine of theta.
In other words, sine is an odd function. One
way to remember these identities is by looking
at the graphs of sine and cosine. Y equals
cosine x has this bilateral symmetry, so it's
an even function. And if I look at the value
of cosine at theta, and cosine at negative
theta, my graph has the same height. So cosine
has the same value for both of these angles.
The graph of y equals sine x does not have
bilateral symmetry, instead, it's got 180
degree rotational symmetry, which is characteristic
of an odd function. And if I compare the y
values, that theta and negative theta, I see
that the y value at negative theta is exactly
the opposite as the y value at theta, and
therefore, sine of negative theta is equal
to negative sine of theta. Another way to
understand that, even in odd identities, is
by going back to the unit circle. If I look
at an angle of theta, compared to an angle
of negative theta, the x coordinate, which
is cosine has the same value for both of these
angles. So that means cosine of negative theta
is equal to cosine of theta. the y coordinate
instead is the opposite. For negative theta,
versus theta, one of them is positive and
one of them is negative, but they have the
same magnitude. Therefore, sine of negative
theta is the negative of sine of theta. My
third favorite trig identity is the angle
sum formula. Again, there are really two,
one for sine and one for cosine, but they
go together, so I'll consider them a single
identity. These identities are easy to remember
because there's a song that goes with them.
And the song goes, sine, cosine, cosine, sine,
cosine, cosine, minus sign sign, you may recognize
the tune, please sing along with me this time.
So remember it 123 go sine cosine cosine sine,
cosine cosine minus sine sine. The only thing
you have to remember when you sing the song
is that it gives the sine of A plus B first,
and then the cosine of A plus B. So these
are the three trig identities that I think
everybody should memorize. Next, I'll show
you how to derive a bunch more trig identities.
Pretty simply, from these three. I've written
my three favorite trig identities across the
top for easy reference. First of all, we can
derive a couple of good identities just from
the beggary and identity. Let's start by dividing
both sides of this identity by cosine squared
theta. We can break up the fraction on the
left into sine squared theta over cosine squared
theta plus cosine squared theta over cosine
squared theta equals one over cosine squared
theta. But sine squared theta over cosine
squared theta is just tan squared theta. and
cosine squared theta over cosine squared theta
is one. And one over cosine squared theta
is seacon squared theta, since secant theta
by definition is one over cosine.
If I draw a right triangle with angle theta
on a unit circle, it's hi partners has length
one, because a unit circle means a circle
of radius one. The base of this triangle has
length cosine of theta, because by definition,
cosine of theta is the x coordinate of the
point on the unit circle at angle theta. Similarly,
the height of the triangle is sine of theta,
because sine of theta means the y coordinate
on the unit circle. So by the Pythagorean
theorem for right triangles, we know that
sine theta squared plus cosine theta squared
equals one, which is exactly the bit beggary
and identity. The second identities that everybody
should know are the even and odd identities.
I guess technically, these are two different
identities but they go together, so I'm counting
them as one. The even identity says that cosine
of negative theta is equal to cosine of Beta.
In other words, cosine is an even function.
And the identity says that sine of negative
theta is equal to negative sine of theta.
In other words, sine is an odd function. One
way to remember these identities is by looking
at the graphs of sine and cosine. Y equals
cosine x has this bilateral symmetry, so it's
an even function. And if I look at the value
of cosine at theta, and cosine at negative
theta, my graph has the same height. So cosine
has the same value for both of these angles.
The graph of y equals sine x does not have
bilateral symmetry, instead, it's got 180
degree rotational symmetry, which is characteristic
of an odd function. And if I compare the y
values, that theta and negative theta, I see
that the y value at negative theta is exactly
the opposite as the y value at theta, and
therefore, sine of negative theta is equal
to negative sine of theta. Another way to
understand that, even in odd identities, is
by going back to the unit circle. If I look
at an angle of theta, compared to an angle
of negative theta, the x coordinate, which
is cosine has the same value for both of these
angles. So that means cosine of negative theta
is equal to cosine of theta. the y coordinate
instead is the opposite. For negative theta,
versus theta, one of them is positive and
one of them is negative, but they have the
same magnitude. Therefore, sine of negative
theta is the negative of sine of theta. My
third favorite trig identity is the angle
sum formula. Again, there are really two,
one for sine and one for cosine, but they
go together, so I'll consider them a single
identity. These identities are easy to remember
because there's a song that goes with them.
And the song goes, sine, cosine, cosine, sine,
cosine, cosine, minus sign sign, you may recognize
the tune, please sing along with me this time.
So remember it 123 go sine cosine cosine sine,
cosine cosine minus sine sine. The only thing
you have to remember when you sing the song
is that it gives the sine of A plus B first,
and then the cosine of A plus B. So these
are the three trig identities that I think
everybody should memorize. Next, I'll show
you how to derive a bunch more trig identities.
Pretty simply, from these three. I've written
my three favorite trig identities across the
top for easy reference. First of all, we can
derive a couple of good identities just from
the beggary and identity. Let's start by dividing
both sides of this identity by cosine squared
theta. We can break up the fraction on the
left into sine squared theta over cosine squared
theta plus cosine squared theta over cosine
squared theta equals one over cosine squared
theta. But sine squared theta over cosine
squared theta is just tan squared theta. and
cosine squared theta over cosine squared theta
is one. And one over cosine squared theta
is seacon squared theta, since secant theta
by definition is one over cosine.
So we found a new identity, a variation on
the Pythagorean identity that involves tangent
and secant. Now, what if we wanted an identity
that involved cotangent and cosecant instead?
Well, as you might be thinking, we could just
start with the theory and identity. And this
time, divide both sides by sine squared of
theta. If we break up the fraction like before,
we get one plus cotangent squared theta equals
cosecant squared theta. Since cotangent is
cosine over sine, and cosecant is one of our
sign. Next, it's possible to get a bunch of
great identities from the angle some formulas.
Let's start by deriving an angle difference
formula. If we want a formula for sine of
A minus B, all we have to do is plug in negative
B for B In our angle some formula. So we get
sine of A cosine of negative b plus cosine
of A sine of negative B. But we know that
cosine of negative B is cosine of B, since
cosine is 11. And sine of negative b is negative
sine of B, so that turns this positive sign
to a negative sign. And we have an angle difference
formula for sine. Similarly, we can use the
angle sum formula for cosine, plugging in
negative B for b. and use the even odd properties
to get an angle difference formula for cosine.
Now let's derive a super useful formula, the
double angle formula. If we want a formula
for sine of two theta, we can think of that
as being the sine of theta plus theta. So
let's plug theta in for a and theta in for
B in our angle sum formula. That gives us
sine cosine, cosine sine, which simplifies
to two sine theta cosine theta. That's the
double angle formula for sine. That worked
out so well, let's try the same thing for
cosine. cosine of two theta is cosine of theta
plus theta. And using the angle sum formula,
that's cosine, cosine minus sine sine, we
can rewrite this as cosine squared theta minus
sine squared theta, and get our first version
of the double angle formula for cosine. But
we could also use the Pythagorean identity
to replace cosine squared theta by one minus
sine squared theta. Or if we prefer, we can
replace sine squared theta by one minus cosine
squared theta. If we replace cosine squared,
we get cosine of two theta is one minus sine
squared theta minus sine squared theta. In
other words, cosine of two theta is one minus
twice sine squared theta. And if we go back
to the original, and replace sine squared
theta by one minus cosine squared theta, we
get cosine of two theta is cosine squared
theta minus quantity one minus cosine squared
theta, which simplifies to cosine of two theta
is twice cosine squared theta minus one. So
we found one version of a double angle formula
for sine, and three versions for cosine, just
using the angle sum formula and the Pythagorean
identity. These last two formulas are particularly
useful for integration when they're rewritten
slightly. For this formula, let me solve for
sine squared of theta, I get two sine squared
of theta is equal to one minus cosine of two
theta. So sine squared of theta is one half
minus one half cosine of two theta. I'll do
the analogous thing with this formula and
solve for cosine squared theta
So we found a new identity, a variation on
the Pythagorean identity that involves tangent
and secant. Now, what if we wanted an identity
that involved cotangent and cosecant instead?
Well, as you might be thinking, we could just
start with the theory and identity. And this
time, divide both sides by sine squared of
theta. If we break up the fraction like before,
we get one plus cotangent squared theta equals
cosecant squared theta. Since cotangent is
cosine over sine, and cosecant is one of our
sign. Next, it's possible to get a bunch of
great identities from the angle some formulas.
Let's start by deriving an angle difference
formula. If we want a formula for sine of
A minus B, all we have to do is plug in negative
B for B In our angle some formula. So we get
sine of A cosine of negative b plus cosine
of A sine of negative B. But we know that
cosine of negative B is cosine of B, since
cosine is 11. And sine of negative b is negative
sine of B, so that turns this positive sign
to a negative sign. And we have an angle difference
formula for sine. Similarly, we can use the
angle sum formula for cosine, plugging in
negative B for b. and use the even odd properties
to get an angle difference formula for cosine.
Now let's derive a super useful formula, the
double angle formula. If we want a formula
for sine of two theta, we can think of that
as being the sine of theta plus theta. So
let's plug theta in for a and theta in for
B in our angle sum formula. That gives us
sine cosine, cosine sine, which simplifies
to two sine theta cosine theta. That's the
double angle formula for sine. That worked
out so well, let's try the same thing for
cosine. cosine of two theta is cosine of theta
plus theta. And using the angle sum formula,
that's cosine, cosine minus sine sine, we
can rewrite this as cosine squared theta minus
sine squared theta, and get our first version
of the double angle formula for cosine. But
we could also use the Pythagorean identity
to replace cosine squared theta by one minus
sine squared theta. Or if we prefer, we can
replace sine squared theta by one minus cosine
squared theta. If we replace cosine squared,
we get cosine of two theta is one minus sine
squared theta minus sine squared theta. In
other words, cosine of two theta is one minus
twice sine squared theta. And if we go back
to the original, and replace sine squared
theta by one minus cosine squared theta, we
get cosine of two theta is cosine squared
theta minus quantity one minus cosine squared
theta, which simplifies to cosine of two theta
is twice cosine squared theta minus one. So
we found one version of a double angle formula
for sine, and three versions for cosine, just
using the angle sum formula and the Pythagorean
identity. These last two formulas are particularly
useful for integration when they're rewritten
slightly. For this formula, let me solve for
sine squared of theta, I get two sine squared
of theta is equal to one minus cosine of two
theta. So sine squared of theta is one half
minus one half cosine of two theta. I'll do
the analogous thing with this formula and
solve for cosine squared theta
to cosine squared theta is equal to one plus
cosine of two theta. So cosine squared theta
is equal to one half, plus one half cosine
of two theta. That's all the triggers in these
we're gonna need. It may seem like a lot,
but remember, they all follow very naturally
from my three favorites at the top. Well,
all these formulas are very useful. The ones
that are of particular importance for techniques
of integration are the first one, that factory
and identity and its various forms. And the
last two. In this video, I told you my three
favorite trig identities, the Pythagorean
identity, the even an odd identities and the
angle some formulas. From these I derived
a bunch of other identities, including a handful
that will be particularly useful as we do
techniques of integration. Remember the angle
some formulas, those are the formulas for
computing sine of A plus B, and cosine of
A plus B. I like to sing them, sine, cosine,
cosine, sine, cosine, cosine minus sine sine.
This video gives a geometric proof of those
formulas. There are many great proofs of the
angle some formulas, but I'd like to share
with you one of my favorites for those who
are interested. Alright, the angle some formulas
up here, so we'll know what we're trying to
prove. To prove these formulas, let me start
by drawing an angle A and angle B on top of
that. Next, I'm going to draw a line perpendicular
to this middle line. And I'm going to extend
the top line until it meets that perpendicular,
making a right triangle. Finally, I'll draw
a rectangle around that right triangle that
just touches its vertices. My rectangle is
now divided up into four right triangles.
And I'm going to choose units of measurement,
so that the high partners of my middle triangle
has length one. Now let's stop for a minute
to think about the angles of these other triangles.
Since the top and the bottom edge of the rectangle
are parallel lines, and this high partners
is a transversal. This angle up here must
have the same measure as a plus b down here.
Also, this skinny angle here must have the
same measure as a down here. Because this
angle is 180 degrees, minus 90 degrees minus
this angle here. And this angle A is also
180 degrees, the measure of the angles in
a triangle minus 90 degrees minus that same
angle.
to cosine squared theta is equal to one plus
cosine of two theta. So cosine squared theta
is equal to one half, plus one half cosine
of two theta. That's all the triggers in these
we're gonna need. It may seem like a lot,
but remember, they all follow very naturally
from my three favorites at the top. Well,
all these formulas are very useful. The ones
that are of particular importance for techniques
of integration are the first one, that factory
and identity and its various forms. And the
last two. In this video, I told you my three
favorite trig identities, the Pythagorean
identity, the even an odd identities and the
angle some formulas. From these I derived
a bunch of other identities, including a handful
that will be particularly useful as we do
techniques of integration. Remember the angle
some formulas, those are the formulas for
computing sine of A plus B, and cosine of
A plus B. I like to sing them, sine, cosine,
cosine, sine, cosine, cosine minus sine sine.
This video gives a geometric proof of those
formulas. There are many great proofs of the
angle some formulas, but I'd like to share
with you one of my favorites for those who
are interested. Alright, the angle some formulas
up here, so we'll know what we're trying to
prove. To prove these formulas, let me start
by drawing an angle A and angle B on top of
that. Next, I'm going to draw a line perpendicular
to this middle line. And I'm going to extend
the top line until it meets that perpendicular,
making a right triangle. Finally, I'll draw
a rectangle around that right triangle that
just touches its vertices. My rectangle is
now divided up into four right triangles.
And I'm going to choose units of measurement,
so that the high partners of my middle triangle
has length one. Now let's stop for a minute
to think about the angles of these other triangles.
Since the top and the bottom edge of the rectangle
are parallel lines, and this high partners
is a transversal. This angle up here must
have the same measure as a plus b down here.
Also, this skinny angle here must have the
same measure as a down here. Because this
angle is 180 degrees, minus 90 degrees minus
this angle here. And this angle A is also
180 degrees, the measure of the angles in
a triangle minus 90 degrees minus that same
angle.
So I'll label this skinny angle with a. Next,
let's figure out as many side lengths as we
can.
So I'll label this skinny angle with a. Next,
let's figure out as many side lengths as we
can.
Based on the middle right triangle with high
partners one, we know that this side length
down here must be cosine of B, since adjacent
over hypotenuse is cosine B. Similarly, this
side length here must be sine of B. Since
opposite of our hypothesis is sine of B, now
we see that sine of B is the hypotenuse of
this right triangle, which means that this
little side here has measure sign a time sign
B. That's because the opposite over the hypothesis
of this angle has to equal sign a. A similar
argument shows that this side has to have
measure cosine A time sign B. Please pause
the video and take a moment to fill in the
side length of this right triangle. And this
right triangle, you should be getting sine
A cosine B cosine A cosine B sine of A plus
B and cosine of A plus B. But remember, we
have a rectangle here. So the opposite sides
have equal length. This tells us that sine
of A plus B has to equal sine of A cosine
of B plus cosine of A sine of B, which is
exactly the first angle sum formula. Also,
cosine of A plus B, which is this side length,
is exactly the difference of this side length
cosine A cosine B minus this side length sine
of A sine B. And that's the second angle sum
formula. So I think that's a pretty great
geometric proof of the angle some formulas.
This video is about integrating trig functions
that involve at least one odd power of sine
or cosine. Let's start by evaluating the integral
of sine to the fourth x times cosine x dx.
This integral is a good candidate for u substitution.
If we let u equal sine of x Then d u is equal
to cosine of x dx. And we can rewrite the
integral as the integral of u to the fourth
do this integrates easily to 1/5 times u to
the fifth plus C. And I can convert things
back to x by plugging in sine of x for you,
to get 1/5 sine to the fifth of x plus C.
The next integral, the integral of sine to
the fourth x times cosine cubed x dx can also
be handled with a similar use of the tuition
with a bit more work. First, I'm going to
rewrite the integral as the integral of sine
to the fourth x times cosine squared x times
cosine of x dx. I'm rewriting the cosine cubed
of x as cosine squared of x times cosine x
in the hopes that I can use cosine of x dx
as my d u, like I did in the previous problem.
Now if we have d u, as cosine of x, dx, we're
going to need you to be sine of x. But unlike
the previous problem, I can't just replace
sine of the fourth x with you to the fourth
and cosine x dx with D, U and be done. Because
I've got this cosine squared x hanging around
that I need to deal with. I wish I didn't
have that cosine squared x, I wish everything
else over here was just written in terms of
sine. Now, as you might realize, it's not
hard for me to get my wish. We know from the
Pythagorean identity, that cosine squared
of x plus sine squared of x is equal to one.
So cosine squared of x can be written as one
minus sine squared x. Making that substitution,
I can now rewrite my integral entirely in
terms of you. And do now if I multiply things
out, this becomes easy to integrate, I get
1/5 u to the fifth minus 1/7 u to the seventh
plus C. And I can rewrite this in terms of
x.
Based on the middle right triangle with high
partners one, we know that this side length
down here must be cosine of B, since adjacent
over hypotenuse is cosine B. Similarly, this
side length here must be sine of B. Since
opposite of our hypothesis is sine of B, now
we see that sine of B is the hypotenuse of
this right triangle, which means that this
little side here has measure sign a time sign
B. That's because the opposite over the hypothesis
of this angle has to equal sign a. A similar
argument shows that this side has to have
measure cosine A time sign B. Please pause
the video and take a moment to fill in the
side length of this right triangle. And this
right triangle, you should be getting sine
A cosine B cosine A cosine B sine of A plus
B and cosine of A plus B. But remember, we
have a rectangle here. So the opposite sides
have equal length. This tells us that sine
of A plus B has to equal sine of A cosine
of B plus cosine of A sine of B, which is
exactly the first angle sum formula. Also,
cosine of A plus B, which is this side length,
is exactly the difference of this side length
cosine A cosine B minus this side length sine
of A sine B. And that's the second angle sum
formula. So I think that's a pretty great
geometric proof of the angle some formulas.
This video is about integrating trig functions
that involve at least one odd power of sine
or cosine. Let's start by evaluating the integral
of sine to the fourth x times cosine x dx.
This integral is a good candidate for u substitution.
If we let u equal sine of x Then d u is equal
to cosine of x dx. And we can rewrite the
integral as the integral of u to the fourth
do this integrates easily to 1/5 times u to
the fifth plus C. And I can convert things
back to x by plugging in sine of x for you,
to get 1/5 sine to the fifth of x plus C.
The next integral, the integral of sine to
the fourth x times cosine cubed x dx can also
be handled with a similar use of the tuition
with a bit more work. First, I'm going to
rewrite the integral as the integral of sine
to the fourth x times cosine squared x times
cosine of x dx. I'm rewriting the cosine cubed
of x as cosine squared of x times cosine x
in the hopes that I can use cosine of x dx
as my d u, like I did in the previous problem.
Now if we have d u, as cosine of x, dx, we're
going to need you to be sine of x. But unlike
the previous problem, I can't just replace
sine of the fourth x with you to the fourth
and cosine x dx with D, U and be done. Because
I've got this cosine squared x hanging around
that I need to deal with. I wish I didn't
have that cosine squared x, I wish everything
else over here was just written in terms of
sine. Now, as you might realize, it's not
hard for me to get my wish. We know from the
Pythagorean identity, that cosine squared
of x plus sine squared of x is equal to one.
So cosine squared of x can be written as one
minus sine squared x. Making that substitution,
I can now rewrite my integral entirely in
terms of you. And do now if I multiply things
out, this becomes easy to integrate, I get
1/5 u to the fifth minus 1/7 u to the seventh
plus C. And I can rewrite this in terms of
x.
To recap, we separated out one copy of cosine
x to be part of our D U. And then we converted
the rest of the cosines in the signs isn't
a Pythagorean identity. This allowed us to
do use of the tuition with u equal to sine
x and evaluate the integral. This same technique
with some modifications works on a lot of
other problems. In this next problem, if we
tried separating out one copy of cosine of
x to be part of our do, we'd run into problems,
because we just have one copy of cosine x
left. And we can't use the Pythagorean identity
can to convert a single cosine into signs.
Well, I guess technically, we could do something
like this. But then we'd have to introduce
a plus or minus sign and a square root sign
into our integrand, which would make things
difficult to integrate. It's a lot easier
if we can just use the cosine squared x is
equal to one minus sine squared x identity
to replace our cosines with signs. But this
identity only applies if we have an even power
of cosines leftover that we want to convert.
So instead of trying to save out a copy of
cosine x, let's say about a copy of sine x
instead. So we'll rewrite our integral as
the integral of sine to the fourth of x times
a sine of x. And we'll keep the cosine squared
x and the dx. Now we want the sine x to be
part of our D U. So let's set u equal to cosine
of x. That way d u is equal to negative sine
of x dx. And so sine of x dx is equal to negative
d U. since u is equal to cosine x, this time,
we want to replace all of our stray signs
with cosines. We know that sine squared of
x is equal to one minus cosine squared of
x by the Pythagorean identity. So let's rewrite
this sine to the fourth as sine squared of
x squared. That allows us to substitute in
one minus cosine squared of x for sine squared
of x And now we can replace everything with
us and d is I'll bring out the negative sign
and multiply things out. One minus u squared
squared is one minus two u squared plus u
to the fourth. And this multiplies out to
us squared minus two u to the fourth plus
u to the sixth. Now I can integrate, distribute
my negative sign. And finally, plug in cosine
of x for you. That completes this problem.
In this video, we'll use use substitution
and the Pythagorean identity. To evaluate
integrals with at least one odd power of sine
or cosine. The idea is to separate off one
copy from the odd power that one copy becomes
part of our D U. and the remaining even power
gets converted using the Pythagorean identity.
In this case, we convert sine squared into
one minus cosine squared. This allows us to
do the use substitution and evaluate the integral.
In this video, we'll evaluate integrals of
trig functions involving only even powers
of sine and cosine. There are three trig identities
that will come in handy here, the first ones
that are familiar, the factory and identity.
The second one's an identity that allows us
to rewrite cosine squared of x in terms of
cosine of 2x. And the third one is in nd that
lets us write sine squared of x. Also in terms
of cosine of 2x. The only difference between
the second and third is the fact that one's
cosine squared and one sine squared. But the
other difference is the plus sign versus the
minus sign here.
To recap, we separated out one copy of cosine
x to be part of our D U. And then we converted
the rest of the cosines in the signs isn't
a Pythagorean identity. This allowed us to
do use of the tuition with u equal to sine
x and evaluate the integral. This same technique
with some modifications works on a lot of
other problems. In this next problem, if we
tried separating out one copy of cosine of
x to be part of our do, we'd run into problems,
because we just have one copy of cosine x
left. And we can't use the Pythagorean identity
can to convert a single cosine into signs.
Well, I guess technically, we could do something
like this. But then we'd have to introduce
a plus or minus sign and a square root sign
into our integrand, which would make things
difficult to integrate. It's a lot easier
if we can just use the cosine squared x is
equal to one minus sine squared x identity
to replace our cosines with signs. But this
identity only applies if we have an even power
of cosines leftover that we want to convert.
So instead of trying to save out a copy of
cosine x, let's say about a copy of sine x
instead. So we'll rewrite our integral as
the integral of sine to the fourth of x times
a sine of x. And we'll keep the cosine squared
x and the dx. Now we want the sine x to be
part of our D U. So let's set u equal to cosine
of x. That way d u is equal to negative sine
of x dx. And so sine of x dx is equal to negative
d U. since u is equal to cosine x, this time,
we want to replace all of our stray signs
with cosines. We know that sine squared of
x is equal to one minus cosine squared of
x by the Pythagorean identity. So let's rewrite
this sine to the fourth as sine squared of
x squared. That allows us to substitute in
one minus cosine squared of x for sine squared
of x And now we can replace everything with
us and d is I'll bring out the negative sign
and multiply things out. One minus u squared
squared is one minus two u squared plus u
to the fourth. And this multiplies out to
us squared minus two u to the fourth plus
u to the sixth. Now I can integrate, distribute
my negative sign. And finally, plug in cosine
of x for you. That completes this problem.
In this video, we'll use use substitution
and the Pythagorean identity. To evaluate
integrals with at least one odd power of sine
or cosine. The idea is to separate off one
copy from the odd power that one copy becomes
part of our D U. and the remaining even power
gets converted using the Pythagorean identity.
In this case, we convert sine squared into
one minus cosine squared. This allows us to
do the use substitution and evaluate the integral.
In this video, we'll evaluate integrals of
trig functions involving only even powers
of sine and cosine. There are three trig identities
that will come in handy here, the first ones
that are familiar, the factory and identity.
The second one's an identity that allows us
to rewrite cosine squared of x in terms of
cosine of 2x. And the third one is in nd that
lets us write sine squared of x. Also in terms
of cosine of 2x. The only difference between
the second and third is the fact that one's
cosine squared and one sine squared. But the
other difference is the plus sign versus the
minus sign here.
Let's start with the simplest possible even
power, the integral of cosine squared x dx.
According to my calculator, this integral
evaluates to sine x cosine x over two plus
x over two. And if I look it up in the back
of my book, I get the integral to be one half
x plus one for a sine of 2x. So what's going
on here? Are these two answers really the
same? Well, yes, because sine of 2x is equal
to two times sine x cosine x. So if I replace
that, here, I get this second answer is equivalent
to one half x plus 1/4 times two sine x cosine
x, which is equivalent to the first answer.
Notice that the calculator on the table in
the back of the book omit the plus c the cost
of integration, but you should always include
them for indefinite integrals. Now let's see
where these answers come from. So let's compute
the integral of cosine squared x dx by hand
that is, without the aid of a calculator or
computer integral table, the hint is that
cosine squared x is equal to one plus cosine
2x over two, or sometimes I like to write
this as one half plus one half cosine of 2x.
So I'll use that identity to rewrite my integral.
Now I can split up the integral using rules
about integration. The integral of one half
is just one half x, and the integral of cosine
of 2x is one half times sine of 2x. It's possible
to get that answer by use substitution with
u equal to x. Or as a shortcut, we can observe
that the derivative of sine of 2x is cosine
of 2x times two, the times two comes from
the chain rule taking the derivative of the
inside. So to get rid of that, or counteract
that, times two, we have to multiply by one
half. In any case, our final answer is then
one half x plus 1/4 sine of 2x plus C. This
is the same answer that we can find using
the integral table in the back of the book.
Please pause the video for a minute and try
to compute the integral of sine squared x
dx. Using a similar technique. You'll want
to use the identity sine squared of x is equal
to one half minus one Half cosine of 2x. If
you rewrite the integral, you can integrate
like before, and get an answer of one half
x minus 1/4 sine of 2x plus C, the same technique
can be used to evaluate a lot of other integrals
involving even powers of sine and cosine,
often with a lot more effort. Let's try evaluating
the integral of sine to the sixth x dx. We
know that sine squared of x is equal to one
half minus one half cosine of 2x. And since
six is an even power, we know we can rewrite
sine to the sixth as sine squared to the x
raised to a power, in this case, the power
of three. Now let's substitute in our identity.
I think I'm going to factor out the one half.
One half cubed is 1/8. So I'll pull the one
eight out of the integral side and multiply
out. Now let me divide up my integral into
pieces. And I'll try to handle each piece
separately. The integral of one dx, that's
easy, that's x, and the integral of cosine
of 2x, that's going to be one half times sine
of 2x, like before. Now to integrate cosine
squared of 2x, we can use the same trick we
used to integrate cosine squared of x, cosine
squared of 2x is going to be one half, plus
one half cosine of two times 2x. So that's
4x.
Let's start with the simplest possible even
power, the integral of cosine squared x dx.
According to my calculator, this integral
evaluates to sine x cosine x over two plus
x
over two. And if I look it up in the back
of my book, I get the integral to be one half
x plus one for a sine of 2x. So what's going
on here? Are these two answers really the
same? Well, yes, because sine of 2x is equal
to two times sine x cosine x. So if I replace
that, here, I get this second answer is equivalent
to one half x plus 1/4 times two sine x cosine
x, which is equivalent to the first answer.
Notice that the calculator on the table in
the back of the book omit the plus c the cost
of integration, but you should always include
them for indefinite integrals. Now let's see
where these answers come from. So let's compute
the integral of cosine squared x dx by hand
that is, without the aid of a calculator or
computer integral table, the hint is that
cosine squared x is equal to one plus cosine
2x over two, or sometimes I like to write
this as one half plus one half cosine of 2x.
So I'll use that identity to rewrite my integral.
Now I can split up the integral using rules
about integration. The integral of one half
is just one half x, and the integral of cosine
of 2x is one half times sine of 2x. It's possible
to get that answer by use substitution with
u equal to x. Or as a shortcut, we can observe
that the derivative of sine of 2x is cosine
of 2x times two, the times two comes from
the chain rule taking the derivative of the
inside. So to get rid of that, or counteract
that, times two, we have to multiply by one
half. In any case, our final answer is then
one half x plus 1/4 sine of 2x plus C. This
is the same answer that we can find using
the integral table in the back of the book.
Please pause the video for a minute and try
to compute the integral of sine squared x
dx. Using a similar technique. You'll want
to use the identity sine squared of x is equal
to one half minus one Half cosine of 2x. If
you rewrite the integral, you can integrate
like before, and get an answer of one half
x minus 1/4 sine of 2x plus C, the same technique
can be used to evaluate a lot of other integrals
involving even powers of sine and cosine,
often with a lot more effort. Let's try evaluating
the integral of sine to the sixth x dx. We
know that sine squared of x is equal to one
half minus one half cosine of 2x. And since
six is an even power, we know we can rewrite
sine to the sixth as sine squared to the x
raised to a power, in this case, the power
of three. Now let's substitute in our identity.
I think I'm going to factor out the one half.
One half cubed is 1/8. So I'll pull the one
eight out of the integral side and multiply
out. Now let me divide up my integral into
pieces. And I'll try to handle each piece
separately. The integral of one dx, that's
easy, that's x, and the integral of cosine
of 2x, that's going to be one half times sine
of 2x, like before. Now to integrate cosine
squared of 2x, we can use the same trick we
used to integrate cosine squared of x, cosine
squared of 2x is going to be one half, plus
one half cosine of two times 2x. So that's
4x.
And finally, to integrate cosine cubed of
2x, well, cosine cubed is an odd power, so
we can use our odd power trick and save aside
one copy of cosine, and turn the remaining
cosine squared into one minus sine squared.
So that looks like this. Notice we have one
minus sine squared of 2x. Because we're replacing
a cosine squared of 2x. I'll copy the first
part down. Now integrate one half to get one
half x, and I'll integrate one half cosine
of forex. To get one half times 1/4 sine of
forex, we need the 1/4. To counteract the
four that we get by taking the derivative
of sine of 4x. And using the chain rule, we
can finish off the integration by using a
use substitution here where u is sine of 2x.
And so d u is two cosine of 2x. So we can
replace this integral here with minus the
integral of one minus us squared times, one
half do I'll copy the first part down again.
and integrate that last part, I'll pull out
the negative a half, and I get you minus 1/3
u cubed, I need a plus C. Now. I'll plug back
in for you and simplify a little bit. And
I get a final answer of five sixteenths x
minus one for sine of 2x plus 360 fourths
sine of 4x plus 148, sine cubed of 2x. Oh,
and we need a plus C here. That's a complicated
answer. And it was a complicated computation.
But it was all based on the same sort of tricks
as before, using identities like this one,
to handle even powers of sine and cosine,
and using the Pythagorean identity to handle
odd powers. In this video, we use these last
two identities to rewrite even powers of cosine
and sine in terms of lower powers of cosine.
This trick can be used to compute the integrals
of complicated even powers of sine and cosine,
provided that you have a lot of time and patience
on hand. This video is about some special
trig integrals, namely, the integral of tangent
squared of x and the integral of secant of
x. these integrals are special only in the
sense that there's some special tricks required
to integrate them. When I come across the
integral of tangent squared X, I find myself
wishing that I could integrate secant squared
x instead, because integrating secant squared
x is easy. It's just tangent x plus c since
the derivative of a tangent secant squared.
But happily, I know how to rewrite tangent
squared in terms of secant, because tangent
squared is secant squared minus one. So I'll
just rewrite this integral as the integral
of secant squared minus one. And that integrates
easily to tangent of x minus x plus C. The
same sort of trick works to integrate cotangent
squared of x, since there's a similar identity,
relating cotangent and cosecant every now
and then, you have to integrate secant of
x. There's several possible tricks that can
be used to do this. One of them is to multiply
secant x by secant x plus tangent x in the
numerator and denominator. Now distributing,
we get seacon squared x plus seek index tangent
x in the numerator, and secant x plus tangent
x in the denominator. Since secant squared
is the derivative of tangent, and secant tangent
is the root of a secant. We can say u equal
to secant x plus tangent x and have d u, sitting
right where we want it in the integrand.
And finally, to integrate cosine cubed of
2x, well, cosine cubed is an odd power, so
we can use our odd power trick and save aside
one copy of cosine, and turn the remaining
cosine squared into one minus sine squared.
So that looks like this. Notice we have one
minus sine squared of 2x. Because we're replacing
a cosine squared of 2x. I'll copy the first
part down. Now integrate one half to get one
half x, and I'll integrate one half cosine
of forex. To get one half times 1/4 sine of
forex, we need the 1/4. To counteract the
four that we get by taking the derivative
of sine of 4x. And using the chain rule, we
can finish off the integration by using a
use substitution here where u is sine of 2x.
And so d u is two cosine of 2x. So we can
replace this integral here with minus the
integral of one minus us squared times, one
half do I'll copy the first part down again.
and integrate that last part, I'll pull out
the negative a half, and I get you minus 1/3
u cubed, I need a plus C. Now. I'll plug back
in for you and simplify a little bit. And
I get a final answer of five sixteenths x
minus one for sine of 2x plus 360 fourths
sine of 4x plus 148, sine cubed of 2x. Oh,
and we need a plus C here. That's a complicated
answer. And it was a complicated computation.
But it was all based on the same sort of tricks
as before, using identities like this one,
to handle even powers of sine and cosine,
and using the Pythagorean identity to handle
odd powers. In this video, we use these last
two identities to rewrite even powers of cosine
and sine in terms of lower powers of cosine.
This trick can be used to compute the integrals
of complicated even powers of sine and cosine,
provided that you have a lot of time and patience
on hand. This video is about some special
trig integrals, namely, the integral of tangent
squared of x and the integral of secant of
x. these integrals are special only in the
sense that there's some special tricks required
to integrate them. When I come across the
integral of tangent squared X, I find myself
wishing that I could integrate secant squared
x instead, because integrating secant squared
x is easy. It's just tangent x plus c since
the derivative of a tangent secant squared.
But happily, I know how to rewrite tangent
squared in terms of secant, because tangent
squared is secant squared minus one. So I'll
just rewrite this integral as the integral
of secant squared minus one. And that integrates
easily to tangent of x minus x plus C. The
same sort of trick works to integrate cotangent
squared of x, since there's a similar identity,
relating cotangent and cosecant every now
and then, you have to integrate secant of
x. There's several possible tricks that can
be used to do this. One of them is to multiply
secant x by secant x plus tangent x in the
numerator and denominator. Now distributing,
we get seacon squared x plus seek index tangent
x in the numerator, and secant x plus tangent
x in the denominator. Since secant squared
is the derivative of tangent, and secant tangent
is the root of a secant. We can say u equal
to secant x plus tangent x and have d u, sitting
right where we want it in the integrand.
So now we just have to integrate one over
u d u, which is the ln of u plus C. And now
plugging back in for you, we get that our
original integral of seeking dx evaluates
to the natural log of secant x plus tangent
x plus a constant. A similar trick can be
used to evaluate the integral of cosecant
x. And that's all for the integral of tangent
squared, and the integral of secant. This
video introduces the technique of trig substitution
to evaluate integrals involving square root
signs like this one. There are a few trig
identities that are especially useful for
this technique. The first one's the Pythagorean
identity. And the second is the related identity
that involves tangent and secant. There's
also a third related identity that involves
cotangent cosecant. This one could also be
used in the method of tree substitution, although
it doesn't come up as often as the first two.
As our first example, let's look at the integral
of x squared over the square root of 49 minus
x squared. According to Wolfram Alpha, this
integral evaluates to this expression involving
a square root expression kind of an as expected
and a sine inverse, which just sort of come
seems to come out of the blue here. Let's
see where this answer comes from. Using a
trig substitution. The inverse sine function
in the answer gives us a hint that we may
want to substitute in something related to
sign, I'm going to substitute in x equals
seven sine theta. If x is seven sine theta,
then dx is going to be seven cosine theta
d theta. Now I'll substitute in for x and
dx in my integral to get the integral of seven
sine theta squared over the square root of
49 minus seven sine theta squared times seven
cosine theta d theta. let me simplify a little.
I have a seven cubed in the numerator times
sine squared theta cosine theta. And the nominator
I have 49 minus 49 sine squared theta. I'll
factor out the 49 here. And since the square
root of 49 is seven, I can pull a seven out
of the square root sign. Now here is where
a little bit of magic occurs. I know that
one minus sine squared theta is equal to cosine
squared The data by the Pythagorean identity,
and the square root of cosine squared theta
is equal to cosine theta, well, actually,
it's equal to the absolute value of cosine
theta, which is the same thing as cosine theta,
if cosine theta is positive. Or in other words,
if theta is between pi over two, and negative
pi over two, for example, I would really like
to replace my square root of one minus sine
squared theta by just cosine theta, not the
absolute value of cosine theta. So I'm just
going to assume that theta is between negative
pi over two and pi over two when I make my
substitution. This might seem like cheating,
but it's actually legit. Because if you think
about the unit circle, as theta ranges from
negative pi over two to pi over two, well,
cosine is always positive like we want it
to be. But sine is ranging all the way from
negative one to one. And so we can actually
achieve all of the x values between negative
seven and seven this way, which are the only
x values in the domain of our function anyway.
Now if we go back to our integral, we can
actually replace the square root of one minus
sine squared theta with a simple cosine theta,
with success successfully gotten rid of this
tricky square root sign, which is the whole
point behind trig substitution. Now, if we
simplify, we just have to integrate seven
squared sine squared theta, d theta. And this
is a familiar problem that we can solve using
another trig identity.
So now we just have to integrate one over
u d u, which is the ln of u plus C. And now
plugging back in for you, we get that our
original integral of seeking dx evaluates
to the natural log of secant x plus tangent
x plus a constant. A similar trick can be
used to evaluate the integral of cosecant
x. And that's all for the integral of tangent
squared, and the integral of secant. This
video introduces the technique of trig substitution
to evaluate integrals involving square root
signs like this one. There are a few trig
identities that are especially useful for
this technique. The first one's the Pythagorean
identity. And the second is the related identity
that involves tangent and secant. There's
also a third related identity that involves
cotangent cosecant. This one could also be
used in the method of tree substitution, although
it doesn't come up as often as the first two.
As our first example, let's look at the integral
of x squared over the square root of 49 minus
x squared. According to Wolfram Alpha, this
integral evaluates to this expression involving
a square root expression kind of an as expected
and a sine inverse, which just sort of come
seems to come out of the blue here. Let's
see where this answer comes from. Using a
trig substitution. The inverse sine function
in the answer gives us a hint that we may
want to substitute in something related to
sign, I'm going to substitute in x equals
seven sine theta. If x is seven sine theta,
then dx is going to be seven cosine theta
d theta. Now I'll substitute in for x and
dx in my integral to get the integral of seven
sine theta squared over the square root of
49 minus seven sine theta squared times seven
cosine theta d theta. let me simplify a little.
I have a seven cubed in the numerator times
sine squared theta cosine theta. And the nominator
I have 49 minus 49 sine squared theta. I'll
factor out the 49 here. And since the square
root of 49 is seven, I can pull a seven out
of the square root sign. Now here is where
a little bit of magic occurs. I know that
one minus sine squared theta is equal to cosine
squared The data by the Pythagorean identity,
and the square root of cosine squared theta
is equal to cosine theta, well, actually,
it's equal to the absolute value of cosine
theta, which is the same thing as cosine theta,
if cosine theta is positive. Or in other words,
if theta is between pi over two, and negative
pi over two, for example, I would really like
to replace my square root of one minus sine
squared theta by just cosine theta, not the
absolute value of cosine theta. So I'm just
going to assume that theta is between negative
pi over two and pi over two when I make my
substitution. This might seem like cheating,
but it's actually legit. Because if you think
about the unit circle, as theta ranges from
negative pi over two to pi over two, well,
cosine is always positive like we want it
to be. But sine is ranging all the way from
negative one to one. And so we can actually
achieve all of the x values between negative
seven and seven this way, which are the only
x values in the domain of our function anyway.
Now if we go back to our integral, we can
actually replace the square root of one minus
sine squared theta with a simple cosine theta,
with success successfully gotten rid of this
tricky square root sign, which is the whole
point behind trig substitution. Now, if we
simplify, we just have to integrate seven
squared sine squared theta, d theta. And this
is a familiar problem that we can solve using
another trig identity.
Now we've got an integral we can compute.
So the integral of one half is one half theta,
and the integral of cosine of two theta is
one half sine of two theta. So let me add
my constant of integration. And I'm almost
done, almost, but not quite. Because this
answer is in terms of theta, and my original
problem was in terms of x. Now I know that
x and theta are related, according to this
equation here. So if I solve for theta, I
get sine theta is equal to x over seven. So
theta is inverse sine or arc sine of x over
seven. So I could just plug in for theta here
and get seven squared, that's 49 times one
half sine inverse x over seven minus one half
times one half is 1/4. sine of two times sine
inverse x over seven plus C. This is a correct
answer. But it's very awkward looking sine
of twice sine inverse x over seven, there's
got to be a way to simplify this. Unfortunately,
we can't just pull the two out and cancel
the sign with a sine inverse, because sine
does work that way. But instead, we can use
the double angle formula. So we can rewrite
sine of two theta as twice sine theta cosine
theta. So let me ignore this line for now.
And I'll rewrite the above line as 49 times
one half theta, minus 1/4 times twice sine
theta, cosine theta
Now we've got an integral we can compute.
So the integral of one half is one half theta,
and the integral of cosine of two theta is
one half sine of two theta. So let me add
my constant of integration. And I'm almost
done, almost, but not quite. Because this
answer is in terms of theta, and my original
problem was in terms of x. Now I know that
x and theta are related, according to this
equation here. So if I solve for theta, I
get sine theta is equal to x over seven. So
theta is inverse sine or arc sine of x over
seven. So I could just plug in for theta here
and get seven squared, that's 49 times one
half sine inverse x over seven minus one half
times one half is 1/4. sine of two times sine
inverse x over seven plus C. This is a correct
answer. But it's very awkward looking sine
of twice sine inverse x over seven, there's
got to be a way to simplify this. Unfortunately,
we can't just pull the two out and cancel
the sign with a sine inverse, because sine
does work that way. But instead, we can use
the double angle formula. So we can rewrite
sine of two theta as twice sine theta cosine
theta. So let me ignore this line for now.
And I'll rewrite the above line as 49 times
one half theta, minus 1/4 times twice sine
theta, cosine theta
plus C.
Now there's one more trick we need to use.
And that trick is to draw a right triangle.
I'm going to label the sides of that triangle
using the equation for the substitution we
made, or this equivalent forms a little easier
to use. So since sine theta is x over seven,
if I label one of my angles as theta, then
the opposite side needs to have a measure
of x, and I have partners should have a measure
of seven. You can check that by the Pythagorean
Theorem, that means that this bottom side
needs to have a measure of the square root
of 49 minus x squared. Notice that that's
exactly the same expression that was in our
original integrand. Once we have the triangle
labeled, we can use it to find expressions
for sine of theta and cosine of theta in terms
of x. So Sine of theta is opposite of our
hypothesis. So that's x over seven. Well,
we already knew that. But now cosine of theta
is adjacent over hypotenuse. So that's the
square root of 49 minus x squared over seven.
We can use these two equations to substitute
in for sine theta and cosine theta. And to
get rid of the, this naked theta here, we'll
still have to use the fact that theta is inverse
sine of x over seven. Those substitutions
lead us to this answer. And a little bit of
simplification leads us to the same answer
that Wolfram Alpha gave us. This was a complicated
problem. But the key step was to use this
trig substitution. And then, that allowed
us to use a trig identity in order to rewrite
our square root and get rid of the square
root. After that, it was a fairly routine
integration problem, until we got to the point
where we had to substitute back in for theta,
and then drawing the right triangle helped
us figure out what to do. In this video, we
use two trig substitution to evaluate an integral
with a square root and that This video introduces
the method of partial fractions as a way to
integrate many rational functions. Recall
that a rational function is a function of
the form a polynomial divided by another polynomial.
Let's work out the integral of 3x plus two
divided by x squared plus 2x minus three.
According to Wolfram Alpha, the integral evaluates
to this expression involving the log of x
minus one and the log of x plus three. So
what do x minus one and x plus three have
to do with our original rational function,
I challenge you to pause the video for a moment
and try to figure this out. You might have
noticed that the denominator x squared plus
2x minus three factors into x minus one times
x plus three. Let's look at what happens if
I take two separate fractions, one with denominator
x minus one and one with denominator x plus
three and add them up. The common denominator
of these two fractions is x minus one times
x plus three. So when I add these fractions
together using standard algebra, I should
get a fraction with common denominator, x
minus one times x plus three. Well, my original
rational function was just such a fraction.
So it seems plausible, that I might be able
to find numbers, a and b, so that these two
partial fractions add up to this original
fraction. Let's figure out what numbers a
and b might make this work. To solve for A
and B, I'm going to clear the denominator
by multiplying both sides of my equation by
this least common denominator, x minus 1x
plus three. When I distribute on the left
side, I get x plus three times a plus x minus
one times B. And on the right side, my x minus
one and x plus three cancel out to give me
3x plus two. I'll distribute the left side
a little further. And I'm going to group the
terms that involve x and the terms that don't
involve x. If I want this equation to hold
true for all values of x, then I need the
coefficients of x to be the same on the left
and the right.
Now there's one more trick we need to use.
And that trick is to draw a right triangle.
I'm going to label the sides of that triangle
using the equation for the substitution we
made, or this equivalent forms a little easier
to use. So since sine theta is x over seven,
if I label one of my angles as theta, then
the opposite side needs to have a measure
of x, and I have partners should have a measure
of seven. You can check that by the Pythagorean
Theorem, that means that this bottom side
needs to have a measure of the square root
of 49 minus x squared. Notice that that's
exactly the same expression that was in our
original integrand. Once we have the triangle
labeled, we can use it to find expressions
for sine of theta and cosine of theta in terms
of x. So Sine of theta is opposite of our
hypothesis. So that's x over seven. Well,
we already knew that. But now cosine of theta
is adjacent over hypotenuse. So that's the
square root of 49 minus x squared over seven.
We can use these two equations to substitute
in for sine theta and cosine theta. And to
get rid of the, this naked theta here, we'll
still have to use the fact that theta is inverse
sine of x over seven. Those substitutions
lead us to this answer. And a little bit of
simplification leads us to the same answer
that Wolfram Alpha gave us. This was a complicated
problem. But the key step was to use this
trig substitution. And then, that allowed
us to use a trig identity in order to rewrite
our square root and get rid of the square
root. After that, it was a fairly routine
integration problem, until we got to the point
where we had to substitute back in for theta,
and then drawing the right triangle helped
us figure out what to do. In this video, we
use two trig substitution to evaluate an integral
with a square root and that This video introduces
the method of partial fractions as a way to
integrate many rational functions. Recall
that a rational function is a function of
the form a polynomial divided by another polynomial.
Let's work out the integral of 3x plus two
divided by x squared plus 2x minus three.
According to Wolfram Alpha, the integral evaluates
to this expression involving the log of x
minus one and the log of x plus three. So
what do x minus one and x plus three have
to do with our original rational function,
I challenge you to pause the video for a moment
and try to figure this out. You might have
noticed that the denominator x squared plus
2x minus three factors into x minus one times
x plus three. Let's look at what happens if
I take two separate fractions, one with denominator
x minus one and one with denominator x plus
three and add them up. The common denominator
of these two fractions is x minus one times
x plus three. So when I add these fractions
together using standard algebra, I should
get a fraction with common denominator, x
minus one times x plus three. Well, my original
rational function was just such a fraction.
So it seems plausible, that I might be able
to find numbers, a and b, so that these two
partial fractions add up to this original
fraction. Let's figure out what numbers a
and b might make this work. To solve for A
and B, I'm going to clear the denominator
by multiplying both sides of my equation by
this least common denominator, x minus 1x
plus three. When I distribute on the left
side, I get x plus three times a plus x minus
one times B. And on the right side, my x minus
one and x plus three cancel out to give me
3x plus two. I'll distribute the left side
a little further. And I'm going to group the
terms that involve x and the terms that don't
involve x. If I want this equation to hold
true for all values of x, then I need the
coefficients of x to be the same on the left
and the right.
So I need a plus b to equal three. Similarly,
I need the constant term to be the same on
the left and the right. So I need three A
minus B to equal two. I now have two linear
equations in the two unknowns, a and b. So
I can use standard algebra to solve these
equations for A and B. For example, if I add
the two equations together, the B and negative
b cancel out to give me four A equals five,
and so a equals five fourths. And then I can
substitute in this five fourths into either
one of my equations and solve for b. So I
was able to find an a value of a and b that
let me rewrite the original fraction as to
partial fractions. Let me fill those values
of a and b in here. Now to calculate the integral
of my original expression, I can calculate
the integral of my partial fractions. Instead,
I split up my integrals here. Now the integral
of one over x minus one is natural log of
absolute value of x minus one, you can check
this by taking the derivative. Or you can
do a simple use of the tuition where you as
x minus one to compute this integral. Similarly,
the integral of one over x plus three is natural
log of absolute value of x plus three. This
completes the computation of the integral
using the method of partial fractions. Recall
that after factoring our denominator, the
key step in this process was finding numbers
a and b that made this equation hold. And
you might wonder, Well, yeah, it work this
time. But can we always find numbers a and
b that will work like that? What if our numerator
had been something different? What if our
numerator had been instead something like,
say 7x minus 15? Could we have still found
an A and B that worked? Well, yes, because
we still would have gotten two linear equations
in two unknowns down here, and we would have
been able to solve them, we'd get different
values of a and b, but we still would have
been able to find a solution. Even if our
numerator had just been a number, like six,
we still couldn't use the same method, we
could have thought of this as 0x plus six.
And we could have used the same equations
down here, where A plus B would have to equals
zero, and three, A minus B would have to equal
six. So we still have two equations and two
unknowns to solve for. In fact, if you think
about it for a while, you may be able to convince
yourself that this method will always work
if you have two conditions. First, the denominator
factors into distinct linear factors. By a
linear factor, I just mean that the factor
can be written like a number times x plus
another number, with no x squared or anything
in it. And by distinct, I just mean that these
two factors are different from each other.
The second condition is that the degree of
the numerator is lower than the degree of
the denominator. The second condition guarantee
is that we'll have the same number of unknowns
here, A and B, as we do coefficients here,
three, and two, so that we'll have equations
that we'll be able to solve for our unknowns.
As a technical note, that distinctness of
the linear factors guarantees that we won't
have contradictory equations. If we have these
two conditions, then we can proceed to integrate,
like we did in this example. In fact, this
method even works if we have more than two
linear factors, in our denominator, we can
have three or four, any number of distinct
linear factors, it'll just get a little bit
more complicated, because we'll have more
constants and more equations to solve for
those constants. There are also several related
methods that allow us to integrate rational
functions, even if the denominator factors
into linear factors that aren't necessarily
distinct. Or even if we can't get all the
way down to linear factors, and some of our
factors have squares in them, or even if the
degree of the numerator is too big. But I
won't get into the details of those related
methods. In this video, you'll have to read
about them in the book or wait for class or
wait for a future video to find out more.
In this video, we integrated a rational function
by splitting up the fraction into two partial
fractions.
So I need a plus b to equal three. Similarly,
I need the constant term to be the same on
the left and the right. So I need three A
minus B to equal two. I now have two linear
equations in the two unknowns, a and b. So
I can use standard algebra to solve these
equations for A and B. For example, if I add
the two equations together, the B and negative
b cancel out to give me four A equals five,
and so a equals five fourths. And then I can
substitute in this five fourths into either
one of my equations and solve for b. So I
was able to find an a value of a and b that
let me rewrite the original fraction as to
partial fractions. Let me fill those values
of a and b in here. Now to calculate the integral
of my original expression, I can calculate
the integral of my partial fractions. Instead,
I split up my integrals here. Now the integral
of one over x minus one is natural log of
absolute value of x minus one, you can check
this by taking the derivative. Or you can
do a simple use of the tuition where you as
x minus one to compute this integral. Similarly,
the integral of one over x plus three is natural
log of absolute value of x plus three. This
completes the computation of the integral
using the method of partial fractions. Recall
that after factoring our denominator, the
key step in this process was finding numbers
a and b that made this equation hold. And
you might wonder, Well, yeah, it work this
time. But can we always find numbers a and
b that will work like that? What if our numerator
had been something different? What if our
numerator had been instead something like,
say 7x minus 15? Could we have still found
an A and B that worked? Well, yes, because
we still would have gotten two linear equations
in two unknowns down here, and we would have
been able to solve them, we'd get different
values of a and b, but we still would have
been able to find a solution. Even if our
numerator had just been a number, like six,
we still couldn't use the same method, we
could have thought of this as 0x plus six.
And we could have used the same equations
down here, where A plus B would have to equals
zero, and three, A minus B would have to equal
six. So we still have two equations and two
unknowns to solve for. In fact, if you think
about it for a while, you may be able to convince
yourself that this method will always work
if you have two conditions. First, the denominator
factors into distinct linear factors. By a
linear factor, I just mean that the factor
can be written like a number times x plus
another number, with no x squared or anything
in it. And by distinct, I just mean that these
two factors are different from each other.
The second condition is that the degree of
the numerator is lower than the degree of
the denominator. The second condition guarantee
is that we'll have the same number of unknowns
here, A and B, as we do coefficients here,
three, and two, so that we'll have equations
that we'll be able to solve for our unknowns.
As a technical note, that distinctness of
the linear factors guarantees that we won't
have contradictory equations. If we have these
two conditions, then we can proceed to integrate,
like we did in this example. In fact, this
method even works if we have more than two
linear factors, in our denominator, we can
have three or four, any number of distinct
linear factors, it'll just get a little bit
more complicated, because we'll have more
constants and more equations to solve for
those constants. There are also several related
methods that allow us to integrate rational
functions, even if the denominator factors
into linear factors that aren't necessarily
distinct. Or even if we can't get all the
way down to linear factors, and some of our
factors have squares in them, or even if the
degree of the numerator is too big. But I
won't get into the details of those related
methods. In this video, you'll have to read
about them in the book or wait for class or
wait for a future video to find out more.
In this video, we integrated a rational function
by splitting up the fraction into two partial
fractions.
This video is about improper integrals, especially
the first type, which I'll define in a moment.
Two examples of improper integrals are the
integral from one to infinity of one over
x squared dx, and the integral from zero to
pi over two of tan x dx. What makes these
integrals improper? Well, in the first example,
it's this infinity in the bound of integration.
And then the second example, is the fact that
the function, tan of x itself goes to infinity
on the interval from zero to pi over two where
we're integrating. So an integral is called
improper. If either of these two situations
occur. It's called a type one improper integral
if we're integrating over an infinite interval.
In other words, there's an infinity or negative
infinity somewhere in the bounds of integration.
So the first example, is a type one improper
integral. A type two improper integral occurs
when the function that we're integrating itself
has an infinite discontinuity on the interval.
by an infinite discontinuity, I mean the function
is going to infinity or negative infinity,
this is also called a vertical asymptote.
This vertical asymptote could occur in the
interior of the interval we're integrating
over. Or, as in this example, it could occur
on the endpoint of that interval of integration.
Now, it's possible that both of these situations
could occur for the same integral. And that's
also an improper integral. This video will
focus on type one improper integrals. A type
one improper integral, asks us to integrate
over an infinite interval. To do this, we
take the integral over larger and larger finite
intervals and take the limit. So for example,
to find the integral from one to infinity
of one over x squared dx, we'll evaluate the
integral from one to some finite number T,
and then take the limit as t goes off to infinity.
In symbols, we can write the limit as t goes
to infinity of the integral from one to T
of one over x squared dx. Since one over x
squared is the same thing as x to the minus
two, we can integrate it to get negative x
to the minus one evaluated between one and
T, and then take that limit or rewrite this
as negative one over x and evaluate on the
bounds of integration. as t goes to infinity,
one over t goes to zero. So the limit just
comes from this expression, which evaluates
to one. If we think of it, the integral is
representing area, this is a little surprising.
Even though we're taking the area of an infinitely
long region, the area still evaluates to a
finite number of one. In this situation, we
say that the improper integral converges.
So in general, the improper integral from
some finite number a
to infinity of f of x dx is defined as the
limit as t goes to infinity of the integral
from a to T of f of x dx. We say that the
integral converges if this limit exists as
a finite number. And we say that the integral
diverges if the limit is infinity, or negative
infinity, or if it doesn't exist. Similarly,
we evaluate the integral from negative infinity
to some finite number by taking bigger and
bigger intervals that extend off to negative
infinity. That is, this integral is defined
as the limit as the left endpoint t goes to
negative infinity of the integral from t to
b of f of x dx. We say that this integral
converges if the limit exists as a finite
number, and diverges otherwise. So to evaluate
the integral from negative infinity to negative
one of one over x dx, we take the limit as
t goes to negative infinity
This video is about improper integrals, especially
the first type, which I'll define in a moment.
Two examples of improper integrals are the
integral from one to infinity of one over
x squared dx, and the integral from zero to
pi over two of tan x dx. What makes these
integrals improper? Well, in the first example,
it's this infinity in the bound of integration.
And then the second example, is the fact that
the function, tan of x itself goes to infinity
on the interval from zero to pi over two where
we're integrating. So an integral is called
improper. If either of these two situations
occur. It's called a type one improper integral
if we're integrating over an infinite interval.
In other words, there's an infinity or negative
infinity somewhere in the bounds of integration.
So the first example, is a type one improper
integral. A type two improper integral occurs
when the function that we're integrating itself
has an infinite discontinuity on the interval.
by an infinite discontinuity, I mean the function
is going to infinity or negative infinity,
this is also called a vertical asymptote.
This vertical asymptote could occur in the
interior of the interval we're integrating
over. Or, as in this example, it could occur
on the endpoint of that interval of integration.
Now, it's possible that both of these situations
could occur for the same integral. And that's
also an improper integral. This video will
focus on type one improper integrals. A type
one improper integral, asks us to integrate
over an infinite interval. To do this, we
take the integral over larger and larger finite
intervals and take the limit. So for example,
to find the integral from one to infinity
of one over x squared dx, we'll evaluate the
integral from one to some finite number T,
and then take the limit as t goes off to infinity.
In symbols, we can write the limit as t goes
to infinity of the integral from one to T
of one over x squared dx. Since one over x
squared is the same thing as x to the minus
two, we can integrate it to get negative x
to the minus one evaluated between one and
T, and then take that limit or rewrite this
as negative one over x and evaluate on the
bounds of integration. as t goes to infinity,
one over t goes to zero. So the limit just
comes from this expression, which evaluates
to one. If we think of it, the integral is
representing area, this is a little surprising.
Even though we're taking the area of an infinitely
long region, the area still evaluates to a
finite number of one. In this situation, we
say that the improper integral converges.
So in general, the improper integral from
some finite number a to infinity of f of x
dx is defined as the limit as t goes to infinity
of the integral from a to T of f of x dx.
We say that the integral converges if this
limit exists as a finite number. And we say
that the integral diverges if the limit is
infinity, or negative infinity, or if it doesn't
exist. Similarly, we evaluate the integral
from negative infinity to some finite number
by taking bigger and bigger intervals that
extend off to negative infinity. That is,
this integral is defined as the limit as the
left endpoint t goes to negative infinity
of the integral from t to b of f of x dx.
We say that this integral converges if the
limit exists as a finite number, and diverges
otherwise. So to evaluate the integral from
negative infinity to negative one of one over
x dx, we take the limit as t goes to negative
infinity
of the integral from t to negative one of
one over x dx. Now the integral of one over
x is ln of the absolute value of x, which
will need to integrate between t and negative
one and take a limit. We evaluate here we
know that ln of the absolute value of negative
one, that's ln of one which is zero. A graph
of ln is helpful for evaluating the rest of
this expression. as t goes to negative infinity,
the absolute value of t is going to infinity.
And so ln is also going to infinity. Therefore,
our limit is actually negative infinity, and
so the integral diverges. In this video, we
evaluated improper integrals Which the interval
that we're integrating over is infinite by
looking at the integrals over larger and larger,
finite intervals and taking a limit. This
video is about type two improper integrals.
These are integrals for which the interval
that we're integrating over is finite. But
the function that we're integrating goes to
infinity on that interval. To integrate a
type to improper integral like this one, or
this one, we integrate our function over a
larger and larger sub intervals on which the
function is finite. And then we take a limit.
So in this first picture, where the function
approaches infinity, as x goes to be from
the left, we can call that moving endpoint
T. and evaluate the integral as the limit
as that right endpoint t approaches B from
the left of the integral from a to T of f
of x dx. The same definition works if f of
x is going to negative infinity instead of
infinity. In the second picture here, we again
want to take a limit of integrals over sub
intervals on which the function is finite.
So in symbols, that says that if f goes to
infinity or negative infinity, as x goes to
a from the positive side, then the integral
from a to b of f of x dx is going to be the
limit as t goes to a from the right of the
integral from t to b of f of x dx. As an example,
let's find the area under the curve y equals
x over the square root of x squared minus
one between the lines of x equals one and
x equals two. That area can be described as
the integral from one to two of our function.
But this is an improper integral, because
the function is going to infinity, as x goes
to one from the right. So we'll evaluate it
by taking the limit as t goes to one from
the right of the integral from t to two of
the function. I'll compute this integral using
u substitution, where u is x squared minus
one, and d u is 2x dx. Since I see an x dx,
in my integrand, here, I'll solve for x dx,
and I get x dx is equal to one half deal.
I'm also going to change my bounds of integration,
when x is equal to t. That means u is equal
to t squared minus one. And when x is equal
to two, u is two squared minus one, that's
three. So I'll rewrite my integral x dx is
the same thing as one half d u, and my square
root of x squared minus one becomes a square
root of u in the denominator. Rewrite again,
by pulling the one half out of the integral
and rewriting the square root of u in the
denominator as u to the negative one half.
Now I can integrate, I get two times you to
the one half evaluated between three and t
squared minus one, my one half and two cancel,
and I'll plug in my bounds of integration
here. Now, as t goes to one from the right,
t squared is also going to one, so t squared
minus one is going to zero.
of the integral from t to negative one of
one over x dx. Now the integral of one over
x is ln of the absolute value of x, which
will need to integrate between t and negative
one and take a limit. We evaluate here we
know that ln of the absolute value of negative
one, that's ln of one which is zero. A graph
of ln is helpful for evaluating the rest of
this expression. as t goes to negative infinity,
the absolute value of t is going to infinity.
And so ln is also going to infinity. Therefore,
our limit is actually negative infinity, and
so the integral diverges. In this video, we
evaluated improper integrals Which the interval
that we're integrating over is infinite by
looking at the integrals over larger and larger,
finite intervals and taking a limit. This
video is about type two improper integrals.
These are integrals for which the interval
that we're integrating over is finite. But
the function that we're integrating goes to
infinity on that interval. To integrate a
type to improper integral like this one, or
this one, we integrate our function over a
larger and larger sub intervals on which the
function is finite. And then we take a limit.
So in this first picture, where the function
approaches infinity, as x goes to be from
the left, we can call that moving endpoint
T. and evaluate the integral as the limit
as that right endpoint t approaches B from
the left of the integral from a to T of f
of x dx. The same definition works if f of
x is going to negative infinity instead of
infinity. In the second picture here, we again
want to take a limit of integrals over sub
intervals on which the function is finite.
So in symbols, that says that if f goes to
infinity or negative infinity, as x goes to
a from the positive side, then the integral
from a to b of f of x dx is going to be the
limit as t goes to a from the right of the
integral from t to b of f of x dx. As an example,
let's find the area under the curve y equals
x over the square root of x squared minus
one between the lines of x equals one and
x equals two. That area can be described as
the integral from one to two of our function.
But this is an improper integral, because
the function is going to infinity, as x goes
to one from the right. So we'll evaluate it
by taking the limit as t goes to one from
the right of the integral from t to two of
the function. I'll compute this integral using
u substitution, where u is x squared minus
one, and d u is 2x dx. Since I see an x dx,
in my integrand, here, I'll solve for x dx,
and I get x dx is equal to one half deal.
I'm also going to change my bounds of integration,
when x is equal to t. That means u is equal
to t squared minus one. And when x is equal
to two, u is two squared minus one, that's
three. So I'll rewrite my integral x dx is
the same thing as one half d u, and my square
root of x squared minus one becomes a square
root of u in the denominator. Rewrite again,
by pulling the one half out of the integral
and rewriting the square root of u in the
denominator as u to the negative one half.
Now I can integrate, I get two times you to
the one half evaluated between three and t
squared minus one, my one half and two cancel,
and I'll plug in my bounds of integration
here. Now, as t goes to one from the right,
t squared is also going to one, so t squared
minus one is going to zero.
Therefore, my limit is just three to the one
half, or square root of three. And that's
the area underneath my curve. This video was
about type two improper integrals, and how
to compute them as the limit of integrals
over larger and larger sub intervals on which
the function is finite. Sometimes we don't
really care what the value of an improper
integral is, we just want to know whether
it's finite or infinite, whether it converges
or diverges. In this situation, the comparison
theorem can be very handy. The comparison
theorem can allow us to determine if an integral
converges or diverges without actually having
to evaluate the integral instead by comparing
it to the integral of a function that we know
converges or diverges. So suppose that g of
x and f of x are both positive valued functions.
They're both greater than zero for all x's
on the interval A B. And let's suppose also
that g of x is less than f of x on that interval
a, b. here, A or B could be infinity or negative
infinity. So in the picture, we'll call this
blue function, g of x, and the orange function,
f of x. And let's consider the interval from
one to infinity, where g of x is less than
f of x, and both of them are bigger than zero.
Now, if we already know that the integral
of f of x on this interval converges to a
finite number, then g of x, which is less
than f of x also has to converge to a finite
number. So if the integral of f of x converges,
then g of x converges. If we turn this around,
we can say that if g of x diverges, so it
doesn't converge to a finite number, then
f of x has to diverged also. So in the situation
where the integral of the bigger function
converges, or the integral of the smaller
function diverges, then we can make some conclusions
about the integral the other function, but
you have to be a little careful about this.
Because if instead, the integral of the bigger
function diverges, then we really can't make
any conclusions at all about the integral
of the smaller function, it could also diverged
or it could be small enough to converge as
similarly, if the integral of the smaller
function converges, then we really just don't
know anything about the integral of the bigger
function, it could converge, or it could divert.
Let's look at an example. Suppose we want
to find out if the integral from two to infinity
of two plus sine x over square root of x dx
converges or diverges. Instead of trying to
evaluate it, which could get tricky, because
of the sine x and the square root of x in
here, I'm going to just try to compare it
to something that I know converges or diverges.
The first thing that I notice is that sine
of x is bounded. It's always between one and
negative one. And that means that the numerator
two plus sine x is always going to be in between
three and one. Therefore, the function two
plus sine x over square root of x is going
to be between three over square root of x
and one over square root of x. Here's the
general idea of the picture. Now the comparison
theorem tells us that if our function is less
than a function whose interval converges,
then the integral of our current function
will converge. And if our function is greater
than a function whose integral diverges than
the integral of our function will diverged.
So which one of these two inequalities if
we want to use depends on what happens to
the integral of these functions on the ends?
Now we know that the integral of one over
the square root of x dx from two to infinity
has to die verge. That's because this is a
p function, where p is equal to one half,
which is less than one, the integral from
two to infinity of three over the square root
of x dx also diverges since it's just three
times the other integral. So if we want to
compare our function to a function whose integral
diverges, it It better be bigger than that
divergent integral in order to get any useful
information out of it being less than a function
whose integral diverges doesn't tell us anything.
So we need to focus on this inequality.
Therefore, my limit is just three to the one
half, or square root of three. And that's
the area underneath my curve. This video was
about type two improper integrals, and how
to compute them as the limit of integrals
over larger and larger sub intervals on which
the function is finite. Sometimes we don't
really care what the value of an improper
integral is, we just want to know whether
it's finite or infinite, whether it converges
or diverges. In this situation, the comparison
theorem can be very handy. The comparison
theorem can allow us to determine if an integral
converges or diverges without actually having
to evaluate the integral instead by comparing
it to the integral of a function that we know
converges or diverges. So suppose that g of
x and f of x are both positive valued functions.
They're both greater than zero for all x's
on the interval A B. And let's suppose also
that g of x is less than f of x on that interval
a, b. here, A or B could be infinity or negative
infinity. So in the picture, we'll call this
blue function, g of x, and the orange function,
f of x. And let's consider the interval from
one to infinity, where g of x is less than
f of x, and both of them are bigger than zero.
Now, if we already know that the integral
of f of x on this interval converges to a
finite number, then g of x, which is less
than f of x also has to converge to a finite
number. So if the integral of f of x converges,
then g of x converges. If we turn this around,
we can say that if g of x diverges, so it
doesn't converge to a finite number, then
f of x has to diverged also. So in the situation
where the integral of the bigger function
converges, or the integral of the smaller
function diverges, then we can make some conclusions
about the integral the other function, but
you have to be a little careful about this.
Because if instead, the integral of the bigger
function diverges, then we really can't make
any conclusions at all about the integral
of the smaller function, it could also diverged
or it could be small enough to converge as
similarly, if the integral of the smaller
function converges, then we really just don't
know anything about the integral of the bigger
function, it could converge, or it could divert.
Let's look at an example. Suppose we want
to find out if the integral from two to infinity
of two plus sine x over square root of x dx
converges or diverges. Instead of trying to
evaluate it, which could get tricky, because
of the sine x and the square root of x in
here, I'm going to just try to compare it
to something that I know converges or diverges.
The first thing that I notice is that sine
of x is bounded. It's always between one and
negative one. And that means that the numerator
two plus sine x is always going to be in between
three and one. Therefore, the function two
plus sine x over square root of x is going
to be between three over square root of x
and one over square root of x. Here's the
general idea of the picture. Now the comparison
theorem tells us that if our function is less
than a function whose interval converges,
then the integral of our current function
will converge. And if our function is greater
than a function whose integral diverges than
the integral of our function will diverged.
So which one of these two inequalities if
we want to use depends on what happens to
the integral of these functions on the ends?
Now we know that the integral of one over
the square root of x dx from two to infinity
has to die verge. That's because this is a
p function, where p is equal to one half,
which is less than one, the integral from
two to infinity of three over the square root
of x dx also diverges since it's just three
times the other integral. So if we want to
compare our function to a function whose integral
diverges, it It better be bigger than that
divergent integral in order to get any useful
information out of it being less than a function
whose integral diverges doesn't tell us anything.
So we need to focus on this inequality.
And now we can say that, since the integral
from two to infinity of one over the square
root of x dx diverges by the P test, the integral
of our function also diverges by the comparison
test. In this video, we saw that if we have
two positive functions, and one function is
always less than or equal to the other function
on an interval, then if the smaller functions
integral diverges, the bigger functions integral
also has to diverge. And if the Biggers functions
integral converges, the smaller functions
integral also has to converge. That's the
comparison there. In this video, I'll give
some definitions and notation for sequences.
A sequence is a list of numbers in a particular
order, the sequence 314159 and So on is a
sequence that gives the digits of pi. A sequence
is sometimes described abstractly, with letters
in place of numbers, a sub one, a sub two,
a sub three, and so on. Or more concisely,
by writing a sub n with these curly brackets.
Here, we're told that the index n ranges from
one all the way up towards infinity. Sometimes
the sequence is written just a sub n with
curly brackets. Here, it's implied that n
ranges through all positive integers. For
these sequences, given by formulas, let's
write out the first few terms. We start with
n equals one, and we get a sub one is three
times one plus one over one plus two factorial.
That is, for over three factorial. Recall
that three factorial means that we start with
three and then multiply with consecutive numbers
all the way down to one, this simplifies to
four, six, or two thirds. To find the next
term, a sub two, we plug in two for add, that's
seven over four factorial, which is 720 fourths.
Similarly, a sub three is 10, over five factorial,
which is 10 over 120, or 112. So the first
three terms of the sequence are two thirds,
720, fourths, and 112. For the second example,
we're asked to start with K equals two. So
I'll call the first term, a sub two, and just
plug in two for K, which is five ninths. Since
negative one squared is positive one. Plugging
in K equals three, we get negative 6/27, or
to negative two nights. For as of four, we
again get a positive number, since negative
one to the fourth is positive. And in fact,
as we keep writing down terms, they're going
to alternate between negative numbers and
positive numbers, because of the negative
one to the K in the definition. Sometimes,
the nth term of a sequence is defined indirectly,
in terms of previous terms. This is called
a recursive formula. To write out the first
few terms of this recursive sequence, we're
told that a sub one equals two, to find a
sub two, we just use the recursive formula
for minus one over a sub one. Since a sub
one is two, that's four minus a half, or seven
half, defined a sub three, we just apply the
recursive formula again, four minus one over
seven has simplifies to 26/7. Sometimes as
possible, describe a sequence with either
a recursive formula, or a closed form non
recursive formula. For example, if I look
at the sequence 246 810, I can describe that
recursively by saying a sub one is two, and
each a sub n is equal to a sub n minus one
plus two. Or I can describe as a closed form
expression by saying the sequence is of the
form two times n, where n starts at one.
And now we can say that, since the integral
from two to infinity of one over the square
root of x dx diverges by the P test, the integral
of our function also diverges by the comparison
test. In this video, we saw that if we have
two positive functions, and one function is
always less than or equal to the other function
on an interval, then if the smaller functions
integral diverges, the bigger functions integral
also has to diverge. And if the Biggers functions
integral converges, the smaller functions
integral also has to converge. That's the
comparison there. In this video, I'll give
some definitions and notation for sequences.
A sequence is a list of numbers in a particular
order, the sequence 314159 and So on is a
sequence that gives the digits of pi. A sequence
is sometimes described abstractly, with letters
in place of numbers, a sub one, a sub two,
a sub three, and so on. Or more concisely,
by writing a sub n with these curly brackets.
Here, we're told that the index n ranges from
one all the way up towards infinity. Sometimes
the sequence is written just a sub n with
curly brackets. Here, it's implied that n
ranges through all positive integers. For
these sequences, given by formulas, let's
write out the first few terms. We start with
n equals one, and we get a sub one is three
times one plus one over one plus two factorial.
That is, for over three factorial. Recall
that three factorial means that we start with
three and then multiply with consecutive numbers
all the way down to one, this simplifies to
four, six, or two thirds. To find the next
term, a sub two, we plug in two for add, that's
seven over four factorial, which is 720 fourths.
Similarly, a sub three is 10, over five factorial,
which is 10 over 120, or 112. So the first
three terms of the sequence are two thirds,
720, fourths, and 112. For the second example,
we're asked to start with K equals two. So
I'll call the first term, a sub two, and just
plug in two for K, which is five ninths. Since
negative one squared is positive one. Plugging
in K equals three, we get negative 6/27, or
to negative two nights. For as of four, we
again get a positive number, since negative
one to the fourth is positive. And in fact,
as we keep writing down terms, they're going
to alternate between negative numbers and
positive numbers, because of the negative
one to the K in the definition. Sometimes,
the nth term of a sequence is defined indirectly,
in terms of previous terms. This is called
a recursive formula. To write out the first
few terms of this recursive sequence, we're
told that a sub one equals two, to find a
sub two, we just use the recursive formula
for minus one over a sub one. Since a sub
one is two, that's four minus a half, or seven
half, defined a sub three, we just apply the
recursive formula again, four minus one over
seven has simplifies to 26/7. Sometimes as
possible, describe a sequence with either
a recursive formula, or a closed form non
recursive formula. For example, if I look
at the sequence 246 810, I can describe that
recursively by saying a sub one is two, and
each a sub n is equal to a sub n minus one
plus two. Or I can describe as a closed form
expression by saying the sequence is of the
form two times n, where n starts at one.
Now let's practice writing out a formula for
the general term, a sub n of a sequence. For
this first sequence, notice that each term
is three more than the previous term. So this
is like a linear function with slope three,
each time that n goes up by one, our ace events
go up by three. And so I can write a sub n
is three times n plus b, where B functions
like my y intercept and a linear equation,
to find B, I can plug in seven, four, a sub
one that corresponds to an N value of one,
and I get that B has to equal four. So my
general formula is three times n plus four,
where n starts at one. I can check this by
plugging in a few values of n, like we did
in the previous example, just to make sure
it works. Notice that it would also be possible
to write this as three times n plus seven
If we're willing to start with n equals zero
instead of one, if we let n start with zero,
then our first term functions like our y intercept.
This is an example of an arithmetic sequence,
a sequence for which consecutive terms have
the same common difference. And in general,
if A is the first term, and d is the common
difference than an arithmetic sequence has
the form d times k plus a, if our index is
K and starts at zero, like it did over here.
Or if we'd rather start with an index of one,
we can rewrite that as D times n minus one
plus a. Notice these two expressions are exactly
the same, if we just set k equal to n minus
one, in particular, the starting value of
n equals one here, if I plug in one for n,
I get the equivalent starting value of K to
be zero. Let's read some more formulas for
sequences. In this first sequence, notice
that consecutive terms always have the same
ratio of 1/10. In other words, each time n
increases by one, a sub n gets multiplied
by 1/10. This is the same property that exponential
functions have. And in fact, we can write
a sub n in the form of an exponential function
with base 1/10. But we need to multiply by
the right initial value, so that when n is
one, we'll get a first term of three, that
correct initial value is 30. As usual, we
can check our answer by plugging in a few
values of n, n equals 123. And making sure
we get back the terms in our sequence. If
we prefer to start with our index at zero,
we can rewrite this as three times 1/10 to
the nth power. Since a value of zero for n
in this formula, gives us three, just like
a value of one for n in this formula gives
us three. In the second example, we again
have a common ratio, if I divide the second
term by the first term, I get a ratio of five
halves. And that's the same ratio as I get
when I divide the third term by the second
term. So if I use an index starting with zero,
I can write this series as 15 halves, which
is the first term times five halves to the
nth power. If I prefer to start with my index
at one, one way to do this is to let K equal
n plus one and making a variable substitution.
When n is 0k, will be one. And since K is
n plus one, n is k minus one, so I can replace
n with k minus one. This gives the following
representation of the sequence. The third
example has a common ratio of negative two
thirds. so we can write it as the initial
term of three times that ratio, negative two
thirds raised to the nth power, where n starts
at zero. Or, as above, we can write it as
three times negative two thirds to the k minus
one.
Now let's practice writing out a formula for
the general term, a sub n of a sequence. For
this first sequence, notice that each term
is three more than the previous term. So this
is like a linear function with slope three,
each time that n goes up by one, our ace events
go up by three. And so I can write a sub n
is three times n plus b, where B functions
like my y intercept and a linear equation,
to find B, I can plug in seven, four, a sub
one that corresponds to an N value of one,
and I get that B has to equal four. So my
general formula is three times n plus four,
where n starts at one. I can check this by
plugging in a few values of n, like we did
in the previous example, just to make sure
it works. Notice that it would also be possible
to write this as three times n plus seven
If we're willing to start with n equals zero
instead of one, if we let n start with zero,
then our first term functions like our y intercept.
This is an example of an arithmetic sequence,
a sequence for which consecutive terms have
the same common difference. And in general,
if A is the first term, and d is the common
difference than an arithmetic sequence has
the form d times k plus a, if our index is
K and starts at zero, like it did over here.
Or if we'd rather start with an index of one,
we can rewrite that as D times n minus one
plus a. Notice these two expressions are exactly
the same, if we just set k equal to n minus
one, in particular, the starting value of
n equals one here, if I plug in one for n,
I get the equivalent starting value of K to
be zero. Let's read some more formulas for
sequences. In this first sequence, notice
that consecutive terms always have the same
ratio of 1/10. In other words, each time n
increases by one, a sub n gets multiplied
by 1/10. This is the same property that exponential
functions have. And in fact, we can write
a sub n in the form of an exponential function
with base 1/10. But we need to multiply by
the right initial value, so that when n is
one, we'll get a first term of three, that
correct initial value is 30. As usual, we
can check our answer by plugging in a few
values of n, n equals 123. And making sure
we get back the terms in our sequence. If
we prefer to start with our index at zero,
we can rewrite this as three times 1/10 to
the nth power. Since a value of zero for n
in this formula, gives us three, just like
a value of one for n in this formula gives
us three. In the second example, we again
have a common ratio, if I divide the second
term by the first term, I get a ratio of five
halves. And that's the same ratio as I get
when I divide the third term by the second
term. So if I use an index starting with zero,
I can write this series as 15 halves, which
is the first term times five halves to the
nth power. If I prefer to start with my index
at one, one way to do this is to let K equal
n plus one and making a variable substitution.
When n is 0k, will be one. And since K is
n plus one, n is k minus one, so I can replace
n with k minus one. This gives the following
representation of the sequence. The third
example has a common ratio of negative two
thirds. so we can write it as the initial
term of three times that ratio, negative two
thirds raised to the nth power, where n starts
at zero. Or, as above, we can write it as
three times negative two thirds to the k minus
one.
Where k starts at one. Sometimes people like
to write the negative one separately. The
negative one to the power makes a series alternate
between negative and positive terms. These
three sequences are all examples of geometric
sequences, which are key sequences where consecutive
terms have the same common ratio. And in general,
if A is the first term and RS, the common
ratio than a geometric sequence can be written
in the form of a times r to the n, where n
starts at zero, or as a times r to the n minus
one, where n starts at one. These next two
sequences are neither arithmetic sequences
nor geometric sequences. Since they're terms
neither have common differences nor common
ratios, but I can still figure out a formula
for the nth term just by looking for the pattern.
In this example, since the terms are alternating,
if I start at n equals one, I know that 90
to negative one to the nth power to make it
start with a negative and then alternate,
positive, negative Again, the numerator looks
like it's just twice n. And the denominator
looks like it's always a perfect square, starting
with the square of three, so I'll write that
as n plus two squared. The next sequence doesn't
have a simple closed form formula, but I can
describe it recursively by saying that a one
is negative six, a two is five. And in general,
a n is equal to the sum of the two previous
terms, a sub n minus one, plus a sub n minus
two. This sequence is closely related to the
standard Fibonacci sequence, which has the
same recursive formula, but different initial
values. This video gave an introduction to
sequences, including arithmetic sequences,
geometric sequences, and recursively defined
sequences. This video introduces the idea
of a series and how to find it sum. For any
sequence, a sub n for n equals one to infinity,
the sum of its terms, a sub one plus a sub
two plus a sub three, and so on, it's called
a series. Often this series is written in
sigma notation, as a sum from n equals one
to infinity of a sub n. Let's look at the
sequence one over two to the n for n equals
one to infinity. If we add together all the
terms, we get the series, the sum from n equals
one to infinity of one over two to the N,
that is the sum of one over two to the one,
that's one half, plus one over two squared,
that's 1/4, plus one over two cubed 1/8 plus
1/16, plus 1/32, and so on. But what does
it really mean to add have infinitely many
numbers? How can we figure out what this infinite
song equals? Well, the start out, we could
add up finitely, many at a time, may write
down the first half dozen or so terms, that
is the ace of ends. And I'll keep adding more
and more of them together one more at a time.
But just add the first term, well, that's
just one half. Now add the next term on, that
gives me a song of three fourths. If I add
1/8 to that, my son goes up to seven eights.
And then I'll add the next one. I get 15 sixteenths,
and so on just adding one more term each time.
This process of repeated addition gives me
a new sequence down at the bottom. That's
called the sequence of partial sums. And it's
usually denoted by s sub n. So the first term
in the sequence of partial sums as S sub one,
just adding together the first term, here's
the second partial sum S sub two, adding together
the first two terms. So three means add together,
the first three terms, and so on. Let me contrast
the sequence of partial sums with the sequence
of terms that we started out with. Those are
denoted a sub n. So here's a sub one, the
first term, a sub two, the second term, and
so on.
Where k starts at one. Sometimes people like
to write the negative one separately. The
negative one to the power makes a series alternate
between negative and positive terms. These
three sequences are all examples of geometric
sequences, which are key sequences where consecutive
terms have the same common ratio. And in general,
if A is the first term and RS, the common
ratio than a geometric sequence can be written
in the form of a times r to the n, where n
starts at zero, or as a times r to the n minus
one, where n starts at one. These next two
sequences are neither arithmetic sequences
nor geometric sequences. Since they're terms
neither have common differences nor common
ratios, but I can still figure out a formula
for the nth term just by looking for the pattern.
In this example, since the terms are alternating,
if I start at n equals one, I know that 90
to negative one to the nth power to make it
start with a negative and then alternate,
positive, negative Again, the numerator looks
like it's just twice n. And the denominator
looks like it's always a perfect square, starting
with the square of three, so I'll write that
as n plus two squared. The next sequence doesn't
have a simple closed form formula, but I can
describe it recursively by saying that a one
is negative six, a two is five. And in general,
a n is equal to the sum of the two previous
terms, a sub n minus one, plus a sub n minus
two. This sequence is closely related to the
standard Fibonacci sequence, which has the
same recursive formula, but different initial
values. This video gave an introduction to
sequences, including arithmetic sequences,
geometric sequences, and recursively defined
sequences. This video introduces the idea
of a series and how to find it sum. For any
sequence, a sub n for n equals one to infinity,
the sum of its terms, a sub one plus a sub
two plus a sub three, and so on, it's called
a series. Often this series is written in
sigma notation, as a sum from n equals one
to infinity of a sub n. Let's look at the
sequence one over two to the n for n equals
one to infinity. If we add together all the
terms, we get the series, the sum from n equals
one to infinity of one over two to the N,
that is the sum of one over two to the one,
that's one half, plus one over two squared,
that's 1/4, plus one over two cubed 1/8 plus
1/16, plus 1/32, and
so on. But what does it really mean to add
have infinitely many numbers? How can we figure
out what this infinite song equals? Well,
the start out, we could add up finitely, many
at a time, may write down the first half dozen
or so terms, that is the ace of ends. And
I'll keep adding more and more of them together
one more at a time. But just add the first
term, well, that's just one half. Now add
the next term on, that gives me a song of
three fourths. If I add 1/8 to that, my son
goes up to seven eights. And then I'll add
the next one. I get 15 sixteenths, and so
on just adding one more term each time. This
process of repeated addition gives me a new
sequence down at the bottom. That's called
the sequence of partial sums. And it's usually
denoted by s sub n. So the first term in the
sequence of partial sums as S sub one, just
adding together the first term, here's the
second partial sum S sub two, adding together
the first two terms. So three means add together,
the first three terms, and so on. Let me contrast
the sequence of partial sums with the sequence
of terms that we started out with. Those are
denoted a sub n. So here's a sub one, the
first term, a sub two, the second term, and
so on.
Although I can't physically add up infinitely
many numbers, I can observe that as I add
up more and more numbers, my partial sums
are approaching the number one. That is the
limit, as the number of terms I add up and
goes to infinity of the nth partial sum is
equal to one. So it makes sense that if I
could add up all infinitely many numbers,
I should get an exact sum of one, the sum
of this infinite series is one. In fact, for
this particular series, there's a nice way
to see that the sum is one using geometry.
If I draw a square with side length one and
fill in half of the square, that gives me
an area of one half. Now if I draw a line
here, that gives me an additional area of
1/4. Here's an area of 1/8 1/16 and I keep
spiraling in here. I keep adding areas that
exactly match the terms of this series. In
the limit, I'll have filled in the entire
R square, which has an area of one. In this
example, which found the sum of the series
by evaluating the limit of the partial sums.
And in general, this is how we find the sum
of any series. For any series, the partial
sums of the series are defined as the sequence
s sub n, where S sub one is equal to just
the first term, a sub one, a sub two is equal
to the sum of the first two terms is a one
plus a sub two, a sub three is a sum of the
first three terms. And in general, s sub n
is the sum of the first n terms. I can also
write this in sigma notation, as the sum of
say, k equals one to n of a sub k. I'm using
a different letter K here as the index, just
because I'm already using n to represent the
number of terms that I'm adding up. That sum
of a sub n is said to converge if this sequence
of partial sums converges as a sequence. That
is, if the limit as n goes to infinity of
the sub ends, exists as a finite number. Otherwise,
if the limit does not exist, or the limit
is infinity or negative infinity, then the
series is said to diverged. I want to emphasize
that we're talking about the limit of the
partial sums here, not the limit of the original
terms as a bad, it's important to keep in
mind when you're working with series that
for any series, they're actually two sequences
of interest. There's the sequence of terms,
the ace of ends. And then there's the sequence
of partial sums, the S events, it's the sequence
of partial sums is telling us what the sum
of our series is. So if the sequence of partial
sums converges to a number L, then we say
the cert series converges to L. Or in other
words, the sum of the series is out. Let's
look at the series The sum of one over n squared
plus n, please pause the video and take a
moment to write out the first four terms and
the first four partial sums. The first four
terms are a sub one, a sub two, a sub three
and a sub four. So plugging in one for n,
one over one squared plus one, so that's one
half, a sub two is one over two squared plus
two, that's one six, Ace of three ends up
being 1/12. And a sub four is 1/20. Now S
sub one is the sum of the first one terms,
that's the same as a sub one is just one half
Although I can't physically add up infinitely
many numbers, I can observe that as I add
up more and more numbers, my partial sums
are approaching the number one. That is the
limit, as the number of terms I add up and
goes to infinity of the nth partial sum is
equal to one. So it makes sense that if I
could add up all infinitely many numbers,
I should get an exact sum of one, the sum
of this infinite series is one. In fact, for
this particular series, there's a nice way
to see that the sum is one using geometry.
If I draw a square with side length one and
fill in half of the square, that gives me
an area of one half. Now if I draw a line
here, that gives me an additional area of
1/4. Here's an area of 1/8 1/16 and I keep
spiraling in here. I keep adding areas that
exactly match the terms of this series. In
the limit, I'll have filled in the entire
R square, which has an area of one. In this
example, which found the sum of the series
by evaluating the limit of the partial sums.
And in general, this is how we find the sum
of any series. For any series, the partial
sums of the series are defined as the sequence
s sub n, where S sub one is equal to just
the first term, a sub one, a sub two is equal
to the sum of the first two terms is a one
plus a sub two, a sub three is a sum of the
first three terms. And in general, s sub n
is the sum of the first n terms. I can also
write this in sigma notation, as the sum of
say, k equals one to n of a sub k. I'm using
a different letter K here as the index, just
because I'm already using n to represent the
number of terms that I'm adding up. That sum
of a sub n is said to converge if this sequence
of partial sums converges as a sequence. That
is, if the limit as n goes to infinity of
the sub ends, exists as a finite number. Otherwise,
if the limit does not exist, or the limit
is infinity or negative infinity, then the
series is said to diverged. I want to emphasize
that we're talking about the limit of the
partial sums here, not the limit of the original
terms as a bad, it's important to keep in
mind when you're working with series that
for any series, they're actually two sequences
of interest. There's the sequence of terms,
the ace of ends. And then there's the sequence
of partial sums, the S events, it's the sequence
of partial sums is telling us what the sum
of our series is. So if the sequence of partial
sums converges to a number L, then we say
the cert series converges to L. Or in other
words, the sum of the series is out. Let's
look at the series The sum of one over n squared
plus n, please pause the video and take a
moment to write out the first four terms and
the first four partial sums. The first four
terms are a sub one, a sub two, a sub three
and a sub four. So plugging in one for n,
one over one squared plus one, so that's one
half, a sub two is one over two squared plus
two, that's one six, Ace of three ends up
being 1/12. And a sub four is 1/20. Now S
sub one is the sum of the first one terms,
that's the same as a sub one is just one half
S sub two, is what I get when I add one half
plus one six, that's four, six, or two thirds.
To get a sub three, I need to add on the next
term, two thirds plus 112, is 912, or three
fourths. And finally, as sub four, I need
to add on the next term, which gives me four
fifths. There's a nice pattern going on with
the S events here. For the nth partial song,
the numerator is just n, and the denominator
is just n plus one. So the limit as n goes
to infinity of the partial sums, is the limit
as n goes to infinity of n over n plus one,
which is just one. That means that the sum
of the infinite series is equal to one, by
coincidence the same sound as in the previous
example. In this video, we saw that to find
the sum of an infinite series, we have to
calculate the partial sums. If we add together
more and more finitely many terms, our partial
sum will get close to our infinite sum. And
in fact, the sum of our infinite sum is defined
as the limit as n goes to infinity of the
partial sum. This video gives some more definitions
about sequences, including the definition
of bounded and the definition of monotonic
sequence is bounded above if all of its terms
are less than or equal to some number in other
Words, there's a number capital M, such that
the term a sub n is less than or equal to
capital M, for all values of the index n.
A sequence is bounded below if all of its
terms are greater than or equal to some number.
In other words, there's a number lowercase
m, such that a sub n is greater than or equal
to lowercase m, for all and we say that a
sequence is bounded if it's bounded both above
and below. In other words, all of its terms
are trapped between two numbers. Please pause
the video and decide which of these three
sequences are bounded. This first sequence
is bounded above by three. Since all of its
terms are less than or equal to three, of
course, we could have also used four as an
upper bound, or 100 is an upper bound, but
three is the tightest upper bound that we
can use. It's also bounded below by zero,
since all of the terms are positive. So we
say that this sequence is bounded. The second
sequence is bounded below by one, but it's
not bounded above, since its terms will eventually
grow past any potential bound. The third sequence
is bounded below and above. In fact, if we
graph n on the x axis and a sub n on the y
axis, then our terms bounce around between
positive and negative values. But since we're
always multiplying by negative two thirds
to get from one term to the next, the oscillations
are dying down in magnitude. And in fact,
the terms can never get above three or below
negative two. We say that a sequence is increasing
if each term is less than the next term, that
is, a sub n is less than a sub n plus one
for all n. sequences called non decreasing
if each term is less than or equal to the
next term. So a sub n is less than or equal
to a sub n plus one for all n. Non decreasing
is like increasing, it's just we allow equality
between 2/6 consecutive terms
S sub two, is what I get when I add one half
plus one six, that's four, six, or two thirds.
To get a sub three, I need to add on the next
term, two thirds plus 112, is 912, or three
fourths. And finally, as sub four, I need
to add on the next term, which gives me four
fifths. There's a nice pattern going on with
the S events here. For the nth partial song,
the numerator is just n, and the denominator
is just n plus one. So the limit as n goes
to infinity of the partial sums, is the limit
as n goes to infinity of n over n plus one,
which is just one. That means that the sum
of the infinite series is equal to one, by
coincidence the same sound as in the previous
example. In this video, we saw that to find
the sum of an infinite series, we have to
calculate the partial sums. If we add together
more and more finitely many terms, our partial
sum will get close to our infinite sum. And
in fact, the sum of our infinite sum is defined
as the limit as n goes to infinity of the
partial sum. This video gives some more definitions
about sequences, including the definition
of bounded and the definition of monotonic
sequence is bounded above if all of its terms
are less than or equal to some number in other
Words, there's a number capital M, such that
the term a sub n is less than or equal to
capital M, for all values of the index n.
A sequence is bounded below if all of its
terms are greater than or equal to some number.
In other words, there's a number lowercase
m, such that a sub n is greater than or equal
to lowercase m, for all and we say that a
sequence is bounded if it's bounded both above
and below. In other words, all of its terms
are trapped between two numbers. Please pause
the video and decide which of these three
sequences are bounded. This first sequence
is bounded above by three. Since all of its
terms are less than or equal to three, of
course, we could have also used four as an
upper bound, or 100 is an upper bound, but
three is the tightest upper bound that we
can use. It's also bounded below by zero,
since all of the terms are positive. So we
say that this sequence is bounded. The second
sequence is bounded below by one, but it's
not bounded above, since its terms will eventually
grow past any potential bound. The third sequence
is bounded below and above. In fact, if we
graph n on the x axis and a sub n on the y
axis, then our terms bounce around between
positive and negative values. But since we're
always multiplying by negative two thirds
to get from one term to the next, the oscillations
are dying down in magnitude. And in fact,
the terms can never get above three or below
negative two. We say that a sequence is increasing
if each term is less than the next term, that
is, a sub n is less than a sub n plus one
for all n. sequences called non decreasing
if each term is less than or equal to the
next term. So a sub n is less than or equal
to a sub n plus one for all n. Non decreasing
is like increasing, it's just we allow equality
between 2/6 consecutive terms
a sequence is decreasing if each term is greater
than the next one. So a sub n is greater than
a sub n plus one for all n. And a sequence
is not increasing, if a sub n is greater than
or equal to a sub n plus one for all n. Again,
not increasing is like decreasing, but we
allow for equality between consecutive terms.
If we were to graph and on the x axis and
a sub n on the y axis, then increasing looks
like this just like an increasing function,
whereas decreasing would go down non decreasing
would go up possibly with some flat patches
and mnandi increasing would go down possibly
with some flat patches, notice that increasing
is a stronger condition than non decreasing
since being strictly less than something is
stronger than just being less than or equal
to it. For that reason. If a sequence is increasing,
it is also non decreasing. And similarly,
if a sequence is decreasing, it is also not
increasing. A sequence is called monotonic,
if it is either non decreasing or non increasing.
Please pause the video and try to decide which
of the following sequences are monotonic.
The first two sequences are monotonic. The
first one is monotonically. Non increasing,
since we never increase when we go from one
term to the next. In fact, we could also say
that it's monotonically decreasing. Since
we always go strictly down as we go from one
term to the next, we never have equality between
terms. The second sequence is monotonically
non decreasing. Since we never go down, as
we go from one term to the next, we either
go up or stay at the same level. In this case,
however, we could not say that the sequence
is monotonically increasing because of the
equality between some pairs of consecutive
terms. The third sequence is not monotonic,
the numbers bounce around between positive
and negative numbers, and therefore sometimes
we are decreasing while other times we're
increasing. And the fourth sequence is not
monotonic, because of the first few terms.
However, from the fifth term on the terms
are monotonically, non decreasing. And we
could also say monotonically increasing. In
this video, we give definitions for bounded
and monotonic sequences. We'll see later that
these definitions can be important for determining
when a sequence converges. In class, we talked
briefly about the sequence n minus five over
n squared, where n goes from one to infinity.
We want to know if the sequence is monotonic.
And if it's bounded. If we compute the first
few terms, the sequence appears to be steadily
increasing. But in this case, appearances
are deceiving. And a better way to decide
whether it's monotonic is to use calculus
to decide if the associated function f of
x equals x minus five over x squared, it is
increasing for x values bigger than one. So
let me take the derivative. Using the quotient
rule and simplify, I get that f prime of x
is equal to minus x squared plus 10x over
x to the fourth. And now I need to decide
is F prime of X greater than zero for x bigger
than one, if so my function, and therefore
my sequence will, will be increasing. To check
if f prime of x
is greater than zero, I'll first set f prime
of x equal to zero. So I'll set my ratio here
equal to zero, which means my numerator needs
to be equal to zero. And if I factor that,
I get that x equals zero, or x equals 10.
a sequence is decreasing if each term is greater
than the next one. So a sub n is greater than
a sub n plus one for all n. And a sequence
is not increasing, if a sub n is greater than
or equal to a sub n plus one for all n. Again,
not increasing is like decreasing, but we
allow for equality between consecutive terms.
If we were to graph and on the x axis and
a sub n on the y axis, then increasing looks
like this just like an increasing function,
whereas decreasing would go down non decreasing
would go up possibly with some flat patches
and mnandi increasing would go down possibly
with some flat patches, notice that increasing
is a stronger condition than non decreasing
since being strictly less than something is
stronger than just being less than or equal
to it. For that reason. If a sequence is increasing,
it is also non decreasing. And similarly,
if a sequence is decreasing, it is also not
increasing. A sequence is called monotonic,
if it is either non decreasing or non increasing.
Please pause the video and try to decide which
of the following sequences are monotonic.
The first two sequences are monotonic. The
first one is monotonically. Non increasing,
since we never increase when we go from one
term to the next. In fact, we could also say
that it's monotonically decreasing. Since
we always go strictly down as we go from one
term to the next, we never have equality between
terms. The second sequence is monotonically
non decreasing. Since we never go down, as
we go from one term to the next, we either
go up or stay at the same level. In this case,
however, we could not say that the sequence
is monotonically increasing because of the
equality between some pairs of consecutive
terms. The third sequence is not monotonic,
the numbers bounce around between positive
and negative numbers, and therefore sometimes
we are decreasing while other times we're
increasing. And the fourth sequence is not
monotonic, because of the first few terms.
However, from the fifth term on the terms
are monotonically, non decreasing. And we
could also say monotonically increasing. In
this video, we give definitions for bounded
and monotonic sequences. We'll see later that
these definitions can be important for determining
when a sequence converges. In class, we talked
briefly about the sequence n minus five over
n squared, where n goes from one to infinity.
We want to know if the sequence is monotonic.
And if it's bounded. If we compute the first
few terms, the sequence appears to be steadily
increasing. But in this case, appearances
are deceiving. And a better way to decide
whether it's monotonic is to use calculus
to decide if the associated function f of
x equals x minus five over x squared, it is
increasing for x values bigger than one. So
let me take the derivative. Using the quotient
rule and simplify, I get that f prime of x
is equal to minus x squared plus 10x over
x to the fourth. And now I need to decide
is F prime of X greater than zero for x bigger
than one, if so my function, and therefore
my sequence will, will be increasing. To check
if f prime of x is greater than zero, I'll
first set f prime of x equal to zero. So I'll
set my ratio here equal to zero, which means
my numerator needs to be equal to zero. And
if I factor that, I get that x equals zero,
or x equals 10.
Now if I draw my number line, since f prime
is equal to zero at zero and 10, it'll be
positive and negative in between these values.
And by plugging in values, like x equals negative
one, one and 11, I can see that f prime is
negative for x less than zero, positive for
x between zero and 10, and negative for x
bigger than 10. In particular, f increases
when x increases from one to 10. And then
it decreases. And so the same thing is happening
to our sequence. Therefore, the sequence is
not monotonic. We can also use calculus to
check if the sequence is bounded. Our first
derivative test shows that our function f
of x has a maximum at x equals 10. At least
that's the maximum for x values, ranging from
one to infinity. And that's all that's relevant
for our sequence. Therefore, our sequence
is bounded above by its value at 10, which
is 10 minus five over 10 squared, or 1/20.
Now notice that our sequence and minus five
over n squared is always bigger than zero,
for n bigger than five since the numerator
and denominator are both positive in this
situation. And since there are only finitely,
many terms where n is less than five, we can
just use the minimum of these terms and zero
as a lower bound. The smallest of the first
four terms is negative four, which is less
than zero, so that negative four forms a lower
bound. So the sequence is in fact bounded.
And somewhat surprisingly, the calculus ideas
of derivative and maximum and minimum. In
the past, we've encountered limits, like the
limit as x goes to two of x minus two over
x squared minus four. We can't evaluate this
limit just by plugging In two for x, because
x minus two goes to zero, and x squared minus
four goes to zero as x goes to two. This is
known as a zero over zero indeterminate form.
It's called indeterminate because we can't
tell what the limits going to be just by the
fact that the numerator goes to zero and the
denominator goes to zero. It depends on how
fast the numerator and the denominator are
going to zero compared to each other. And
the final limit of the quotient could be any
number at all, or it could be infinity, or
it could not even exist. In the past, we've
been able to evaluate some limits in zero
over zero indeterminate form by using algebraic
tricks to rewrite the quotients. In this video,
we'll introduce lopatok rule, which is a very
powerful technique for evaluating limits and
indeterminate forms. A limit of the form the
limit as x goes to a of f of x over g of x
is called a zero over zero indeterminate form.
If the limit as x goes to a of f of x is equal
to zero, and the limit as x goes to a of g
of x is equal to zero. A limit in this form
is called an infinity over infinity indeterminate
form. If the limit as x goes to a of f of
x is equal to infinity or minus infinity.
And the limit as x goes to a pub g of x is
equal to infinity or minus infinity. We saw
an example of a zero over zero indeterminate
form in the introductory slide. One example
of a infinity over infinity indeterminate
form is the limit as x goes to infinity of
3x squared minus 2x plus seven divided by
negative 2x squared plus 16. Notice that as
x goes to infinity, the numerator goes to
infinity while the denominator goes to negative
infinity. In these definitions of indeterminate
form, it's possible for a to be a negative
infinity or infinity, like it is in this example,
but it doesn't have to be loopy. talls rule
can be applied when f and g are differentiable
functions. And the derivative of g is nonzero
in some open interval around a except possibly
in a
Now if I draw my number line, since f prime
is equal to zero at zero and 10, it'll be
positive and negative in between these values.
And by plugging in values, like x equals negative
one, one and 11, I can see that f prime is
negative for x less than zero, positive for
x between zero and 10, and negative for x
bigger than 10. In particular, f increases
when x increases from one to 10. And then
it decreases. And so the same thing is happening
to our sequence. Therefore, the sequence is
not monotonic. We can also use calculus to
check if the sequence is bounded. Our first
derivative test shows that our function f
of x has a maximum at x equals 10. At least
that's the maximum for x values, ranging from
one to infinity. And that's all that's relevant
for our sequence. Therefore, our sequence
is bounded above by its value at 10, which
is 10 minus five over 10 squared, or 1/20.
Now notice that our sequence and minus five
over n squared is always bigger than zero,
for n bigger than five since the numerator
and denominator are both positive in this
situation. And since there are only finitely,
many terms where n is less than five, we can
just use the minimum of these terms and zero
as a lower bound. The smallest of the first
four terms is negative four, which is less
than zero, so that negative four forms a lower
bound. So the sequence is in fact bounded.
And somewhat surprisingly, the calculus ideas
of derivative and maximum and minimum. In
the past, we've encountered limits, like the
limit as x goes to two of x minus two over
x squared minus four. We can't evaluate this
limit just by plugging In two for x, because
x minus two goes to zero, and x squared minus
four goes to zero as x goes to two. This is
known as a zero over zero indeterminate form.
It's called indeterminate because we can't
tell what the limits going to be just by the
fact that the numerator goes to zero and the
denominator goes to zero. It depends on how
fast the numerator and the denominator are
going to zero compared to each other. And
the final limit of the quotient could be any
number at all, or it could be infinity, or
it could not even exist. In the past, we've
been able to evaluate some limits in zero
over zero indeterminate form by using algebraic
tricks to rewrite the quotients. In this video,
we'll introduce lopatok rule, which is a very
powerful technique for evaluating limits and
indeterminate forms. A limit of the form the
limit as x goes to a of f of x over g of x
is called a zero over zero indeterminate form.
If the limit as x goes to a of f of x is equal
to zero, and the limit as x goes to a of g
of x is equal to zero. A limit in this form
is called an infinity over infinity indeterminate
form. If the limit as x goes to a of f of
x is equal to infinity or minus infinity.
And the limit as x goes to a pub g of x is
equal to infinity or minus infinity. We saw
an example of a zero over zero indeterminate
form in the introductory slide. One example
of a infinity over infinity indeterminate
form is the limit as x goes to infinity of
3x squared minus 2x plus seven divided by
negative 2x squared plus 16. Notice that as
x goes to infinity, the numerator goes to
infinity while the denominator goes to negative
infinity. In these definitions of indeterminate
form, it's possible for a to be a negative
infinity or infinity, like it is in this example,
but it doesn't have to be loopy. talls rule
can be applied when f and g are differentiable
functions. And the derivative of g is nonzero
in some open interval around a except possibly
in a
under these conditions, if the limit as x
goes to a of f of x over g of x is zero over
zero or infinity over infinity indeterminate
form, then the limit as x goes to a of f of
x over g of x is the same thing as the limit
as x goes to a of f prime of x over g prime
of x, provided that the second limit exists,
or as plus or minus infinity. Let's look at
loopy towers rule in action. In this example,
as x goes to infinity, the numerator x goes
to infinity and the denominator three to the
x also goes to infinity. So we have an infinity
over infinity indeterminate form. So let's
try applying lopi tos rule, our original limit
should equal the limit as x goes to infinity
of the derivative of the numerator, which
is one divided by the derivative of the denominator,
which is ln of three times three to the x,
provided that the second limit exists or as
infinity or negative infinity. In the second
limit, the numerators just fixed at one. And
the nominator goes to infinity as x goes to
infinity. Therefore, the second limit is just
zero. And so the original limit evaluates
to zero as well. In this example, we have
a zero over zero indeterminate form, because
as x goes to zero, sine of x and x, both go
to zero in the numerator, and sine of x cubed
goes to zero in the denominator. So using
loopy tells rule, I'll try to evaluate instead,
the limit I get by taking the derivative of
the numerator and the derivative of the denominator.
The derivative of sine x minus x is cosine
of x minus one, and the derivative of sine
x cubed is three times sine x squared times
cosine x using the chain rule. Now let me
try to evaluate the limit again. As x goes
to zero, cosine of x goes to one, so the numerator
here goes to zero. As x goes to zero, sine
of x goes to zero and cosine of x goes to
one, so the denominator also goes to zero.
So I still have a zero over zero and determinant
form. And I might as well try applying leptitox
rule again. But before I do, I want to point
out that cosine of x is going to one. So the
cosine of x here really isn't affecting my
limit. And in fact, I could rewrite my limit
of a product as a product of limits, where
the second limit is just one and can be ignored
from here on out. Now apply lopatok rule on
this first limit, which is a little bit easier
to take the derivatives. And so the derivative
of the top is minus sine x. And the derivative
of the bottom is six times sine x times cosine
x. Now let's try to evaluate again, as x goes
to zero, our numerator is going to zero and
our denominator is also going to zero. But
hang on, we don't have to apply lobby towels
rule again, because we can actually just simplify
our expression, the sine x on the top cancels
with the sine x on the bottom. And we can
just rewrite our limit as the limit of negative
one over six cosine of x, which evaluates
easily to negative one, six. In this example,
I want to emphasize that it's a good idea
to simplify after each application of lopi
talls rule. If you don't simplify, like we
did here, then you might be tempted to apply
lopatok rule and additional time when you
don't need to, which might make the problem
more complicated. Instead of simpler to solve
this video, we were able to evaluate zero
over zero and infinity over infinity indeterminate
forms by replacing the limit of f of x over
g of x with the limit of f prime of x over
g prime of x, provided that second limit exists.
This trick is known as lopi tels rule. We've
seen that lopatok rule can be used to evaluate
limits of the form zero over zero, or infinity
over infinity. In this video, we'll continue
to use loopy towels rule to evaluate additional
indeterminate forms, like zero times infinity,
infinity to the 00 to the zero, and one to
the infinity.
under these conditions, if the limit as x
goes to a of f of x over g of x is zero over
zero or infinity over infinity indeterminate
form, then the limit as x goes to a of f of
x over g of x is the same thing as the limit
as x goes to a of f prime of x over g prime
of x, provided that the second limit exists,
or as plus or minus infinity. Let's look at
loopy towers rule in action. In this example,
as x goes to infinity, the numerator x goes
to infinity and the denominator three to the
x also goes to infinity. So we have an infinity
over infinity indeterminate form. So let's
try applying lopi tos rule, our original limit
should equal the limit as x goes to infinity
of the derivative of the numerator, which
is one divided by the derivative of the denominator,
which is ln of three times three to the x,
provided that the second limit exists or as
infinity or negative infinity. In the second
limit, the numerators just fixed at one. And
the nominator goes to infinity as x goes to
infinity. Therefore, the second limit is just
zero. And so the original limit evaluates
to zero as well. In this example, we have
a zero over zero indeterminate form, because
as x goes to zero, sine of x and x, both go
to zero in the numerator, and sine of x cubed
goes to zero in the denominator. So using
loopy tells rule, I'll try to evaluate instead,
the limit I get by taking the derivative of
the numerator and the derivative of the denominator.
The derivative of sine x minus x is cosine
of x minus one, and the derivative of sine
x cubed is three times sine x squared times
cosine x using the chain rule. Now let me
try to evaluate the limit again. As x goes
to zero, cosine of x goes to one, so the numerator
here goes to zero. As x goes to zero, sine
of x goes to zero and cosine of x goes to
one, so the denominator also goes to zero.
So I still have a zero over zero and determinant
form. And I might as well try applying leptitox
rule again. But before I do, I want to point
out that cosine of x is going to one. So the
cosine of x here really isn't affecting my
limit. And in fact, I could rewrite my limit
of a product as a product of limits, where
the second limit is just one and can be ignored
from here on out. Now apply lopatok rule on
this first limit, which is a little bit easier
to take the derivatives. And so the derivative
of the top is minus sine x. And the derivative
of the bottom is six times sine x times cosine
x. Now let's try to evaluate again, as x goes
to zero, our numerator is going to zero and
our denominator is also going to zero. But
hang on, we don't have to apply lobby towels
rule again, because we can actually just simplify
our expression, the sine x on the top cancels
with the sine x on the bottom. And we can
just rewrite our limit as the limit of negative
one over six cosine of x, which evaluates
easily to negative one, six. In this example,
I want to emphasize that it's a good idea
to simplify after each application of lopi
talls rule. If you don't simplify, like we
did here, then you might be tempted to apply
lopatok rule and additional time when you
don't need to, which might make the problem
more complicated. Instead of simpler to solve
this video, we were able to evaluate zero
over zero and infinity over infinity indeterminate
forms by replacing the limit of f of x over
g of x with the limit of f prime of x over
g prime of x, provided that second limit exists.
This trick is known as lopi tels rule. We've
seen that lopatok rule can be used to evaluate
limits of the form zero over zero, or infinity
over infinity. In this video, we'll continue
to use loopy towels rule to evaluate additional
indeterminate forms, like zero times infinity,
infinity to the 00 to the zero, and one to
the infinity.
In this example, we want to evaluate the limit
of a product. Notice that as x goes to zero
from the positive side, sine x goes to zero,
and ln x goes to negative infinity. Remember
the graph of y equals ln x. So this is actually
a zero times infinity indeterminate form.
Even though the second factor is going to
negative infinity, we still call it a zero
times infinity and indeterminate form, you
can think of the Infinity here as standing
for either positive or negative infinity.
It's indeterminate. Because as x goes to zero,
the sine x factor is pulling the product towards
zero, while the ln x factor is pulling the
product towards large negative numbers. And
it's hard to predict what the limit of the
product will actually be. But the great thing
is, I can actually rewrite this product to
look like an infinity over infinity and determinant
form, or a zero over zero and determinant
form. Instead of sine x times ln x, I can
rewrite the limit as ln x divided by one over
sine x. Now as x goes to zero, my numerator
is going to negative infinity. And since sine
x is going to zero through positive numbers,
my denominator one over sine x is going to
positive infinity. So I have an infinity over
infinity indeterminate form. Now, I could
instead choose to leave the sine x in the
numerator, and instead, put a one over ln
x in the denominator. If I do this, then as
x goes to zero through positive numbers, sine
x goes to zero. And since ln x goes to negative
infinity, one over ln x goes to zero, and
so I have a zero over zero indeterminate form.
Sometimes it can be difficult to decide which
of these two ways to rewrite a product as
a quotient. One rule of thumb is to take the
version that makes it easier to take the derivative
of the numerator and denominator. Another
trick is just to try one of the ways and if
you get stuck, go back and try the other.
I'm going to use the first method of rewriting
it because I recognize that one over sine
x can be written as cosecant of x and I know
how to take the derivative of cosecant x using
lopi towels rule On this infinity over infinity
indeterminate form, I can rewrite my limit
as the limit of what I get when I take the
derivative of the numerator, that's one over
x divided by the derivative of the denominator,
that's negative cosecant x cotangent x. As
always, I want to simplify my expression before
going any further, I can rewrite my trig functions
in the denominator in terms of sine and cosine.
cosecant x is one over sine x. and cotangent
x is cosine of x over sine of x. Now flipping
and multiplying, I get the limit as x goes
to zero plus of one over x times the sine
squared of x over negative cosine of x. In
other words, the limit of negative sine squared
x over x cosine x, we know that cosine of
x goes to one as x goes to zero. So I can
rewrite this as the limit of negative sine
squared x over x times the limit of something
that goes to one. So I once again have a zero
over zero and determinant form. And I can
apply lopatok rule yet again, taking the derivative
of the top, I get negative two sine x, cosine
of x, and the derivative, the bottom is just
one. Now I'm in a good position just to evaluate
the limit by plugging in zero for x in the
numerator, I get negative two times zero times
one, the denominator is just one, so my final
limit is zero. In this limit, we have a battle
of forces. As x is going to infinity, one
over x is going to zero. So one plus one over
x is going to one, but the exponent x is going
to infinity, it's hard to tell what's going
to happen here. If we had one, to any finite
number, that would be one. But anything slightly
bigger than one, as we raise it to have bigger
and bigger powers, we would expect to get
infinity.
In this example, we want to evaluate the limit
of a product. Notice that as x goes to zero
from the positive side, sine x goes to zero,
and ln x goes to negative infinity. Remember
the graph of y equals ln x. So this is actually
a zero times infinity indeterminate form.
Even though the second factor is going to
negative infinity, we still call it a zero
times infinity and indeterminate form, you
can think of the Infinity here as standing
for either positive or negative infinity.
It's indeterminate. Because as x goes to zero,
the sine x factor is pulling the product towards
zero, while the ln x factor is pulling the
product towards large negative numbers. And
it's hard to predict what the limit of the
product will actually be. But the great thing
is, I can actually rewrite this product to
look like an infinity over infinity and determinant
form, or a zero over zero and determinant
form. Instead of sine x times ln x, I can
rewrite the limit as ln x divided by one over
sine x. Now as x goes to zero, my numerator
is going to negative infinity. And since sine
x is going to zero through positive numbers,
my denominator one over sine x is going to
positive infinity. So I have an infinity over
infinity indeterminate form. Now, I could
instead choose to leave the sine x in the
numerator, and instead, put a one over ln
x in the denominator. If I do this, then as
x goes to zero through positive numbers, sine
x goes to zero. And since ln x goes to negative
infinity, one over ln x goes to zero, and
so I have a zero over zero indeterminate form.
Sometimes it can be difficult to decide which
of these two ways to rewrite a product as
a quotient. One rule of thumb is to take the
version that makes it easier to take the derivative
of the numerator and denominator. Another
trick is just to try one of the ways and if
you get stuck, go back and try the other.
I'm going to use the first method of rewriting
it because I recognize that one over sine
x can be written as cosecant of x and I know
how to take the derivative of cosecant x using
lopi towels rule On this infinity over infinity
indeterminate form, I can rewrite my limit
as the limit of what I get when I take the
derivative of the numerator, that's one over
x divided by the derivative of the denominator,
that's negative cosecant x cotangent x. As
always, I want to simplify my expression before
going any further, I can rewrite my trig functions
in the denominator in terms of sine and cosine.
cosecant x is one over sine x. and cotangent
x is cosine of x over sine of x. Now flipping
and multiplying, I get the limit as x goes
to zero plus of one over x times the sine
squared of x over negative cosine of x. In
other words, the limit of negative sine squared
x over x cosine x, we know that cosine of
x goes to one as x goes to zero. So I can
rewrite this as the limit of negative sine
squared x over x times the limit of something
that goes to one. So I once again have a zero
over zero and determinant form. And I can
apply lopatok rule yet again, taking the derivative
of the top, I get negative two sine x, cosine
of x, and the derivative, the bottom is just
one. Now I'm in a good position just to evaluate
the limit by plugging in zero for x in the
numerator, I get negative two times zero times
one, the denominator is just one, so my final
limit is zero. In this limit, we have a battle
of forces. As x is going to infinity, one
over x is going to zero. So one plus one over
x is going to one, but the exponent x is going
to infinity, it's hard to tell what's going
to happen here. If we had one, to any finite
number, that would be one. But anything slightly
bigger than one, as we raise it to have bigger
and bigger powers, we would expect to get
infinity.
So our limit has an independent permanent
form, it's hard to tell whether the answer
is going to be one infinity, or maybe something
in between. Whenever I see an expression with
a variable in the base, and a variable in
the exponent, I'm tempted to use logarithms.
If we set y equal to one plus one over x to
the x, then if I take the natural log of both
sides, I can use my log roles to rewrite that
by multiplying by x in the front. Now, if
I wanted to take the limit as x goes to infinity
of ln y, that would be the limit of this product,
x times ln one plus one over x. As x goes
to infinity, the first factor x goes to infinity.
One plus one over x goes to just one and ln
one is going to zero. So we have infinity
times zero indeterminate form, which we can
try to rewrite as an infinity over infinity,
or a zero over zero indeterminate form. Let's
rewrite this as the limit of ln one plus one
over x divided by one of our x. This is indeed
a zero over zero indeterminate form. So we
can use lobi tiles rule and take the derivative
of the top and the bottom. The derivative
of the top is one over one plus one over x
times the derivative of the inside, which
would be negative one over x squared. And
the derivative on the bottom, the derivative
one over x is negative one over x squared,
we can actually cancel out these two factors,
and rewrite our limit as the limit as x goes
to infinity of one over one plus one over
x, which is just equal to one since one over
x is going to zero. So we found that the limit
of ln y is equal to one, but we're really
interested in finding the limit of y which
we can think of as e to the ln y. Since ln
y is going to one, e to the ln y must be going
to e to the one. In other words, E. So we
found that our original limit is equal to
E. And in fact, you may recognize that this
limit is one of the ways of defining E.
So our limit has an independent permanent
form, it's hard to tell whether the answer
is going to be one infinity, or maybe something
in between. Whenever I see an expression with
a variable in the base, and a variable in
the exponent, I'm tempted to use logarithms.
If we set y equal to one plus one over x to
the x, then if I take the natural log of both
sides, I can use my log roles to rewrite that
by multiplying by x in the front. Now, if
I wanted to take the limit as x goes to infinity
of ln y, that would be the limit of this product,
x times ln one plus one over x. As x goes
to infinity, the first factor x goes to infinity.
One plus one over x goes to just one and ln
one is going to zero. So we have infinity
times zero indeterminate form, which we can
try to rewrite as an infinity over infinity,
or a zero over zero indeterminate form. Let's
rewrite this as the limit of ln one plus one
over x divided by one of our x. This is indeed
a zero over zero indeterminate form. So we
can use lobi tiles rule and take the derivative
of the top and the bottom. The derivative
of the top is one over one plus one over x
times the derivative of the inside, which
would be negative one over x squared. And
the derivative on the bottom, the derivative
one over x is negative one over x squared,
we can actually cancel out these two factors,
and rewrite our limit as the limit as x goes
to infinity of one over one plus one over
x, which is just equal to one since one over
x is going to zero. So we found that the limit
of ln y is equal to one, but we're really
interested in finding the limit of y which
we can think of as e to the ln y. Since ln
y is going to one, e to the ln y must be going
to e to the one. In other words, E. So we
found that our original limit is equal to
E. And in fact, you may recognize that this
limit is one of the ways of defining E.
In the previous example, we had a one to the
infinity and determinant form. And we took
logs and used log rules to write that as an
infinity times zero indeterminate form. Well,
the same thing can be done if we have an infinity
to the zero indeterminate form, or a zero
to the zero and determinant form. So one to
the infinity, infinity to the zero, and zero
to the zero are all indeterminate forms that
can be handled using lobi TAs role. In this
video, we saw that a zero times infinity indeterminate
form could be converted to a zero over zero,
or infinity over infinity indeterminate form
by rewriting f of x times g of x as f of x
divided by one over g of x, or as g of x divided
by one over f of x. We also saw how to use
lopi talls rule on these three sorts of indeterminate
forms by taking the ln of y, where y is our
f of x to the g of x that we want to take
the limit of this video gives some tricks
for deciding whether a sequence converges.
We say that a sequence a sub n converges,
if the limit as n goes to infinity of the
terms, a sub n exists as a finite number.
Otherwise, we say the sequence diverges. In
other words, a sequence diverges if the limit
is infinity, or negative infinity, or does
not exist. More formally, we said the limit
as n goes to infinity of a sub n equals L,
if for any small number epsilon, there's a
number capital N, such that when the index
little n is bigger than or equal to capital
N, a sub n is within distance epsilon of owl.
Saying that a sedan is within distance epsilon
of L is the same thing as saying that the
absolute value of a sub n minus L is less
than epsilon. Let me draw this as a picture.
If we put in on the x axis and a sub n on
the y axis, we can plot our terms a sub n
like this, here, it looks like our a sub n
are settling at a particular value, I'll draw
the value on the y axis and call it L. We
say that the limit of a sub n is equal to
L. Because for any tiny number epsilon, here,
I've tried to draw a distance epsilon above
L and a distance epsilon below, we can trap
or a sub ends within epsilon of L by requiring
the index and to be big enough, for the epsilon
I've chosen here, are a sub ends are trapped
within epsilon of L, when little n is bigger
than equal to three. So there is that big
number n, which is here, like two or three,
such that when little n is bigger than that
the a sub n are always trapped within epsilon
of L. And if I chosen a tinier epsilon, I
would just have to go a little bit farther
out to make sure that my sequence was trapped
within epsilon of n about this is the epsilon
definition of a limit. Formally, we say the
limit as n goes to infinity of a sub n is
infinity. If for any big number, omega, there's
a number capital N, such that a sub n is bigger
than capital N, for a little n bigger than
or equal to capital N. In other words, no
matter how big an Omega I originally pick,
my terms a sub n are eventually true. Above
omega. Let me draw a picture for this one
too. My terms here again, are drawn in red.
And now if I pick a certain height omega,
eventually all my turns will be above omega.
And if I pick a different, bigger value of
omega, my terms will still eventually be bigger
than omega, I might just need to go further
out in my sequence.
In the previous example, we had a one to the
infinity and determinant form. And we took
logs and used log rules to write that as an
infinity times zero indeterminate form. Well,
the same thing can be done if we have an infinity
to the zero indeterminate form, or a zero
to the zero and determinant form. So one to
the infinity, infinity to the zero, and zero
to the zero are all indeterminate forms that
can be handled using lobi TAs role. In this
video, we saw that a zero times infinity indeterminate
form could be converted to a zero over zero,
or infinity over infinity indeterminate form
by rewriting f of x times g of x as f of x
divided by one over g of x, or as g of x divided
by one over f of x. We also saw how to use
lopi talls rule on these three sorts of indeterminate
forms by taking the ln of y, where y is our
f of x to the g of x that we want to take
the limit of this video gives some tricks
for deciding whether a sequence converges.
We say that a sequence a sub n converges,
if the limit as n goes to infinity of the
terms, a sub n exists as a finite number.
Otherwise, we say the sequence diverges. In
other words, a sequence diverges if the limit
is infinity, or negative infinity, or does
not exist. More formally, we said the limit
as n goes to infinity of a sub n equals L,
if for any small number epsilon, there's a
number capital N, such that when the index
little n is bigger than or equal to capital
N, a sub n is within distance epsilon of owl.
Saying that a sedan is within distance epsilon
of L is the same thing as saying that the
absolute value of a sub n minus L is less
than epsilon. Let me draw this as a picture.
If we put in on the x axis and a sub n on
the y axis, we can plot our terms a sub n
like this, here, it looks like our a sub n
are settling at a particular value, I'll draw
the value on the y axis and call it L. We
say that the limit of a sub n is equal to
L. Because for any tiny number epsilon, here,
I've tried to draw a distance epsilon above
L and a distance epsilon below, we can trap
or a sub ends within epsilon of L by requiring
the index and to be big enough, for the epsilon
I've chosen here, are a sub ends are trapped
within epsilon of L, when little n is bigger
than equal to three. So there is that big
number n, which is here, like two or three,
such that when little n is bigger than that
the a sub n are always trapped within epsilon
of L. And if I chosen a tinier epsilon, I
would just have to go a little bit farther
out to make sure that my sequence was trapped
within epsilon of n about this is the epsilon
definition of a limit. Formally, we say the
limit as n goes to infinity of a sub n is
infinity. If for any big number, omega, there's
a number capital N, such that a sub n is bigger
than capital N, for a little n bigger than
or equal to capital N. In other words, no
matter how big an Omega I originally pick,
my terms a sub n are eventually true. Above
omega. Let me draw a picture for this one
too. My terms here again, are drawn in red.
And now if I pick a certain height omega,
eventually all my turns will be above omega.
And if I pick a different, bigger value of
omega, my terms will still eventually be bigger
than omega, I might just need to go further
out in my sequence.
For this first value of omega, I would just
need to pick a capital N of about 123456.
Once my little ends are all bigger than six,
my Ace events are bigger than that omega,
and for this bigger value of omega, I need
to pick a value of capital N of about nine,
once my little ends are bigger than about
nine, all my as events would be bigger than
this omega. There's a similar definition for
the limit as n goes to infinity of a sub n
equaling negative infinity. Now we just need
to say that for any big negative number, omega,
there's a number. And such that a sub n is
less than omega for a little n bigger than
or equal to capital N. Please take a moment
and try to come up with an example of a sequence
that converges, a sequence that diverges to
infinity or negative infinity, and a sequence
that's bounded but still diverges. One example
of a convergent sequence is a sequence whenever
n, this sequence converges to zero, since
the limit as n goes to infinity of one over
N is zero. A divergent sequence is two to
the N. Since the limit as n goes to infinity
of two to the n is infinity. One example of
a sequence that's bounded, but still diverges
is negative one to the n. The sequence alternates
between negative one and one, depending on
whether n is odd, or even. So it's bounded
in between negative one and one. But it still
diverges because the limit does not exist.
Since the sequence doesn't settle at a single
value. The rest of this video will give some
techniques for proving that sequences converge.
The first technique is to use standard calculus
tricks for finding limits of functions. Even
though a sequence is only defined on positive
integers. Sometimes it's possible to find
a function defined on all positive real numbers
that agrees with our sequence on the integers.
In other words, the terms as of n are equal
to f of n for this function F. When this happens,
then if the limit as x goes to infinity of
f of x equals L, then the limit as n goes
to infinity of a sub n also equals out, the
red dots are converging to the same limit
as the blue function. So a lot of times, we
can figure out if a sequence converges by
replacing the terms a sub n with F of X for
some appropriate function, and then using
lobaton ruler, other tricks from calculus
one to show that the function limit exists.
Let's try that for the following example.
When the indices are missing, as in this example,
we'll assume that n starts at one and goes
to infinity. In order to prove that this sequence
converges, let's instead look at the function
f of x equals ln one plus two e to the x over
x, where x is a real number. Now let's look
at the limit as x goes to infinity of f of
x. That's the limit as x goes to infinity
of ln one plus two e to the x over x. And
as x goes to infinity in the x goes to infinity,
so one plus two times e to the x goes to infinity,
which means ln of that goes to infinity. So
the numerator is going to infinity as x goes
to infinity. And so as the denominator, we
have an infinity over an infinity indeterminate
form. So we can apply lobby towels rule and
take the derivative of the numerator over
the derivative of the denominator, the derivative
of the numerator one over one plus two times
e to the x times two times e to the x using
the chain rule, and the derivative of the
denominator is just one. We can take derivatives
here, because we're thinking of x as a real
number, not just an integer. Simplifying,
we still have an infinity over infinity indeterminate
form. So let's take the derivatives again,
For this first value of omega, I would just
need to pick a capital N of about 123456.
Once my little ends are all bigger than six,
my Ace events are bigger than that omega,
and for this bigger value of omega, I need
to pick a value of capital N of about nine,
once my little ends are bigger than about
nine, all my as events would be bigger than
this omega. There's a similar definition for
the limit as n goes to infinity of a sub n
equaling negative infinity. Now we just need
to say that for any big negative number, omega,
there's a number. And such that a sub n is
less than omega for a little n bigger than
or equal to capital N. Please take a moment
and try to come up with an example of a sequence
that converges, a sequence that diverges to
infinity or negative infinity, and a sequence
that's bounded but still diverges. One example
of a convergent sequence is a sequence whenever
n, this sequence converges to zero, since
the limit as n goes to infinity of one over
N is zero. A divergent sequence is two to
the N. Since the limit as n goes to infinity
of two to the n is infinity. One example of
a sequence that's bounded, but still diverges
is negative one to the n. The sequence alternates
between negative one and one, depending on
whether n is odd, or even. So it's bounded
in between negative one and one. But it still
diverges because the limit does not exist.
Since the sequence doesn't settle at a single
value. The rest of this video will give some
techniques for proving that sequences converge.
The first technique is to use standard calculus
tricks for finding limits of functions. Even
though a sequence is only defined on positive
integers. Sometimes it's possible to find
a function defined on all positive real numbers
that agrees with our sequence on the integers.
In other words, the terms as of n are equal
to f of n for this function F. When this happens,
then if the limit as x goes to infinity of
f of x equals L, then the limit as n goes
to infinity of a sub n also equals out, the
red dots are converging to the same limit
as the blue function. So a lot of times, we
can figure out if a sequence converges by
replacing the terms a sub n with F of X for
some appropriate function, and then using
lobaton ruler, other tricks from calculus
one to show that the function limit exists.
Let's try that for the following example.
When the indices are missing, as in this example,
we'll assume that n starts at one and goes
to infinity. In order to prove that this sequence
converges, let's instead look at the function
f of x equals ln one plus two e to the x over
x, where x is a real number. Now let's look
at the limit as x goes to infinity of f of
x. That's the limit as x goes to infinity
of ln one plus two e to the x over x. And
as x goes to infinity in the x goes to infinity,
so one plus two times e to the x goes to infinity,
which means ln of that goes to infinity. So
the numerator is going to infinity as x goes
to infinity. And so as the denominator, we
have an infinity over an infinity indeterminate
form. So we can apply lobby towels rule and
take the derivative of the numerator over
the derivative of the denominator, the derivative
of the numerator one over one plus two times
e to the x times two times e to the x using
the chain rule, and the derivative of the
denominator is just one. We can take derivatives
here, because we're thinking of x as a real
number, not just an integer. Simplifying,
we still have an infinity over infinity indeterminate
form. So let's take the derivatives again,
the derivative of the numerator is now two
times e to the x, and the derivative of the
denominator is also two times e to the x.
So their limit here is one. Since our function
converges to one, our sequence also converges
to one. So this original sequence converges
to one.
the derivative of the numerator is now two
times e to the x, and the derivative of the
denominator is also two times e to the x.
So their limit here is one. Since our function
converges to one, our sequence also converges
to one. So this original sequence converges
to one.
Another technique for proving that sequences
converge is to use the squeeze theorem and
trap the sequence between two simpler sequences
that converge to the same limit. In this example,
since sine and cosine are both bounded in
between one and negative one, we know that
cosine of n plus sine of n can't be any bigger
than two, certainly, or on a smaller than
negative two. If I divide all sides of this
inequality by n to the two thirds, we can
see that the original sequence is bounded
in between negative two over n to the two
thirds and two over n to the two thirds. Notice
that n to the two thirds has to be positive,
since as usual, we're assuming that n starts
as one and goes to infinity. And so dividing
by n to the two thirds does not switch the
inequality signs. Now it's easy to check that
the limit as n goes to infinity of negative
two over n to the two thirds is zero, since
as n goes to infinity, and to the two thirds
also goes to infinity. Similarly, the limit
as n goes to infinity of two over n to the
two thirds is zero. Since these two limits
are the same, we know by the squeeze theorem,
that the limit of our sequence in the middle
has to exist at equals zero. Also, it's a
remarkable fact that I won't prove here that
if a sub n is bounded, and monotonic, then
it has to converge. You might get some intuition
for this fact, by looking at a graph. If the
ace of ends are monotonically, increasing,
for example, but are bounded, then there's
no place for these events to go. And they
can't oscillate up and down. Because they're
monotonically increasing. So it makes intuitive
sense that they have to settle on some limit.
A fun example of this fact is a sequence that
starts point 1.1 2.12 3.1234, and so on. Where
we just keep stringing together the counting
numbers as our decimal, the sequence is certainly
monotonically increasing, and is bounded.
Since every term of the sequence is greater
than zero and less than, say, point five.
So we have a bounded monotonic sequence. And
so the sequence has to converge. Now, what
it actually converges to is a little mysterious,
since it doesn't converge to some number we're
already familiar with like, like, point six,
or pi over three or something like that. But
it does converge to some real number. And
that real number is called champion nouns
constant. And it has some interesting properties.
And of course, it has a decimal expansion
that's easy to to come up with, since you
get it just by stringing together the counting
numbers. If you can recognize a sequence to
be a geometric sequence, then it's pretty
easy to decide whether it converges or diverges.
Recall that a geometric sequence is a sequence
of the form a times r to the n minus one where
n runs from one to infinity. Or sometimes
it's written as a times r to the n, where
n runs from zero to infinity. Let's try to
figure out for what values of our the sequence
r to the n converges. It's not really important
here whether and starts at zero or starts
So one, since when we talk about convergence,
we're talking about the behavior of the terms
as n goes to infinity. So the first few terms
really don't matter. if r is greater than
one, then the sequence r to the n is an increasing
sequence. In fact, for the sequence r to the
n, if we replace n with x, and look at the
function f of x equals r to the x, that's
an exponential function. And if we're assuming
r is greater than one, the base for our exponential
functions is greater than one. So we know
that the limit as x goes to infinity of our
to the X is infinity, which means that our
sequence r to the n also has to diverge to
infinity.
Another technique for proving that sequences
converge is to use the squeeze theorem and
trap the sequence between two simpler sequences
that converge to the same limit. In this example,
since sine and cosine are both bounded in
between one and negative one, we know that
cosine of n plus sine of n can't be any bigger
than two, certainly, or on a smaller than
negative two. If I divide all sides of this
inequality by n to the two thirds, we can
see that the original sequence is bounded
in between negative two over n to the two
thirds and two over n to the two thirds. Notice
that n to the two thirds has to be positive,
since as usual, we're assuming that n starts
as one and goes to infinity. And so dividing
by n to the two thirds does not switch the
inequality signs. Now it's easy to check that
the limit as n goes to infinity of negative
two over n to the two thirds is zero, since
as n goes to infinity, and to the two thirds
also goes to infinity. Similarly, the limit
as n goes to infinity of two over n to the
two thirds is zero. Since these two limits
are the same, we know by the squeeze theorem,
that the limit of our sequence in the middle
has to exist at equals zero. Also, it's a
remarkable fact that I won't prove here that
if a sub n is bounded, and monotonic, then
it has to converge. You might get some intuition
for this fact, by looking at a graph. If the
ace of ends are monotonically, increasing,
for example, but are bounded, then there's
no place for these events to go. And they
can't oscillate up and down. Because they're
monotonically increasing. So it makes intuitive
sense that they have to settle on some limit.
A fun example of this fact is a sequence that
starts point 1.1 2.12 3.1234, and so on. Where
we just keep stringing together the counting
numbers as our decimal, the sequence is certainly
monotonically increasing, and is bounded.
Since every term of the sequence is greater
than zero and less than, say, point five.
So we have a bounded monotonic sequence. And
so the sequence has to converge. Now, what
it actually converges to is a little mysterious,
since it doesn't converge to some number we're
already familiar with like, like, point six,
or pi over three or something like that. But
it does converge to some real number. And
that real number is called champion nouns
constant. And it has some interesting properties.
And of course, it has a decimal expansion
that's easy to to come up with, since you
get it just by stringing together the counting
numbers. If you can recognize a sequence to
be a geometric sequence, then it's pretty
easy to decide whether it converges or diverges.
Recall that a geometric sequence is a sequence
of the form a times r to the n minus one where
n runs from one to infinity. Or sometimes
it's written as a times r to the n, where
n runs from zero to infinity. Let's try to
figure out for what values of our the sequence
r to the n converges. It's not really important
here whether and starts at zero or starts
So one, since when we talk about convergence,
we're talking about the behavior of the terms
as n goes to infinity. So the first few terms
really don't matter. if r is greater than
one, then the sequence r to the n is an increasing
sequence. In fact, for the sequence r to the
n, if we replace n with x, and look at the
function f of x equals r to the x, that's
an exponential function. And if we're assuming
r is greater than one, the base for our exponential
functions is greater than one. So we know
that the limit as x goes to infinity of our
to the X is infinity, which means that our
sequence r to the n also has to diverge to
infinity.
If instead, r is equal to one, then r to the
n is just one to the n, which is just a sequence
of ones, so that converges to one. if r is
between zero and one, then r to the n, is
decreasing. This time, it's like the exponential
function f of x equals r to the x with the
base between zero and one. And so the limit
of that exponential function, as x goes to
infinity is going to be equals zero. Therefore,
the sequence also converges to zero. Of course,
if r equals exactly zero, and
the sequence is just a sequence of zeros,
so it also converges to zero. Next, let's
look at the case when r is between negative
one and zero. Now, the sequence of rd ends
are going to oscillate between positive and
negative numbers that get smaller and smaller
and magnitude as n goes to infinity. That's
because we get from one number to the next
by multiplying by r, which is a negative number
of magnitude less than one. So our limit as
n goes to infinity of our A to the ends, is
going to be zero again. Another way of thinking
about this case, is by thinking about the
squeeze theorem, since r to the n is always
less than or equal to the absolute value of
r to the n, which is o n is always greater
than or equal to negative the absolute value
of r to the n. Technically, r to the n is
always exactly equal to the absolute value
are the n when n is even, so that art of the
N is positive. And it's always exactly equal
to the negative of the absolute value of r,
the N, when n is odd, so that are the n is,
is negative. But in any case, the inequality
still does technically hold. And so therefore,
since by the squeeze theorem, the limit of
the left terms is zero, and the limit of the
right terms is zero. As we noted before, the
limit of the middle term also has to be zero.
So our sequence converges to zero. Now, if
r is equal to negative one, then our sequence
r to the n is just negative one to the n,
which alternates between negative one and
one. And so that sequence diverges. Finally,
if r is less than negative one, then to get
from one term to the next, we're multiplying
by negative number that has magnitude bigger
than one. And so our terms are going to oscillate
between positive and negative numbers, but
they're going to be going up in magnitude.
And so the limit as n goes to infinity of
a sub n, does not exist. And we see that our
sequence diverges. If we look through all
these cases, we see that the sequence r to
the n converges to zero, when r is between
negative one and one. it converges to one
when r is exactly equal to one, and it diverges
when r is bigger than one or less than negative
one. All right, then Summary below. In fact,
almost the same thing as true, when we look
at the sequence a times r to the n, where
A is any real number, the sequence a times
r to the n converges to zero, when r is between
negative one and one. it converges to a, when
r is equal to one. And it diverges when r
is less than negative one, or greater than
one. This follows because multiplying all
the terms in the sequence by a just multiplies
the limit by a and zero times as zero, well,
one times i is a. So anytime you encounter
a geometric sequence, that is a sequence that
can be written in the form of a times r to
the n,
If instead, r is equal to one, then r to the
n is just one to the n, which is just a sequence
of ones, so that converges to one. if r is
between zero and one, then r to the n, is
decreasing. This time, it's like the exponential
function f of x equals r to the x with the
base between zero and one. And so the limit
of that exponential function, as x goes to
infinity is going to be equals zero. Therefore,
the sequence also converges to zero. Of course,
if r equals exactly zero, and the sequence
is just a sequence of zeros, so it also converges
to zero. Next, let's look at the case when
r is between negative one and zero. Now, the
sequence of rd ends are going to oscillate
between positive and negative numbers that
get smaller and smaller and magnitude as n
goes to infinity. That's because we get from
one number to the next by multiplying by r,
which is a negative number of magnitude less
than one. So our limit as n goes to infinity
of our A to the ends, is going to be zero
again. Another way of thinking about this
case, is by thinking about the squeeze theorem,
since r to the n is always less than or equal
to the absolute value of r to the n, which
is o n is always greater than or equal to
negative the absolute value of r to the n.
Technically, r to the n is always exactly
equal to the absolute value are the n when
n is even, so that art of the N is positive.
And it's always exactly equal to the negative
of the absolute value of r, the N, when n
is odd, so that are the n is, is negative.
But in any case, the inequality still does
technically hold. And so therefore, since
by the squeeze theorem, the limit of the left
terms is zero, and the limit of the right
terms is zero. As we noted before, the limit
of the middle term also has to be zero. So
our sequence converges to zero. Now, if r
is equal to negative one, then our sequence
r to the n is just negative one to the n,
which alternates between negative one and
one. And so that sequence diverges. Finally,
if r is less than negative one, then to get
from one term to the next, we're multiplying
by negative number that has magnitude bigger
than one. And so our terms are going to oscillate
between positive and negative numbers, but
they're going to be going up in magnitude.
And so the limit as n goes to infinity of
a sub n, does not exist. And we see that our
sequence diverges. If we look through all
these cases, we see that the sequence r to
the n converges to zero, when r is between
negative one and one. it converges to one
when r is exactly equal to one, and it diverges
when r is bigger than one or less than negative
one. All right, then Summary below. In fact,
almost the same thing as true, when we look
at the sequence a times r to the n, where
A is any real number, the sequence a times
r to the n converges to zero, when r is between
negative one and one. it converges to a, when
r is equal to one. And it diverges when r
is less than negative one, or greater than
one. This follows because multiplying all
the terms in the sequence by a just multiplies
the limit by a and zero times as zero, well,
one times i is a. So anytime you encounter
a geometric sequence, that is a sequence that
can be written in the form of a times r to
the n,
you can know that it converges if r is bigger
than negative one and less than or equal to
one. This sequence here, although it looks
really complicated, it's really a geometric
sequence in disguise. One way to see this
is by simplifying the form of the terms, so
this is negative one to the t, e to the t
times e to the minus one over three to the
T times three squared. This is the same thing
as negative e over three to the T times one
over three squared times E. Now this is looking
like the tail end of a geometric sequence,
where A is one over three squared times E,
and R, the common ratio is minus e over three,
say the tail end, because we have T starting
at three instead of zero. Now since he is
less than three, the magnitude of our is got
to be smaller than one. In other words, our
as a negative number, that's between negative
one and zero, and therefore, the tail end
of
this geometric sequence converges. It's kind
of interesting to note that we could also
rewrite this geometric sequence if we wanted
to, using an index and going from zero to
infinity. And one way to figure out how to
do that the are the common ratio stays the
same as negative e over three. But since this
version starts at t equals three, the first
term here is really minus e over three cubed
times one over three squared E. And that becomes
our value of A. Notice that when n is zero
here, I get this value. And when t is three,
here, I get the same value for this sequence.
So these sequences are equivalent. But in
any case, for either a sequence, the common
ratio, R is negative B over three, and a sequence
converges. Therefore, the final trick that
I want to mention for deciding whether sequences
converge or diverge is limit laws, the usual
limit laws about addition, subtraction, and
so on hold for sequences as well for functions.
So for example, if the limit as n goes to
infinity of a sub n is out, and the limit
of b sub n is am than the limit of the sum,
a sub n plus b sub n is going to be equal
to L plus m. And the limit of a sub n times
b sub n is L times M. And the limit of C times
a sub n where C is some constant is going
to be c times though similar roles holds for
subtraction and division. I want to emphasize
that these limit holds hold under the condition
that the limits of the component sequences
exist as finite numbers. I can use these limit
laws to decide if this sequence converges,
since the limit of the terms is equal to the
difference of the limits, provided those limits
exist. Now the first limit is zero, since
the degree of the numerator is less than the
degree of the denominator here, and the second
limit is also zero. Since this is a geometric
sequence, with ratio of four fifths, and four
fifths is between zero and one. Therefore,
the limit of our original sequence must be
zero. In this video, we saw several ways to
prove that a sequence converges. We saw that
we could use calculus techniques like lopi
taas rule. After replacing the sequence with
its associated function defined on real numbers,
we also saw that we could use the squeeze
theorem. we noted that all sequences that
are bounded and monotonic must converge. And
we saw that geometric sequences always converge
if r is bigger than negative one and less
than or equal to one. Finally, we saw that
we can use limit laws to handle sums and products
and other conglomerations of sequences. This
video is about geometric series, and when
they converge, and when they diverged.
you can know that it converges if r is bigger
than negative one and less than or equal to
one. This sequence here, although it looks
really complicated, it's really a geometric
sequence in disguise. One way to see this
is by simplifying the form of the terms, so
this is negative one to the t, e to the t
times e to the minus one over three to the
T times three squared. This is the same thing
as negative e over three to the T times one
over three squared times E. Now this is looking
like the tail end of a geometric sequence,
where A is one over three squared times E,
and R, the common ratio is minus e over three,
say the tail end, because we have T starting
at three instead of zero. Now since he is
less than three, the magnitude of our is got
to be smaller than one. In other words, our
as a negative number, that's between negative
one and zero, and therefore, the tail end
of this geometric sequence converges. It's
kind of interesting to note that we could
also rewrite this geometric sequence if we
wanted to, using an index and going from zero
to infinity. And one way to figure out how
to do that the are the common ratio stays
the same as negative e over three. But since
this version starts at t equals three, the
first term here is really minus e over three
cubed times one over three squared E. And
that becomes our value of A. Notice that when
n is zero here, I get this value. And when
t is three, here, I get the same value for
this sequence. So these sequences are equivalent.
But in any case, for either a sequence, the
common ratio, R is negative B over three,
and a sequence converges. Therefore, the final
trick that I want to mention for deciding
whether sequences converge or diverge is limit
laws, the usual limit laws about addition,
subtraction, and so on hold for sequences
as well for functions. So for example, if
the limit as n goes to infinity of a sub n
is out, and the limit of b sub n is am than
the limit of the sum, a sub n plus b sub n
is going to be equal to L plus m. And the
limit of a sub n times b sub n is L times
M. And the limit of C times a sub n where
C is some constant is going to be c times
though similar roles holds for subtraction
and division. I want to emphasize that these
limit holds hold under the condition that
the limits of the component sequences exist
as finite numbers. I can use these limit laws
to decide if this sequence converges, since
the limit of the terms is equal to the difference
of the limits, provided those limits exist.
Now the first limit is zero, since the degree
of the numerator is less than the degree of
the denominator here, and the second limit
is also zero. Since this is a geometric sequence,
with ratio of four fifths, and four fifths
is between zero and one. Therefore, the limit
of our original sequence must be zero. In
this video, we saw several ways to prove that
a sequence converges. We saw that we could
use calculus techniques like lopi taas rule.
After replacing the sequence with its associated
function defined on real numbers, we also
saw that we could use the squeeze theorem.
we noted that all sequences that are bounded
and monotonic must converge. And we saw that
geometric sequences always converge if r is
bigger than negative one and less than or
equal to one. Finally, we saw that we can
use limit laws to handle sums and products
and other conglomerations of sequences. This
video is about geometric series, and when
they converge, and when they diverged.
A geometric sequence is a sequence of the
form a a times r, a times r squared, a times
r cubed, and so on. For some numbers a and
r. this can be written in the wrapped up notation,
a times r to the k, where k goes from zero
to infinity. For example, if a is three, and
r is one half, the sequence would be three,
three halves, three fourths, three eighths,
and so on, which could be written as three
times one half to the k, where k ranges from
zero to infinity. A geometric series is the
series you get by adding all these numbers
up. So that would be a plus a times r plus
a times r squared, and so on, which can be
written in summation notation is the sum from
K equals zero to infinity of A times r to
the K. For our example, our series would be
the following, which could be written as the
sum from K equals zero to infinity of three
times one half to the K. Sometimes you might
get a geometric series that's in disguise,
like this one. If I write out the first few
terms, notice that we're told to start with
i equals two. So plugging in i equals two
here, I get negative one, squared over three
to the two times two minus three, that's one
over three. If I plug in i equals three, I
get negative one cubed, that's over three
to the two times three minus three, or negative
one over three cubed, negative 127. When I
go four, I get one over 243. If I look at
the ratio of consecutive terms, negative 127
divided by 1/3, is negative one night. Similarly,
the ratio here is also negative one nights,
suggesting that we might have a geometric
series with ratio R of negative 1/9. And first
term coming from here, of 1/3. But there's
another way to see this that's less arithmetic
intensive, and makes use of exponent rules.
If we look at the basic term, and rewrite
it using exponent rules, this is three to
the two i times three to the minus three,
I can rewrite the three to the two is three
squared to the I and the three to the minus
three and the denominator becomes a three
cubed and the numerator. Now I can group together
all the pieces that are raised to the nth
power. And write this as negative 1/9 to the
i times three cubed, or 27 times negative
one night to the I reading like this, I can
see that every time I increases by one, I
get another factor of negative one nine multiplied
in my expression. And therefore, the this
is a geometric series with ratio negative
one nine, as I saw before, now, you might
think that the first term should be 27. But
remember that it doesn't start at zero, it
starts at two. So the first term is going
to be what I get I get when I plug in the
first value of i. So that's 27 times negative
one nine squared, which works out to 1/3.
as before. So we do have a geometric series
with first term of 1/3, a common ratio of
negative 1/9. In fact, we could rewrite it
in a more standard form as the sum of 1/3
times negative 1/9 to the k, where k ranges
from zero to infinity. Since k equals zero,
and this expression corresponds to i equals
two in this expression, k is equal to, can
be thought of as equal to i minus two. And
this is really a reindexing tugann simplification
to get from this version to this version.
A geometric sequence is a sequence of the
form a a times r, a times r squared, a times
r cubed, and so on. For some numbers a and
r. this can be written in the wrapped up notation,
a times r to the k, where k goes from zero
to infinity. For example, if a is three, and
r is one half, the sequence would be three,
three halves, three fourths, three eighths,
and so on, which could be written as three
times one half to the k, where k ranges from
zero to infinity. A geometric series is the
series you get by adding all these numbers
up. So that would be a plus a times r plus
a times r squared, and so on, which can be
written in summation notation is the sum from
K equals zero to infinity of A times r to
the K. For our example, our series would be
the following, which could be written as the
sum from K equals zero to infinity of three
times one half to the K. Sometimes you might
get a geometric series that's in disguise,
like this one. If I write out the first few
terms, notice that we're told to start with
i equals two. So plugging in i equals two
here, I get negative one, squared over three
to the two times two minus three, that's one
over three. If I plug in i equals three, I
get negative one cubed, that's over three
to the two times three minus three, or negative
one over three cubed, negative 127. When I
go four, I get one over 243. If I look at
the ratio of consecutive terms, negative 127
divided by 1/3, is negative one night. Similarly,
the ratio here is also negative one nights,
suggesting that we might have a geometric
series with ratio R of negative 1/9. And first
term coming from here, of 1/3. But there's
another way to see this that's less arithmetic
intensive, and makes use of exponent rules.
If we look at the basic term, and rewrite
it using exponent rules, this is three to
the two i times three to the minus three,
I can rewrite the three to the two is three
squared to the I and the three to the minus
three and the denominator becomes a three
cubed and the numerator. Now I can group together
all the pieces that are raised to the nth
power. And write this as negative 1/9 to the
i times three cubed, or 27 times negative
one night to the I reading like this, I can
see that every time I increases by one, I
get another factor of negative one nine multiplied
in my expression. And therefore, the this
is a geometric series with ratio negative
one nine, as I saw before, now, you might
think that the first term should be 27. But
remember that it doesn't start at zero, it
starts at two. So the first term is going
to be what I get I get when I plug in the
first value of i. So that's 27 times negative
one nine squared, which works out to 1/3.
as before. So we do have a geometric series
with first term of 1/3, a common ratio of
negative 1/9. In fact, we could rewrite it
in a more standard form as the sum of 1/3
times negative 1/9 to the k, where k ranges
from zero to infinity. Since k equals zero,
and this expression corresponds to i equals
two in this expression, k is equal to, can
be thought of as equal to i minus two. And
this is really a reindexing tugann simplification
to get from this version to this version.
As you may know, a geometric sequence converges
to zero, when the common ratio R is between
negative one and one, it converges to a, when
r is equal to one, and it diverges. Otherwise,
when r is less than or equal to negative one,
or when r is greater than one. We're assuming
here, that A is not equal zero, since otherwise,
we'd have a very boring though convergent
sequence of all zeros. I want to restate this
convergence criteria in limit form, since
we'll use it later. But it's saying is that
when r is between negative one and one, the
limit, as K goes to infinity of A times r
to the K is zero, that's what it means to
converge to zero. when r is equal to one,
that limit is equal to A. And when r is less
than or equal to negative one or greater than
one, that limit does not exist as a finite
number. Now I'd like to find similar rules
in terms of r for when a geometric series
converges or diverges. Again, we'll assume
that a is not equal to zero. Since otherwise,
I just have a sum of a bunch of zeros, a boring
series that would converge to zero. Our strategy
is going to be to find a formula for the nth
partial sum of the series, and then take the
limit of partial sums. Since by definition,
that limit tells us whether the series converges
or diverges. Before we carry out that strategy,
I want to consider one special case, when
r is equal to one, then the series is just
a plus a plus a, and so that diverges to infinity
if A is positive, or to negative infinity,
if a is negative, remember, we're assuming
that A is not zero. so far is one our series
diverges. And from now on, we'll assume that
R is not equal to one. Let's look at a few
partial sums. The first partial sum S sub
one, just the first term A, S sub two is a
plus a times R, and so on. In general, the
nth partial sum s sub n is a plus a times
r plus a times r squared. And I continue until
let's see, the last term will be a times r
to the n minus one, the second last term will
be a times r to the n minus two. Notice that
the nth partial sum only goes up to A times
r to the n minus one. Since we're starting
at a which is a 10 to the zero. I'd like to
write the partial sum in a nicer form, so
I don't have to write all those dots. And
to do that, I'm going to use a trick, I'm
going to multiply both sides of this equation
by R. So on the left, I get r times s sub
n. And on the right, I'm going to multiply
each term by R. So the first term becomes
a times R, the second term A times r squared,
a times r cubed, and so on, the second to
last term becomes a times r to the n minus
one, and the last term becomes a times r to
the n. Notice that this equation, and the
equation under it have a lot of terms in common,
they match up along the diagonals. So if I
subtract the second equation from the first,
on the left side, I'm going to get s sub n
minus r times s sub n. But on the right side,
a lot of my terms will cancel, this term will
cancel the next one, this one cancels with
the previous one. And what I'm left with is
just a minus a times r to the n, I get a minus
sign here, because I'm subtracting the whole
equation. Now I can solve for a sub n, I can
factor it out. I'll factor out the A also
just to keep things tidy. And then I get that
s sub n is a times one minus r to the n over
one minus R. I don't have to worry about dividing
by one minus r that can't be zero, because
remember, I'm assuming that R is not one.
Now that I have a nice tidy formula for s
sub n, I can proceed to take the limit as
n goes to infinity and see if my sequence
of partial sums converges or diverges sets
the limit of my formula. And notice that the
only part of this formula that depends on
n is the art of the N, a one one minus are
all constants as far as n is concerned. So
we can use limit rurals. To take those out
of the limit, I can rewrite the limit as a
over one minus r times the limit of one minus
r to the n or even better as a over one minus
r times one minus the limit of r to the n.
Now this limit I've seen before, right on
this page, is the same as the limit I was
considering when I was looking at convergence
of sequences, where I use the same R, and
my A is equal to one. So we know that this
limit goes to zero, when r is between negative
one and one, and does not exist as a finite
number. when r is less than or equal to negative
one, or r is greater than one. Therefore,
the limit of the partial sums is going to
equal a over one minus r times one minus zero,
which is just a over one minus r, when r is
between negative one and one, and that limit,
will not exist as a finite number. when r
is less than or equal to negative one, or
r is greater than one. Since the limit also
doesn't exist as a finite number, when r is
one, I can add a little equality sign. And
now I've got all this cases for our covered
me write this down as a conclusion. The geometric
series converges to a over one minus R.
As you may know, a geometric sequence converges
to zero, when the common ratio R is between
negative one and one, it converges to a, when
r is equal to one, and it diverges. Otherwise,
when r is less than or equal to negative one,
or when r is greater than one. We're assuming
here, that A is not equal zero, since otherwise,
we'd have a very boring though convergent
sequence of all zeros. I want to restate this
convergence criteria in limit form, since
we'll use it later. But it's saying is that
when r is between negative one and one, the
limit, as K goes to infinity of A times r
to the K is zero, that's what it means to
converge to zero. when r is equal to one,
that limit is equal to A. And when r is less
than or equal to negative one or greater than
one, that limit does not exist as a finite
number. Now I'd like to find similar rules
in terms of r for when a geometric series
converges or diverges. Again, we'll assume
that a is not equal to zero. Since otherwise,
I just have a sum of a bunch of zeros, a boring
series that would converge to zero. Our strategy
is going to be to find a formula for the nth
partial sum of the series, and then take the
limit of partial sums. Since by definition,
that limit tells us whether the series converges
or diverges. Before we carry out that strategy,
I want to consider one special case, when
r is equal to one, then the series is just
a plus a plus a, and so that diverges to infinity
if A is positive, or to negative infinity,
if a is negative, remember, we're assuming
that A is not zero. so far is one our series
diverges. And from now on, we'll assume that
R is not equal to one. Let's look at a few
partial sums. The first partial sum S sub
one, just the first term A, S sub two is a
plus a times R, and so on. In general, the
nth partial sum s sub n is a plus a times
r plus a times r squared. And I continue until
let's see, the last term will be a times r
to the n minus one, the second last term will
be a times r to the n minus two. Notice that
the nth partial sum only goes up to A times
r to the n minus one. Since we're starting
at a which is a 10 to the zero. I'd like to
write the partial sum in a nicer form, so
I don't have to write all those dots. And
to do that, I'm going to use a trick, I'm
going to multiply both sides of this equation
by R. So on the left, I get r times s sub
n. And on the right, I'm going to multiply
each term by R. So the first term becomes
a times R, the second term A times r squared,
a times r cubed, and so on, the second to
last term becomes a times r to the n minus
one, and the last term becomes a times r to
the n. Notice that this equation, and the
equation under it have a lot of terms in common,
they match up along the diagonals. So if I
subtract the second equation from the first,
on the left side, I'm going to get s sub n
minus r times s sub n. But on the right side,
a lot of my terms will cancel, this term will
cancel the next one, this one cancels with
the previous one. And what I'm left with is
just a minus a times r to the n, I get a minus
sign here, because I'm subtracting the whole
equation. Now I can solve for a sub n, I can
factor it out. I'll factor out the A also
just to keep things tidy. And then I get that
s sub n is a times one minus r to the n over
one minus R. I don't have to worry about dividing
by one minus r that can't be zero, because
remember, I'm assuming that R is not one.
Now that I have a nice tidy formula for s
sub n, I can proceed to take the limit as
n goes to infinity and see if my sequence
of partial sums converges or diverges sets
the limit of my formula. And notice that the
only part of this formula that depends on
n is the art of the N, a one one minus are
all constants as far as n is concerned. So
we can use limit rurals. To take those out
of the limit, I can rewrite the limit as a
over one minus r times the limit of one minus
r to the n or even better as a over one minus
r times one minus the limit of r to the n.
Now this limit I've seen before, right on
this page, is the same as the limit I was
considering when I was looking at convergence
of sequences, where I use the same R, and
my A is equal to one. So we know that this
limit goes to zero, when r is between negative
one and one, and does not exist as a finite
number. when r is less than or equal to negative
one, or r is greater than one. Therefore,
the limit of the partial sums is going to
equal a over one minus r times one minus zero,
which is just a over one minus r, when r is
between negative one and one, and that limit,
will not exist as a finite number. when r
is less than or equal to negative one, or
r is greater than one. Since the limit also
doesn't exist as a finite number, when r is
one, I can add a little equality sign. And
now I've got all this cases for our covered
me write this down as a conclusion. The geometric
series converges to a over one minus R.
For
r between negative one and one, I can also
say that's the absolute value of r less than
one, and it diverges for the absolute value
of r greater than or equal to one. Let's use
this fact in this example. Remember that we
decided that this was a geometric series with
a common ratio r equal to negative one night,
and we found the first term a by plugging
in i equals two, and I got that first term
of 1/3. Since the absolute value of our sales
value of negative 1/9 is 1/9, which is less
than one, we know that the series converges,
and it converges to a over one minus r, so
that's 1/3 over one minus negative one nights,
which is 1/3 over one plus one night, that's
1/3 over 10 nights, which simplifies to three
tenths. In this video, we looked at geometric
series, with first term a common ratio R,
we saw that a geometric series will converge
if the absolute value of r is less than one.
And they'll diverged if the absolute value
of r is greater than or equal to one. In the
case that it converges, it converges to a
over one minus r, where A is the first term,
and r is the common ratio. This video explains
how to determine whether a series converges
or diverges using an integral. Let's start
with the series, the sum of one over n squared.
Please pause the video for a moment and think
about why this might converge or diverge.
The sum from n equals one to infinity of one
over n squared is closely related to the integral
from one to infinity of one over x squared
dx. Let me show you what I mean. In this picture,
I've graphed the function y equals one over
x squared in blue. in green, I've drawn a
bunch of rectangles, I've divided the x axis
into sub intervals of length one, and so each
rectangle has a base of length one, and a
height given by my functions value on the
right endpoint of the sub interval. So the
first rectangle has a base of one and a height
of one, so it has an area of one, the second
rectangle has a base of one and a height of
one over two squared, so that's 1/4. So the
area here is 1/4. The next rectangle base
of one again, and a height of 1/9, and so
on. The area of each rectangle is just the
same as its height, and its height is just
given by one over n squared for the appropriate
value of n In other words, if I write out
the first few terms of this series, it's exactly
the same as the areas of my rectangles. And
the sum of my series is just going to be the
total green area. Now my integral can also
be thought of in terms of area, this integral
represents the area from one to infinity.
Under my blue curve, we know that this area
is finite, because we know that this integral
converges by the P test where p is two. Now
if I just look at the rectangles, starting
with the second rectangle on, all of those
rectangles will lie below the blue curve,
and to the right of the line x equals one,
so they will have a smaller area, and therefore
the area of these rectangles from the second
one on has to converge to a finite number.
That is, the sum from n equals two to infinity
of one over n squared converges. We're interested
in the sum from one to infinity. But that's
just the area of this single rectangle plus
the area of all these rectangles with just
one more than this sum here. So it also converges
to a finite number. To recap, the chain of
logic goes like this. First, we solve the
integral represents a finite area, because
of the P test. From that, we can conclude
that the sum from n equals two to infinity
of one over n squared represents a smaller
and also finite area. And from that, we can
figure out that the sum from n equals one
to infinity has to represent a finite area.
So our series converges to a finite number.
Let's look at another example. The sum from
n equals one to infinity of one over the square
root of n.
r between negative one and one, I can also
say that's the absolute value of r less than
one, and it diverges for the absolute value
of r greater than or equal to one. Let's use
this fact in this example. Remember that we
decided that this was a geometric series with
a common ratio r equal to negative one night,
and we found the first term a by plugging
in i equals two, and I got that first term
of 1/3. Since the absolute value of our sales
value of negative 1/9 is 1/9, which is less
than one, we know that the series converges,
and it converges to a over one minus r, so
that's 1/3 over one minus negative one nights,
which is 1/3 over one plus one night, that's
1/3 over 10 nights, which simplifies to three
tenths. In this video, we looked at geometric
series, with first term a common ratio R,
we saw that a geometric series will converge
if the absolute value of r is less than one.
And they'll diverged if the absolute value
of r is greater than or equal to one. In the
case that it converges, it converges to a
over one minus r, where A is the first term,
and r is the common ratio. This video explains
how to determine whether a series converges
or diverges using an integral. Let's start
with the series, the sum of one over n squared.
Please pause the video for a moment and think
about why this might converge or diverge.
The sum from n equals one to infinity of one
over n squared is closely related to the integral
from one to infinity of one over x squared
dx. Let me show you what I mean. In this picture,
I've graphed the function y equals one over
x squared in blue. in green, I've drawn a
bunch of rectangles, I've divided the x axis
into sub intervals of length one, and so each
rectangle has a base of length one, and a
height given by my functions value on the
right endpoint of the sub interval. So the
first rectangle has a base of one and a height
of one, so it has an area of one, the second
rectangle has a base of one and a height of
one over two squared, so that's 1/4. So the
area here is 1/4. The next rectangle base
of one again, and a height of 1/9, and so
on. The area of each rectangle is just the
same as its height, and its height is just
given by one over n squared for the appropriate
value of n In other words, if I write out
the first few terms of this series, it's exactly
the same as the areas of my rectangles. And
the sum of my series is just going to be the
total green area. Now my integral can also
be thought of in terms of area, this integral
represents the area from one to infinity.
Under my blue curve, we know that this area
is finite, because we know that this integral
converges by the P test where p is two. Now
if I just look at the rectangles, starting
with the second rectangle on, all of those
rectangles will lie below the blue curve,
and to the right of the line x equals one,
so they will have a smaller area, and therefore
the area of these rectangles from the second
one on has to converge to a finite number.
That is, the sum from n equals two to infinity
of one over n squared converges. We're interested
in the sum from one to infinity. But that's
just the area of this single rectangle plus
the area of all these rectangles with just
one more than this sum here. So it also converges
to a finite number. To recap, the chain of
logic goes like this. First, we solve the
integral represents a finite area, because
of the P test. From that, we can conclude
that the sum from n equals two to infinity
of one over n squared represents a smaller
and also finite area. And from that, we can
figure out that the sum from n equals one
to infinity has to represent a finite area.
So our series converges to a finite number.
Let's look at another example. The sum from
n equals one to infinity of one over the square
root of n.
Please pause the video for a moment and think
about how you might use an integral to decide
if this series converges or diverges. A natural
integral to consider is the integral from
one to infinity of one over the square root
of x dx. This integral diverges by the P test,
where p is equal to one half, which is less
than one. Let's look at a picture to compare
areas. The blue curve here is the graph of
the function y equals one over the square
root of x. And here, once again, I've drawn
green rectangles using the right endpoints
to get the heights of the rectangles. So the
areas of my rectangles are the same as the
terms in my series. As in the previous problem,
if I ignore the first rectangle, then all
the rest of the rectangles have an area that's
less than the area under my curve from one
to infinity. But there's a serious problem
here, the integral from one to infinity of
one over the square root of x dx diverges
to infinity, the area of my rectangles from
the second one on might be less than my area
under the blue curve. But being less than
something that diverges to infinity, it tells
us nothing, this series could converge or
it could diverged. But don't give up hope.
If we just tweak this picture a little bit,
we'll be able to get something that we can
use here. In this second picture, I've used
left endpoints instead of right endpoints
for the heights of my rectangles. Because
my function y equals one over the square root
of x is a decreasing function. Using left
endpoints, makes my rectangles have a larger
area than the area under the corresponding
section of the curve. let me label the rectangles
with their areas. The areas of these rectangles
correspond to the terms in my series. But
now we have that the area of the green rectangles,
that total area, that total area is bigger
than the integral from one to infinity of
one over x squared of x dx.
Please pause the video for a moment and think
about how you might use an integral to decide
if this series converges or diverges. A natural
integral to consider is the integral from
one to infinity of one over the square root
of x dx. This integral diverges by the P test,
where p is equal to one half, which is less
than one. Let's look at a picture to compare
areas. The blue curve here is the graph of
the function y equals one over the square
root of x. And here, once again, I've drawn
green rectangles using the right endpoints
to get the heights of the rectangles. So the
areas of my rectangles are the same as the
terms in my series. As in the previous problem,
if I ignore the first rectangle, then all
the rest of the rectangles have an area that's
less than the area under my curve from one
to infinity. But there's a serious problem
here, the integral from one to infinity of
one over the square root of x dx diverges
to infinity, the area of my rectangles from
the second one on might be less than my area
under the blue curve. But being less than
something that diverges to infinity, it tells
us nothing, this series could converge or
it could diverged. But don't give up hope.
If we just tweak this picture a little bit,
we'll be able to get something that we can
use here. In this second picture, I've used
left endpoints instead of right endpoints
for the heights of my rectangles. Because
my function y equals one over the square root
of x is a decreasing function. Using left
endpoints, makes my rectangles have a larger
area than the area under the corresponding
section of the curve. let me label the rectangles
with their areas. The areas of these rectangles
correspond to the terms in my series. But
now we have that the area of the green rectangles,
that total area, that total area is bigger
than the integral from one to infinity of
one over x squared of x dx.
Since this integral diverges, and this series
is larger, it must diverged also. This method
of comparing a series to an integral is a
very general method for showing convergence.
It's known as the interval test. The integral
test says that if f is a continuous positive
and decreasing function on the interval from
one to infinity, and our terms a sub n are
equal to f evaluated at n, then if the integral
from one to infinity of f of x dx converges,
the series from one to infinity of a sub n
converges. And if the integral from one to
infinity of f of x dx diverges, then the series
diverges. Although I won't give a formal proof
of this theorem, the logic behind is the same
logic we used in the previous two examples.
If the interval converges, we use the picture
here, using write endpoints to draw rectangles.
The area of each rectangle is the same as
its height, since the rectangle has base one,
and the height of each rectangle is just f
sub n. So the area of the first rectangle
is just f sub one, which is a sub one, the
area the second rectangle is F sub two, which
is a sub two, and so on. If we focus on the
second rectangle onwards, then the combined
area of those rectangles is less than the
area represented by the integral. So we can
say the sum from n equals two to infinity
of a sub n is less than or equal to the integral.
So the integral converges by assumption, this
series here has to converge, and therefore,
our original series from n equals one to infinity
must also converge. If instead, our integral
diverges, then we use the other picture, and
we use left endpoints for our rectangles,
the areas of the rectangles are still given
by a sub one, a sub two, and so on. But this
time, the combined area of the green rectangles,
that area is now greater than or equal to
the integral of our function. Since this integral
diverges, the larger area must diverged as
well. That's the idea behind the integral
test. And to apply it, we just need to be
able to integrate the function that corresponds
to our terms, and check that that function
is continuous, positive and decreasing. Actually,
it's enough to check that the function is
eventually continuous, positive and decreasing.
By eventually I mean that it has these properties
on some interval from R to infinity for some
number R. This is good enough, because then
I can always draw the same pictures, just
starting with R instead of one in my picture,
and get the integral converges if and only
if the series starting at our converges by
the same arguments we use before, but the
series starting at our converges if and only
if the series starting at one converges, since
adding on Finally, many extra terms to my
series doesn't affect whether it converges
or not. And the integral from R to infinity
converges if and only if the integral from
one to infinity converges, because similarly,
adding on a finite little piece of area from
one to R, doesn't change the convergent status
of the integral. So by this chain of logic,
it's okay if our function starts out increasing
for a while, as long as it's eventually positive,
continuous and decreasing. Here's an example
of the integral test and action. We want to
know if the sum from n equals one to infinity
of ln n over n, converges or diverges. So
let's look instead at the integral from one
to infinity of ln of x
Since this integral diverges, and this series
is larger, it must diverged also. This method
of comparing a series to an integral is a
very general method for showing convergence.
It's known as the interval test. The integral
test says that if f is a continuous positive
and decreasing function on the interval from
one to infinity, and our terms a sub n are
equal to f evaluated at n, then if the integral
from one to infinity of f of x dx converges,
the series from one to infinity of a sub n
converges. And if the integral from one to
infinity of f of x dx diverges, then the series
diverges. Although I won't give a formal proof
of this theorem, the logic behind is the same
logic we used in the previous two examples.
If the interval converges, we use the picture
here, using write endpoints to draw rectangles.
The area of each rectangle is the same as
its height, since the rectangle has base one,
and the height of each rectangle is just f
sub n. So the area of the first rectangle
is just f sub one, which is a sub one, the
area the second rectangle is F sub two, which
is a sub two, and so on. If we focus on the
second rectangle onwards, then the combined
area of those rectangles is less than the
area represented by the integral. So we can
say the sum from n equals two to infinity
of a sub n is less than or equal to the integral.
So the integral converges by assumption, this
series here has to converge, and therefore,
our original series from n equals one to infinity
must also converge. If instead, our integral
diverges, then we use the other picture, and
we use left endpoints for our rectangles,
the areas of the rectangles are still given
by a sub one, a sub two, and so on. But this
time, the combined area of the green rectangles,
that area is now greater than or equal to
the integral of our function. Since this integral
diverges, the larger area must diverged as
well. That's the idea behind the integral
test. And to apply it, we just need to be
able to integrate the function that corresponds
to our terms, and check that that function
is continuous, positive and decreasing. Actually,
it's enough to check that the function is
eventually continuous, positive and decreasing.
By eventually I mean that it has these properties
on some interval from R to infinity for some
number R. This is good enough, because then
I can always draw the same pictures, just
starting with R instead of one in my picture,
and get the integral converges if and only
if the series starting at our converges by
the same arguments we use before, but the
series starting at our converges if and only
if the series starting at one converges, since
adding on Finally, many extra terms to my
series doesn't affect whether it converges
or not. And the integral from R to infinity
converges if and only if the integral from
one to infinity converges, because similarly,
adding on a finite little piece of area from
one to R, doesn't change the convergent status
of the integral. So by this chain of logic,
it's okay if our function starts out increasing
for a while, as long as it's eventually positive,
continuous and decreasing. Here's an example
of the integral test and action. We want to
know if the sum from n equals one to infinity
of ln n over n, converges or diverges. So
let's look instead at the integral from one
to infinity of ln of x
over x.
This is a continuous function, because it's
the quotient of two continuous functions,
and we're starting at an x value of one, so
we don't have to worry about the denominator
being zero. It's also a positive function.
Since we know that ln of x is greater than
zero for x bigger than one, and therefore
this quotient is greater than
This is a continuous function, because it's
the quotient of two continuous functions,
and we're starting at an x value of one, so
we don't have to worry about the denominator
being zero. It's also a positive function.
Since we know that ln of x is greater than
zero for x bigger than one, and therefore
this quotient is greater than
zero also.
Finally, let's check if our function is decreasing.
One way to do that is to look at the derivative.
If f of x is ln x over x, then f prime of
x by the quotient rule is x times one over
x minus ln x times one over x squared. This
simplifies to one minus ln x over x squared,
which is negative when one minus ln x is less
than zero, that is one is less than our an
x, that is E is less than x. So the function
has a negative derivative and is decreasing
whenever x is bigger than E, so it's eventually
decreasing the three conditions
Finally, let's check if our function is decreasing.
One way to do that is to look at the derivative.
If f of x is ln x over x, then f prime of
x by the quotient rule is x times one over
x minus ln x times one over x squared. This
simplifies to one minus ln x over x squared,
which is negative when one minus ln x is less
than zero, that is one is less than our an
x, that is E is less than x. So the function
has a negative derivative and is decreasing
whenever x is bigger than E, so it's eventually
decreasing the three conditions
They're met, so we can apply the integral
test. Next, we need to figure out if this
integral converges
or diverges.
This is an improper integral. So by definition,
it's the limit as t goes to infinity of the
integral from one to T of ln x over x. We
can use use of the tuition to evaluate it,
where u is equal to ln x, d u is equal to
one over x dx. And when x is equal to one,
u is equal to ln of one, that's zero, when
x is equal to t, u is equal to ln of t. Substituting
in, we get the integral from zero to ln T
of you do this integrates to use squared over
two evaluated between ln T and zero.
Substituting in our bounds of integration,
we get the limit as t goes to infinity of
ln t squared over two minus zero. Now as t
goes to infinity, ln of T also goes to infinity.
So ln t squared over two goes to infinity,
therefore, the integral diverges. And so by
the integral test, the series also diverges.
In this video, we saw that a series converges
if and only if the corresponding integral
converges, provided that the corresponding
function is eventually continuous, positive
and decreasing. In this video, we'll determine
whether series converge or diverge by comparing
them to more familiar series. Suppose that
the sum of a sub n and the sum of b sub n
are series. And suppose that the terms of
the series are always greater than or equal
to zero, and that a sub n is less than or
equal to b sub n for all n. In the pictures
below, the heights of the blue bars are supposed
to represent the ACE events, and the heights
of the green bars are supposed to represent
the base events. If we put the pictures together,
we see that the heights of the blue bars are
less than the heights of the green bars. So
we have the inequality, zero is less than
or equal to a sub n is less than or equal
to b sub n. Since the base of each bar has
length one, the height of each bar is the
same number as its area. So when we write
the sum from n equals one to infinity, of
a sub n, this represents the area of all the
blue rectangles added up the total blue area.
And when we write sum from n equals one to
infinity of b sub n, this represents the area
of all the green rectangles, the total green
area. Because the blue bars have a smaller
area than the green bars, we can make some
conclusions. First of all, if the total green
area is finite, then so is the total blue
area. In other words, if the sum of the b
sub n converges, then so does the sum of the
A sub N. Furthermore, if the total blue area
is infinite, then so is the total green area.
So we can also say, if the sum of the ace
of ends diverges, then so does the sum of
the base events. These facts are known as
the comparison test for series and are very
useful in establishing convergence. But we
have to be careful not to take the conclusions
too far. In particular, if the smaller series
of Ace events converges, then we really can't
say anything about the larger series of these
events. The some of the big events could converge,
red could diverge. Also, if the larger series
of B sub ends diverges, then we can't conclude
anything about the smaller series of Ace events,
the sum of the ACE events could converge or
could diverged. When using the comparison
test to establish convergence or divergence,
it's handy to compare your unfamiliar series
to a familiar series that you already know
converges or diverges. The following series
are especially handy when making these comparisons.
First, the geometric series Sum of A times
r to the n, which converges when the absolute
value of r is less than one. And second, the
P series, one over n to the P, which converges
when p is greater than one. Let's use a comparison
theorem to determine whether the sum of three
to the n over five to the n plus n squared
converges or diverges. What matters most as
far as whether a series converges or diverges
is the behavior of the terms, when n gets
close to infinity, the behavior of the terms
when n is small, the behavior the first few
terms doesn't make any difference as far as
whether that series converges or diverges.
So I'm going to focus on what happens to these
terms, as n goes to infinity, well, three
to the n goes to infinity, and five to the
n goes to infinity, and n squared also goes
to infinity.
But between five to the n and n squared, five
to the n is going to infinity much faster.
So I'm going to say that this five to the
n term dominates the denominator, it's more
important. And for that reason, the behavior
of the series we're given should be similar
to the behavior of the series, three to the
n, over five to the n, where I've just left
out the n squared term, which is insignificant
compared to five to the n when n is large.
So I'm going to compare our given series to
this other series, which is a geometric series.
In fact,
the second series we know converges, because
it has a common ratio of three fifths, and
the absolute value of three fifths is less
than one. In order to use the comparison theorem,
I'm going to need to compare the terms of
this series to the terms of this series. And
I want to show that these terms are less than
or equal to those terms, because being smaller
than a convergent series will guarantee convergence
is clear that everything's positive, so we
don't have to worry about that. And it's also
clear that five to the n plus n squared is
bigger than or equal to five to the n. When
you divide by a bigger number, you get a smaller
ratio. So three to the n over five to the
n plus n squared is therefore less than or
equal to three to the n over five to the n,
we've shown that the inequality we need holds.
And so by the comparison theorem, since the
sum of three to the n over five to the n converges,
so does our original series. We've established
convergence using the comparison test.
This video was about the comparison test,
the fact that if we have zero less than or
equal to A ad less than or equal to bn, and
the sum of the bands converges, then the sum
of the smaller series A ends converges. And
if the sum of the ends diverges, then the
sum of the larger series diverges. The limit
comparison test gives an alternative to the
regular ordinary comparison test for series.
In the previous video, we looked at the series
the sum from n equals one to infinity of three
to the n over five to the n plus n squared.
And we use the ordinary comparison test and
compare it to the series, the sum of three
to the n over five to the n. This worked out
pretty nicely, because the terms here are
less than the terms here. And this series
converges. being less than a convergent series
ensures convergence. But if we change the
problem very slightly, and look instead at
the sum of three to the n over five to the
n minus n squared, look how things start to
go wrong. If we now try to compare to the
same series, then we get the inequality five
to the n minus n squared is less than or equal
to five to the n, and therefore, three to
the n over five to the n minus n squared is
greater than or equal to three to the n over
five to the n. Since dividing by a smaller
number gives a larger fraction, but this inequality
unfortunately, is not useful to us, being
greater than a convergence series doesn't
guarantee convergence or divergence. So we
can't conclude anything Based on this inequality,
the limit comparison test gives us one way
around this. The limit comparison test says
the following. Suppose that sum of a n and
the sum of bn are series with positive terms.
If the limit as n goes to infinity of the
ratio of a n over bn, is a number L, where
L is a finite number that's bigger than zero,
then either a both series converge,
or both diverge, so they have the same convergence
status. Let's try the limit comparison test
on the problem we were just working on. We
still want to compare to the same series,
three to the n over five to the n.
But this time, we're going to try a limit
comparison. So we're going to take the limit,
as n goes to infinity of the ratio of terms,
three to the n over five to the n, divided
by three to the n over five to the n minus
n squared, it doesn't actually matter which
term goes on the top and which goes on the
bottom, we could instead take the ratio the
other way, whatever limit we get, when we
do the ratio, this way, will just be the reciprocal
of the limit, we get When do the ratio this
way. So if this ratio is a finite number that's
bigger than zero, this ratio is reciprocal
will also be a finite number that's bigger
than zero. So I'll just stick with the first
computation. let me simplify by flipping and
multiplying, I can cancel my three to the
ends. And now I can actually rewrite this
as the limit of one minus n squared over five
to the n. By breaking out my limit, this is
the same as one minus the limit of n squared
over a five to the n. And the second limit
is an infinity over infinity form. So using
lopi talls rule, carry the one over, I get
and get the limit of what I get when I take
the derivative of the numerator and the derivative
of the denominator, I've still got an infinity
over infinity and determinant form. So I'll
use Libby toss rule again, the derivative
of two n is two, and the derivative of the
denominator is ln five times ln five times
five to the n. Now the numerator is fixed
at two, while the denominator goes to infinity
as n goes to infinity, therefore this fraction
goes to zero. And my final limit is one. Since
one is bigger than zero, and it's finite,
it's less than infinity. The limit comparison
test tells me that my original series and
my comparison series, either both converge,
or both diverged. But my comparison series
is a geometric series with ratio three fifths,
so it definitely converges. Therefore, by
the limit comparison test, our given series
also converge us. That's the Limit Comparison
theorem in action. The limit comparison test
tells us that for two series with positive
terms, if the limit of the ratio of the terms
is some number, which is bigger than zero
and less than infinity, then the two theories
have the same convergence status. That is,
they either both converge or both diverged.
The limit comparison test is especially handy
when the ordinary comparison test doesn't
seem to work when we know what we want to
compare to, but we can't get the inequality
to go the right direction. In this video,
I'll prove that the limit comparison test
works. The limit comparison test says that
if the sum of the ACE events, and the sum
of the B sub ends are two series with positive
terms. And if the limit as n goes to infinity
of the ratio, a sub n over B sub n is equal
to L, where L is a finite number that's bigger
than zero, then either both series converge
or both series diverged. To prove this theorem,
let's start by assuming that all the hypotheses
are true. That is, we'll assume all the stuff
in brackets here is true. The limit as n goes
to infinity of a sub n over B sub n equals
L means that if I plot the numbers, 123, and
so on, on the x axis, so those are the values
of n, and I plot the ratios, a sub n over
B sub n, on the y axis, those ratios are going
to settle down to a value of L, as n goes
to infinity. Using more technical mathematical
language, it means that for any small
number, epsilon that's bigger than zero, we
can trap the ratios within epsilon of L, as
long as we go out far enough for our values
of n. That is, there exists a number capital
N, such that n over bn is between L plus epsilon.
And l minus epsilon for little n bigger than
or equal to capital N. In the picture here,
value for capital N of three would work, because
for all little ends bigger than or equal to
three, my ratios are trapped in between r
minus epsilon, which is right here, and l
plus epsilon, which is that upper bound here.
Let's pick a small enough epsilon. So this
interval here doesn't extend all the way down
to zero through zero on the y axis, it just
extends through through positive numbers near
owl. Recall that that l itself is a positive
number, so it's possible to trap it in a little
interval. That's all positive numbers. For
example, we could pick epsilon to be equal
to L over two, for example,
that way, the interval that I'm drawing here
would extend down to l minus l over two, which
is equal to L over two, and our extend up
to l plus l over two, which is three L over
two. So we have that l over two is less than
a n over bn is less than three L over two,
four little n bigger than or equal to our
capital N that works for that value of epsilon.
Now, I'm going to multiply all three sides
of this inequality by b sub n, recall that
b sub n is a positive number, all the series
terms are positive, so that doesn't change
around the inequalities at all. So we get
L over two times b sub n is less than a sub
n is less than three L over two times b sub
n. And remember that everything here is bigger
than zero, since all the ACE events and B
sub ends are positive. Let's think about what
this inequality tells us. First of all, if
the sum of the beast events converges, then
so does the sum of three L over two times
b sub n, because I'm just multiplying that
series by a constant still convergent. But
now my a sub n terms are less than the terms
of a convergent series. So by the ordinary
comparison test, we know that the sum of the
ACE events converges also. Furthermore, if
the sum of the base events diverges, then
we can focus on this part of the inequality,
we know that l over two times b sub n diverges
also. And so here we have
the ace of ends are bigger than the terms
of a Divergent series, so the sum of the AC
bands must diverged, just using the ordinary
comparison test. Now, you might be worried
about the fact that this inequality only holds
for little n bigger than or equal to some
capital N. So we could rewrite this argument
a little bit to say, if the sum from n equals
one to infinity of the base events converges,
then so does the sum from n equals capital
n to infinity of b sub n, because adding or
subtracting finitely many terms off the front
never changes the convergence status of a
series. After that, we can say well, then
so does the sum from n equals capital n to
infinity. Three L over two times b sub n.
And so then by the ordinary comparison test,
since this inequality does hold for our little
n bigger than or equal to capital N, we can
conclude that the sum from little n equals
capital n to infinity of a sub n converges.
And so the sum from n equals one to infinity
of a sub n converges Also, since again, adding
or subtracting Finally, many terms from the
beginning of a series doesn't change anything
about convergence. We could similarly rewrite
the second part of the argument using precise
indices as well. We've shown that the sum
of the B ends and the sum of the A ends either
both converge, or both diverged. And that
completes the proof of the theorem. In this
video, we prove the limit comparison test
using the ordinary comparison test. This video
defines absolute convergence and how it's
related to convergence for a series. A series
is called absolutely convergent. If the series
of absolute values of the terms converges.
Please pause the video for a moment and try
to decide which of the following series are
convergent, and which ones are absolutely
convergent. The first series is convergent,
because it's a geometric series with ratio
r equal to negative 0.8. It's also absolutely
convergent, because if I take the series of
absolute values, that's the same thing as
the series, the geometric series with a ratio
of 0.8, which is also convergent. The second
series, the sum of one over the square root
of k is not convergent, we can see this by
the P test. Since p is equal to one half,
which is less than one. It's also not absolutely
convergent. In this case, the sum of the absolute
values of the terms is just the same as the
sum of the original terms, which we already
said diverges. The third series is the sum
of negative one to the J times one over j.
This is a convergent series by the alternating
series test. In fact, this is the alternating
harmonic series. What about absolute convergence?
If we look at the sum of the absolute values
of the terms, that's just the same thing as
the regular harmonic series, which diverges.
So this series is not absolutely convergent.
Here's a question for you. Is it possible
to have a series that's convergent, but not
absolutely convergent? Please pause the video
for a moment and try to answer this question.
The answer is yes. We just saw us an example
of such a series, the alternating harmonic
series. There are many other examples of such
theories. And in fact, there's a special name
for them, they're called conditionally convergent.
A series is called conditionally convergent
if it is convergent, but not absolutely convergent.
In symbols, that is, the sum of the a ns converges,
but the sum of the absolute values of the
a ns diverges. Next question for you. Is it
possible to have a series that's absolutely
convergent, but not convergent? This is a
little trickier. But please pause the video
for a moment and think about your answer.
The answer to this one is no. It's a fact
that every absolutely convergent series is
convergent. Let me prove to you why that's
true. Let's suppose that we have a series
that's absolutely convergent. That is the
sum of the absolute value of the A ends convergence.
We know that the A ends might be positive
or negative, but they do have to lie in between
the absolute value of a n and the negative
absolute value of a n. Actually, it's true
that a sub n is either equal to its absolute
value or its negative absolute value, but
I'm ready This way with inequalities to help
set the mood for using the comparison test.
Now, I can't quite use a comparison test here
to prove that the series of Ace events converges,
because even though the ace of ends are less
than or equal to the terms of a convergent
series, they're not necessarily positive or
greater than equals zero. And the can parison
test only applies to series whose terms are
all greater than equal to or equal to zero.
But there's a nice trick to get around that
difficulty. And that trick is to add the absolute
value of a sub n to all the sides of the inequality.
So then I get zero is less than or equal to
a sub n plus the absolute value of a sub n,
which is less than or equal to twice the absolute
value of a sub n. Now, since this sum of the
absolute value of f sub n converges, so does
the sum of twice the absolute value of a sub
n, since it's just a constant multiple. Based
on this inequality, which now does involve
terms that are greater than or equal to zero,
I can conclude that the sum of a sub n plus
the absolute value of a sub n converges based
on the ordinary comparison test. But now,
the series that we want, the sum of the ace
of ends can be written as a difference. And
we know that a series formed by subtracting
the terms of two convergent series itself
converges. So this converges, in fact, to
the difference of the sobs. We've proved that
if our series is absolutely convergent, then
it must be convergent. The fact that absolute
convergence implies convergence can come in
handy when you're trying to prove that a series
converges, as in the following example. In
this example, we want to prove that this series
is convergent or divergent, but the cosine
and sine make things a little bit tricky.
My intuition here is that this series should
converge since cosine and sine are bounded.
And so this essentially should behave something
like the sum of one over n cubed, which converges
because of the P
test.
But we can't just compare our series to the
sum of one over n cubed and use the ordinary
comparison test like we've done in similar
problems in the past. What's different here
is that our terms are not always going to
be positive, because sine and cosine can be
positive and negative. And so can there's
some to help us out of this pickle. Let's
think about absolute convergence instead.
If we look at the sum of the absolute values,
which is the same as the sum of the absolute
value of the numerator, divided by m cubed.
Since cosine of n is between one and negative
one, and sine of n is also in between one
and negative one, we know that the som cosine
n plus sine of n has to be less than or equal
to two and bigger than or equal to negative
two. In fact, it can't even get all the way
to two or all the way down to negative two,
we could find that tighter bound if we tried,
but this is good enough for our purposes,
this inequality can be rewritten as the absolute
value of cosine n plus sine of n is less than
or equal to two. And if I divide both sides
here by n cubed, I have an inequality involving
positive terms. So since we know the sum of
one over n cubed converges by the P test,
that implies that the sum of two over n cubed
also converges. It's just a constant multiple.
And that implies that the sum of my absolute
value of cosine n plus sine n over n cubed
converges by the comparison test. Therefore,
we know that our series is absolutely convergent.
And therefore, it must be convergent. Since
an absolutely convergent series is always
convergent. We've shown that our original
series converges. In this video, we saw that
if a series is absolutely convergent, then
it has to be convergent But not vice versa.
This video is about the ratio test, a test
that can be used to prove that a series converges
or diverges. The ratio test is all about looking
at the ratio of consecutive terms. To figure
out how it works, it can be helpful to think
about geometric series first, recall it for
a geometric series, the ratio of consecutive
terms is given by this number R. And if R
has absolute value less than one, the series
converges. Why while if R has absolute value
greater than one, it diverges. For more general
series, the ratio of consecutive terms is
not necessarily a constant. But if we look
at the limit as n goes to infinity, of the
absolute value of the ratio of consecutive
terms, and if we get a limit of L, which is
less than one, then the series converges,
just like a geometric series. In fact, the
series is absolutely convergent, meaning the
sum of the absolute values of the a ns converges,
and therefore, the sum of the a ns converges
also, if instead, the limit as n goes to infinity
of the absolute value of the ratio of consecutive
terms, is a number l that's greater than one.
Or if that limit is infinity, then just like
a geometric series, the series diverges. Finally,
if the limit of the absolute value of the
ratio of consecutive terms is exactly equal
to one, or if the limit doesn't exist, then
the ratio test is inconclusive. That is, the
sum of the ace of ends may converge. Or it
may diverge. And to figure out, which will
have to use a different test or a different
argument, let's apply the ratio test to this
series, we'll need to compute the limit as
n goes to infinity of the absolute value of
the ratio of consecutive terms. In this case,
that's the limit as n goes to infinity, have
the absolute value of n plus one
squared
times negative 10 to the n plus one divided
by n plus one factorial, all of our n squared
times negative 10 to the n over n factorial.
I've just plugged in n plus one for n in this
formula to get the a sub n plus one term.
I can simplify this by flipping and multiplying.
And I'm going to rearrange my factors. This
expression is equivalent to the previous one,
I've just arranged factors so that similar
factors are on top of each other, this will
make it easier to cancel things. Now, n factorial
means n times n minus one times n minus two
and so on. And n plus one factorial means
n plus one, times n times n minus one, and
so on. So if I divide n factorial by n plus
one factorial, all my factors from the numerator
will cancel with factors from the denominator.
And I'll just be left with one over n plus
one. Also, negative 10 to the n plus one over
negative 10 to the n cancels out to just negative
10 to the One Power, so I can rewrite my limit
as N plus one squared over n squared times
negative 10 times one over n plus one, I'm
going to divide my limit of a product into
a product of limits. Now as n goes to infinity,
n plus one over n goes to one. So this expression,
which is equivalent to the square of n plus
one over N, also goes to one. The limit of
the absolute value of negative 10 is just
10. And the limit as n goes to infinity of
one over n plus one is zero. Therefore our
limit is one times 10 times zero, which is
zero. And since zero is less than one by the
ratio test, we know that our series converges
absolutely. This video was about the ratio
test, which focuses on the limit as n goes
to infinity of the absolute value of the ratio
of consecutive terms. Depending on whether
this limit is less than one greater than one,
or equal to one, we can determine whether
the series converges or diverges. Or if we
need to try another test. In this video, I
prove the ratio test for convergence and divergence
of series.
The ratio test says that for a series, if
the limit of the absolute value of the ratio
of consecutive terms is equal to a number
L, that's less than one, then the series is
absolutely convergent, and therefore convergent.
If however, the limit of the absolute value
of the ratio of consecutive terms is a number
L, that's bigger than one, or is equal to
infinity, then the series is divergent. Although
I didn't write it here, if the limit is equal
to one exactly, or if the limit doesn't exist,
then the ratio test is inconclusive and can't
be used to establish convergence or divergence.
To prove that the ratio test works, let's
first assume that the limit is less than one.
This means that if I graph n on the x axis,
and my absolute value of the ratio of consecutive
terms, on my Y axis, I get a bunch of dots
that settle at a value of L. and this number
L is less than one. Let's pick a tiny number
epsilon, so that when I add epsilon to L,
I'm still less than one.
So
pick epsilon greater than zero, such that
l plus epsilon is less than one. By the definition
of limit, if I go far enough to the right
on the x axis, all of my red dots are going
to be trapped in between this epsilon interval
around L. In mathematical symbols, this means
there exists a number capital N, such that
the absolute value of ratios, the thing that's
a limiting to L is between L plus epsilon.
And minus epsilon, for all little n bigger
than or equal to
capital that
I'm going to multiply all three sides of this
inequality by the absolute value of a sub
little m, I'm going to focus on the right
end of the inequality, because ultimately,
I want to prove that my series is absolutely
convergent. So it's going to be more useful
to show that my terms are smaller than things
than to show that my terms are bigger than
things. This inequality is true for all values
of little n that are bigger than or equal
to capital N. So in particular, it's true
when little n equals capital N. The inequalities
also true when little n is equal to capital
N plus one. Here, I've just plugged in capital
N plus one for a little n here. And when I
plug it in here, I end up with capital N plus
one plus one, which is capital N plus two.
Now if I string these two inequalities together,
essentially, I'm substituting in this inequality,
right here, I get the following inequality,
which simplifies to give me the absolute value
of a sub capital N plus two is less than l
plus epsilon squared times the absolute value
of a sub capital N. Let's try this one more
time. Going back to my original inequality
here, I'm going to plug in capital N plus
two for lowercase n. And stringing these two
inequalities together, I get that this is
less than l plus epsilon cube times the absolute
value of a piece of capital N. And in general,
the same reasoning shows that the absolute
value of a sub capital N plus i is less than
l plus epsilon to the i times the asset value
of a sub capital N. For any I. With all these
inequalities, I'm gradually building up to
series. The first series is the series, the
sum of the absolute value of a sub capital
N plus i. Let's start that from i equals one
to infinity. And the second series is the
sum of L plus epsilon to the i times the absolute
value of a so capital that again, let's start
from equals one to infinity. Now the second
series is a geometric series, where r is equal
to L plus epsilon, which is less than one,
because remember, we chose epsilon to make
sure that was
less than one.
Therefore, this series converges. But that's
great news. Because now looking at this inequality,
we can show that series one converges, just
using the ordinary comparison test, and recognizing
that these terms are bigger than or equal
to zero. So series one converges by the comparison
test. But series one is just the tail end
of the series, the sum from n equals one to
infinity absolute value of a sub little n.
So this series converges, because it's just
finally many terms added on to a convergent
series. And so we've shown that our original
series converges absolutely. This proves the
first part of the ratio test. Now let's prove
the second part. And let's start by assuming
that the limit is greater than one. This time,
since l is bigger than one, we can pick a
tiny number epsilon, so that when we go down
from L by epsilon, we don't go as far as the
number one. So we're going to pick an epsilon
greater than zero, such that l minus epsilon
is still greater than one. As before, we can
use the definition of limit and a little algebra
to get the same inequality as we got before.
This time, I'm going to focus on the left
side of the inequality though. Since l minus
epsilon is greater than one. This tells me
in particular, that the absolute value of
a sub n plus one is always bigger than the
absolute value of as little n for little n
bigger than or equal to capital N. This means
that the absolute value of Ace of capital
n is less than the absolute value of a sub
capital N plus one, which is less than the
absolute value of capital A sub capital N
plus two, and so on. And so my sequence of
terms is actually ultimately an increasing
sequence of positive numbers. So my sequence
of terms cannot converge to zero, limit as
little n goes to infinity as the value of
a sub little n cannot be zero. And so the
limit as little n goes to infinity of a sub
little n cannot be zero either. But that means
that my original series cannot converge, it
has to diverged by the divergence test, we
still have one detail that consider the possibility
that the limit of the absolute value of ratios
is infinity. In this case, the argument that
we just used, works almost exactly the same.
If we assume that the limit is infinity, then
we can skip this part here.
And here, and just note that there exists
some capital n such that the ratios are always
bigger than say to for all little n bigger
than or equal to capital N. Since if the ratios
are heading towards infinity, they're certainly
going to be bigger than two, eventually. This
gives us the same inequality that we need,
I just read a two there. And now as before,
we can conclude that a sub n plus one is absolute
value is strictly greater than a sub n is
absolute value. In fact, it's greater than
twice of it for all little n bigger than equal
to capital N. And we can make the same conclusion
about an increasing sequence of positive terms.
That so that the terms can't go to zero, and
the series has to diverge by the divergence
test. This concludes the proof of the ratio
test. In this video, we prove the convergent
part of the ratio test by comparing our series
to a convergent geometric series, and we prove
the divergent part of the ratio test using
the divergence test. This video is a review
of all the convergence tests we've talked
about in class. I'll list the test roughly
in the order that I would try to apply them.
I like to start with the divergence test.
Usually it's pretty easy to check if the limit
as n goes to infinity of the terms is equal
to zero. And if not, you're done because the
series diverges. Be careful though. The divergence
test can only be used to check for divergence,
it cannot be used to prove convergence, because
if the limits of the terms is equal to zero,
the series may converge, but it may still
diverge. The next thing I do is to check if
the series is a simple p series, or a geometric
series. Remember, a p series is a series of
the form one over n to the p n is our indexing
variable P is some number like two or 5.8.
And this is easy to test for convergence since
it converges. If p is greater than one and
it diverges, otherwise, a geometric series
this is the kind of the form a times r to
the n, where A is the first term, and they
start at zero here. So it's the really the
first term and r is the common ratio. And
this one's easy to check to because it converges
if the absolute value of r is less than one
and diverges otherwise. If the series happens
to be alternating, than the alternating test
is a good one to apply next. Be careful, this
test can only be used to prove convergence.
If the series is actually alternating. And
this what I call this step size, that's the
absolute value of the terms is going to zero
and decreasing, then we can conclude that
the series converges. But if some of those
conditions are not satisfied, we can't automatically
assume that the series diverges. Well, not
at least by the alternating test, if the step
size doesn't go to zero, then we should have
already figured out the series diverges by
the divergence test were really, really applying
the divergence test there. And if the step
size is not decreasing, not even ultimately
decreasing, then the alternating test is just
inconclusive. It doesn't apply, we don't know
yet, whether it diverges or converges, and
we have to look for another test. Now if the
series is not one of these nice p series geometric
or alternating series, my go to test is going
to be the ratio test. The ratio test is especially
good for series with n factorials in them
or
two to the ends and things with sort of geometric
pieces that are not strictly geometric are
good candidates for the ratio test. But be
careful, the ratio test will be inconclusive
for like all p like series, so series that
just have you know things like ends and, and
maybe the square roots of ends and things
that can be easily compared to a p series
are not good candidates for the ratio test.
So if you happen to remember that you can
save some time by not trying the ratio test
on those. If the ratio test is not a good
candidate or ends up being inconclusive, what
I might try next is one of the comparison
tests.
So that would be like what I call the ordinary
or the limit comparison test. We generally
want to compare two series that we know a
lot about that we know the convergence status
of so we would generally want to compare to
either p series or geometric series. The comparison
tests are especially good for p like series
that the ratio test is inconclusive for. And
to figure out what to compare to it's a good
rule of thumb to consider the dominant or
highest power terms. One thing you need to
be aware of when applying the comparison test
is that it only applies to series with positive
terms. Of course, the first few terms never
matter for series convergence. So it's okay
to apply it if you have eventually positive
terms. But if the terms never become always
positive, and they're not strictly alternating,
so the alternating test doesn't apply. We
don't have to give up hope we can use the
fact that absolute convergence implies convergence.
That's what I try and sort of mine since my
seventh test to try. So you can just take
the absolute values of your terms and then
maybe use the comparison test. And if that
works to prove convergence, then your original
series will converge also. Another method
I haven't mentioned before is to use limit
laws to split up the series. So if you have
the sum of two series, say a p series and
a geometric series, then a natural thing to
do is to split this up as the sum of two series
and use a different method for each piece.
If both pieces converge, like they do in this
situation, then the psalm also converges.
Also, if one piece happens to converge on
the other diverges, then the sun will diverged.
The only thing to be careful of is that if
both pieces diverged, then the psalm may still
diverged. But it may converge because there
might be cancellation, one piece might be
diverted into infinity and one piece may be
diverging to negative infinity. And that's
an indeterminate kind of form. If none of
this stuff has worked so far, I might look
to try the integral test and compare my series
to an integral. This is especially handy in
my experience four series with logs in them.
So something and also it has to be a series
where the integral of easy compute so you
know, something like ln n over n, if you instead
look at the integral of ln x over x, that's
pretty easy to compute using use substitution.
And so that would be a good candidate for
the integral test. Be aware that the integral
test can only be used when the series terms
can be thought of as the functions values
at integers for a function that is positive,
continuous, and decreasing. Last on my list
is the method of telescoping series. I put
it last only because it's kind of a hassle
to work with telescoping series, but it does
have some good points. First of all, using
the method of telescoping series, you can
actually compute the sum rather than just
tell if it converges or diverges. The only
other tool on this list that will actually
compute the sum of an infinite series is the
geometric series test where we have a formula
for the sum provided it converges. Another
reason to use the telescoping series is if
you happen to notice that your terms are the
difference of related expressions. So something
like the sum of e to the one over n plus one
minus e to the one over N might be a good
candidate for telescoping series. Something
like the sum of one over n squared minus one
would also be a reasonable candidate, because
you can rewrite it using the method of partial
fractions. And using that method well, and
the telescoping series stuff will help you
find an actual song. But if you just want
to know convergence, it'll be a lot easier
just to use comparison to a p series whenever
n squared for this one. So that's pretty much
everything I know about convergence tests
for series. If you want to keep watching,
I'll take a look at some examples on the next
page. Before you keep watching, please take
a moment to look at these six examples and
decide which convergence or divergence test
you might try.
Please be
aware that for many of these series, there
are lots of tests that will work. So just
because you pick a different one than I do
doesn't mean that yours is wrong. I think
this first example can be conquered using
the divergence test. My hunch is if we took
that limit and use lopi talls rule, we get
a limit of infinity not zero. An alternative
though would be to use the ratio test. Because
this is
a
term that is has a geometric piece as well
as some other stuff. The second example is
an alternating series. So my first try is
going to be the alternating series test. And
my recollection is it does work to prove convergence
in this case. For this third one, this is
the kind that I call a p like series, because
if I just look at the the dominant terms,
the highest power terms, I could compare to
the P series, which is one over and squared
cubed rooted or in other words, one over n
to the two thirds power. Since this one diverges,
I'm gonna expect my original one also diverged,
I probably need to use the limit comparison
test because I don't think the inequalities
will go the right direction for the ordinary
comparison test. This next one's a perfect
candidate for splitting up into two pieces.
This one, the second piece, I could use the
geometric series test to show convergence.
And this first one says it has an n factorial
that's a great candidate for the ratio test.
This next one's kind of tricky for me. At
first glance, I almost thought it would be
a candidate for the integral test. If this
had just been an N instead of an n squared,
I might be able to integrate using use substitution.
But because it's an n squared, the integral
test would be more tricky to do or I might
have to do integration by parts or something.
So I'm gonna stay away from that. And I'm
going to start by trying the ratio test because
this does have a geometric kind of like piece
to it. And this last example, I'm going to
use the integral test here because I know
like To integrate one over x ln x dx, using
the use substitution u equals ln x, apply
and converge, the divergence test is something
that takes practice, the more you do it, the
better you'll be at recognizing which tests
might apply. But a lot of times, there's no
substitute for just trying the test. And if
it doesn't work, it's where it's inconclusive.
Just try something else. Good luck, and see
you in class. This video introduces some of
the ideas and key formulas of Taylor series.
One of the main ideas behind Taylor series,
the idea of approximating functions with polynomials.
So suppose we have some function f of x, we
want to approximate this function with a polynomial,
and we'd like the approximation to be good
near x equals zero. And we're going to assume
that f prime of zero exists, and f double
prime of zero exists, and F third derivative
exists at zero, all of its derivatives, we're
gonna assume exists at x equals zero. Now,
if we just want to get F value, right at zero,
we can approximate F with the constant function,
y equals f of zero, we can think of this constant
function as being a degrees zero polynomial
approximation. But it's a pretty lousy approximation,
we can do much better than that, in fact,
we can do a lot better even if we just use
a degree one polynomial, that's a linear function.
As you know, the tangent line at x equals
zero is a linear function that provides a
pretty good approximation for the actual function
when x is near zero least that's the best
approximation you can hope for out of a linear
function. The equation for the tangent line
is given by y equals f of zero, plus f prime
of zero times x. This comes straight from
the point slope form for a line where m is
the slope of the tangent line, that's the
derivative at zero, and the point x one y
one is just the point zero, f of zero. So
we get y minus f of zero is f prime of zero
times x minus zero, which simplifies to that
equation for the tangent line right there.
Notice that the tangent line has the same
value as f of x at x equals zero, and it has
the same slope as f of x at x equals zero.
But I'd like to do a little better than this,
I'd like to approximate my function f of x
with a polynomial that has the same value,
the same slope or first derivative, and the
same second derivative as f of x at x equals
zero. It turns out, I can do this with a degree
two polynomial. And I'll show you how, in
general, a degree two polynomial, also called
a quadratic is a polynomial of the form P
of x equals c sub zero, plus c sub one times
x, plus c sub two times x squared. And I just
have to figure out what values of the constants
C sub zero, c sub one, c sub two, will make
my polynomial, agree with my function in its
value, first derivative and second derivative.
Well, if I want P of zero to equal f of zero,
and that means I want c sub zero plus c sub
one times zero plus c sub two times zero squared
to equal s value at zero. In other words,
c sub zero had better be equal to f of zero.
But now I also want p prime of zero to equal
f prime of zero. P prime of x is equal to
c sub one plus two times c sub 2x. I'm just
using my derivative rules on the equation
for p remembering that my C's are constants.
Therefore, to evaluate p prime of zero, I
just plug in zero for x, and I get c sub one,
but this needs to equal f prime of zero, and
therefore c sub one is equal to f prime of
zero. Finally, I want p double prime of zero
to equal f double prime at
zero, I can
find p double prime of x by taking the derivative
of my derivative, so that gives me two times
C two, but that needs to equal f double prime
of zero means that C two had better equal
f double prime of zero divided by two. So
now let's look what happened, requiring that
P has the same value as zero as f forces c
sub zero to have the value of f of zero, requiring
that the polynomial and F had the same first
derivative zero, forces the value of CS of
one, two equal f prime of zero, and requiring
that the polynomial and the function have
the same second derivative at zero forces
the value of c two to be f double prime of
zero divided by two. So we've shown that there
is a secondary polynomial that has the same
value first derivative, the second derivative
as F at X equals zero, and there's a unique
such polynomial, and it's given by p of x
equals f of zero,
plus f prime of zero times x, plus f double
prime of zero over two times x squared.
Visually, that second degree polynomials going
to look like a parabola, it might look something
like this. Let's play this game again. But
this time, I want to find a degree three polynomial
p of x, such that P of zero is the same as
f of zero, p prime of zero is the same thing
as f prime of zero, p double prime of zero
is equal to f double prime of zero, and peas,
third derivative at zero is the same as F,
third derivative at zero.
Graphically, that's going to be a cubic polynomial
that approximates my function, and it's going
to be a pretty close approximation. We know
that a three three polynomial in general has
the form c sub zero plus c sub 1x, plus c
sub 2x squared plus c sub 3x cubed. And we
need to find the values of all the constant
C's. Please pause the video and see if you
can figure out the values of those constants,
especially the value of c sub three in terms
of the value of f and its derivatives at zero.
If we write down the derivatives of P, we
get the following expressions. And if we evaluate
these expressions at x equals zero, all the
terms with x's in them vanish. So we get these
expressions. Now, because we want our polynomials
value, and its derivatives to match the value
and derivatives of our function, we get these
equations from which we can solve for our
constants, c sub zero is f of zero, c sub
one is f prime of zero, c sub two is f double
prime of zero over two, and c sub three is
the third derivative of f at zero divided
by six. Notice that that number six came from
multiplying three times two, and that three
and that two came from bringing down my success
of exponents, when I took derivatives, we
can keep track of this process by rewriting
c sub three is the third derivative of f of
zero divided by three times two or three factorial.
So the third degree polynomial that approximates
our function is p of x, which is f of zero,
plus f prime of zero times x plus f double
prime of zero over two times x squared, plus
f third derivative at zero over three factorial
times x cubed. I'll write this as P sub three
to remember it's the third degree polynomial.
We can repeat this process to get a fourth
degree polynomial whose value add zero is
the same as f of zero, and whose first four
derivatives at zero are the same as f first
for derivatives at zero. Please pause the
video and either work out expressions for
the coefficients of peace and four, or else
make an educated guess what those coefficients
should be based on the patterns you say. You
should get the fourth degree polynomial has
the same first terms as a third degree polynomial
and has a final term of f, fourth derivative
at zero over four factorial times x to the
fourth. If we continue this process forever
Finding polynomials of higher and higher degree
that match more and more derivatives of f.
Then in the limit, we'll have infinitely many
terms that look like this. This is an infinite
series, and it can be written in summation
notation as the sum from n equals zero to
infinity of the nth derivative of f at zero,
divided by n factorial times x to the nth
power. This works as long as we use the conventions,
that the zeroeth derivative means just the
function that zero factorial is equal to one,
and that x to the zero is just equal to one,
even if x is zero. This infinite series is
called the Maclaurin series for f of x. And
it's also called the Taylor series for f of
x centered at x equals zero. Now, so far,
we've been focusing on the value of f and
its derivatives at x equals zero. What if
we wanted to approximate f of x near x equals
a, please pause the video and write down what
you think the Taylor series centered at x
equals A should look like. This is a series
I'll call it T of x, that we want to match
F's value
at A.
and we want all of its derivatives to match
f derivatives at a, it makes sense that this
series should have a formula similar to the
formula we just found. But it should involve
derivatives at a instead of derivatives at
zero. In addition, the formula needs to involve
powers of x minus a, instead of powers of
x. I'll leave you to think about the details.
And to verify that this series really does
have the derivatives that we wanted to have.
In this video, we tried to approximate a function
by polynomials that had the same value and
derivatives at x equals zero. And we ended
up with a formula for a Taylor series at x
equals zero, which we generalized to a Taylor
series centered at x equals a. This video
defines power series. informally, a power
series is a series with a variable in it,
often the letter X, and it looks like a polynomial
with infinitely many terms. For example, if
we look at the series, the sum from n equals
zero to infinity of two n plus one times x
to the n over three to the n minus one, that's
a power series with variable x. If we expand
that out by plugging in values of n, we get
one n equals 01 times x to the zero over three
to the minus 1x to the zero is one and three
to the minus one on the denominator is the
same as three on the numerator. So we can
rewrite this term as just three. The next
term, when n equals one, is three times x
to the one over three to the zero, we can
rewrite this as 3x, since three to the zero
is one. The next term is 5x squared over three,
and we can continue like this. I want to point
out that when working with power series, x
to the zero is always taken to be one, even
though there's a possibility that x could
end up being zero, and zero to the zero is
considered undefined in other contexts. When
working with power series, x to the zero for
any value of x is one. The next series expands
out to one plus five times x minus six, and
so on. This is an example of a power series
centered at six because of all the factors
of x minus six. In general, a power series
centered at a is a series of the form the
sum from n equals zero to infinity of c sub
n times x minus a to the n, where x is the
variable. The cease events are real numbers,
they're constants, called the coefficients,
and a is also a real number a constant that's
called the center. If I expand out the power
series and read out the first few terms that
looks like this, where c sub zero is the constant
term, notice that x minus A to the zero is
taken to be one, even when x equals a. If
the power series is centered at zero, then
we just set a equal to zero, we can write
this a little more efficiently in the following
form. Sometimes you might see a power series
that starts with index of one instead of zero.
That's perfectly legit. It just means there's
no constant term. Or if you prefer, you can
think of the constant term as being zero.
It's also fun for the index to start at some
other positive number.
But it's not considered a power series if
the index starts at a negative number, resulting
in x's in the denominator. That's all for
the definition of power series. Recall that
a power series is a series with a variable
in it. In this example, the C sub n and the
A are supposed to be real numbers that are
held constant, so the only variable is x.
That's the only place where I can plug in
different values at different times. This
video explores the question of for what values
of the variable x does the power series converge,
and for what values of x does it diverged.
Let's look at a few examples. First, for what
values of x does this power series converge.
There's one value of x that I know for sure
it converges for, please pause the video for
a moment and try to guess which value of x
I'm thinking of the series definitely converges
when x equals three. If I expand out the first
few terms of the series, I get this expression.
then plugging in three 4x, all of my terms
vanish to zero, except for my constant term
of one. So at x equals three, the series converges
to its constant turn. And in fact, this is
true of any power series all power series
converge at their center. But let's see what
other values of exit converges for. Although
we have many tests for convergence in our
toolkit, the ratio test is usually the best
test to use to determine where of power series
converges. For the ratio test, we need to
take the limit as n goes to infinity of the
absolute value of the ratio of consecutive
terms. For our example, this is n plus one
factorial times x minus three to the n plus
one divided by n factorial times x minus three
to the N. Let's simplify by canceling things.
We get n plus one, times x minus three. Now
x minus three is some number. And I'll assume
it's a nonzero number, since I already dealt
with the case when x equals three, so I have
a nonzero number that stays fixed as n goes
to infinity times a number that's going to
infinity. So the absolute value of the product
has to go to infinity, no matter what x value
we have, other than the x value of three.
The ratio test says that if this limit is
infinity, the series diverges. Therefore,
the power series diverges for all values of
x except for three. The only place where it
converges is at the center of three. In this
next example, the center of this series is
negative four. So the series definitely converges
when x equals negative four. Let's use the
ratio test to figure out what other values
of x make it converge. So we'll take the limit
as n goes to infinity of the absolute value
of a sub n plus one over a sub n. This works
out to the limit the absolute value of negative
two to the n plus one times x plus four to
the n plus one divided by n plus one factorial,
all over negative two to the n x plus four
to the n over n factorial. Let's simplify
by flipping and multiplying and rearranging
a little. After canceling, we get the limit
of the opposite value of negative two times
x plus four divided by n plus one. The numerator
of this expression doesn't depend on an n,
so it stays fixed as n goes to infinity, but
the denominator goes to infinity. Therefore,
we're dividing some fixed constant by larger
and larger numbers, and so this limit is equal
to zero. Once again, the limit doesn't depend
on x as value It's always zero no matter what
axis. So by the ratio test zero is less than
one, the series converges for all values of
x.
Here's our third and last example, in this
example, it's a little trickier to figure
out what the center is, one thing we can do
is to rewrite the series in a more standard
form by factoring out the negative five, then
we get negative five times x minus two fifths,
all raised to the nth power over N, I can
rewrite this again as negative five to the
n times x minus two fifths to the n over n.
And in this more standard form, it's easy
to recognize that the center is two fifths.
Another way to find the center is just to
figure out the value of x, that makes terms
go to zero. So in our case, if we want negative
5x plus two, two equals zero, we need X to
equal two fifths. And therefore, two fifths
must be the center, like we found before.
In any case, our series converges for x equals
two fifths, for sure, but it might converge
for other values of x. So let's use the ratio
test. To find other values of x that make
the series converge. We start off the same
way as usual, by taking a limit of a ratio
of the n plus one than n terms. And then we
simplify by flipping and multiplying. And
after canceling, we get the limit of negative
5x plus two times n over n plus one as n goes
to infinity, and over n plus one goes to one.
And negative 5x plus two doesn't depend on
n. So this final limit is just the absolute
value of negative 5x plus two. So by the ratio
test, our series converges when this limit
is less than one, and it diverges when the
limit is greater than one, the ratio test
is inconclusive when the absolute value of
negative 5x plus two is exactly equal to one,
so we'll worry about that case later. Let's
solve the first absolute value inequality.
When the absolute value of something is less
than one, that means that the quantity inside
the absolute value sign has to be between
one and negative one. So we can rewrite the
absolute value inequality as negative one
is less than negative 5x plus two, which is
less than one, we can solve this for x by
subtracting two and dividing by negative five.
dividing by a negative number reverses the
direction of the inequality signs. So we have
that our series converges for these values
of x. Now let's solve the second absolute
value and equality. The one that tells us
where the power series diverges, the series
diverges when the absolute value of negative
5x plus two is greater than one. When the
absolute value of something is greater than
one, that means that whatever is inside the
absolute value sign has to either be less
than negative one or greater than one. So
we can replace our absolute value in equality
with two inequalities. Negative 5x plus two
is less than negative one, or negative 5x
plus two is greater than one. Let's solve
these inequalities by subtracting two and
dividing by negative five. And similarly on
the other side. So our series diverges when
x is greater than three fifths or less than
1/5. That makes sense, it's kind of the opposite
of where it converges because we're solving
an absolute value inequality with the opposite
inequality side. Putting all this information
together, we see that our series converges
when x is between 1/5 and three fifths and
divert On either side of this interval,
we still don't know what happens when x is
exactly equal to 1/5, or exactly equal to
three fifths, since those values correspond
to the case when the ratio test is inconclusive.
So let's turn our attention to the x values
of 1/5 and three fifths Next, let me write
down our original power series, it was the
sum from n equals one to infinity of negative
5x plus two to the n
over n.
If we want to know if this power series converges
at x equals 1/5, let's just plug in x equals
1/5. This simplifies to the sum of one to
the n over n, which is just the regular harmonic
series, which diverges. If we plug in x equals
three fifths, we get this series, which simplifies
to the alternating harmonic series. So it
converges. So now we know that the series
converges when x equals three fifths and diverges
when x equals 1/5. And our final answer is
that the power series converges on the interval
from 1/5 to three fifths, where we use an
open bracket, to denote that we exclude the
endpoint 1/5, because the series diverges
there, and the closed bracket, square bracket
means that we include the endpoint of three
fifths where the series does converge. I want
to make one more observation. Before we leave
this example. Notice that the midpoint of
this interval is the number 2/5. Remember,
at the beginning of the problem, we calculated
the center of the power series, and it was
also two fifths. We'll see in a moment that
this is no coincidence. In fact, the interval
of convergence is always centered at the center
of the power series. And we could in fact,
describe the interior of this interval of
convergence as the x values for which x minus
that center is less than 1/5. Bet is all x
values within a distance of 1/5. From the
interval center. We've seen three examples
of power series, and each one converge in
a very different way. In general, it turns
out that there are only these three different
types of convergence that we've already seen.
It's possible, like we saw on the first example,
that a series might converge only at its center.
It's also possible that a power series could
converge for all values of x. This is what
happened in our second example. But if neither
of these two cases hold, then the only other
possibility is that there exists a number
R, such that R is series converges anytime,
where within our units from the center a and
the power series diverges for any x values
that are more than our units from the center
array. In symbols, I can right there exists
a number are such that the power series converges
when the absolute value of x minus a is less
than R, and diverges when the absolute value
of x minus a is greater than R, since the
absolute value of x minus a represents the
distance between x and a. This was a situation
we saw in our third example. Now in the first
case, we say that the radius of convergence
of the power series is zero. In the second
example, we say the radius of convergence
is infinity. And in the third example, we
say the radius of convergence is our since
our represents the distance from the center
of the interval, sort of like the radius of
a circle represents the circles distance from
the center. Now the interval of convergence
is the interval of all x values for which
the power series converges. So in our first
situation, the interval of convergence is
just the number a it's not really an interval,
just a single number, but we call it the interval
of convergence anyway, in the second situation,
our interval of convergence is the interval
from now negative infinity to infinity. And
then the third situation, the interval of
convergence includes this entire interval
here that extends from the number A minus
r to the number A plus R.
So our interval could be the open interval,
a minus r to a plus R. But it could also include
one or more endpoints, so it could be the
closed interval, or it could just include
the left endpoint, or just the right endpoint.
In this video, I worked out some examples
using the ratio test to figure out what x
values make a power series converge. I also
stated the fact that there are only three
options for convergence of a power series,
convergence at the center only convergence
for all real numbers and convergence on some
finite interval centered at the center of
the power series. This video gives an example
of computing the interval of convergence and
the radius of convergence for a power series.
To compute the radius of convergence and interval
of convergence for this power series, we start
by using the ratio test. So we need to find
the limit as n goes to infinity of the absolute
value of a sub n plus one over a sub n, where
the a sub ns are the terms for this power
series, we can compute a sub n plus one, by
just plugging in n plus one everywhere we
see an N in this expression. So that's negative
four to the n plus one, times x minus eight
to the two times quantity and plus one divided
by n plus one. We divide all that by the A
sub N term, which is just negative four to
the n x minus eight to the to n over n, which
I've just copied from the formula here. Now
I'm going to simplify, flip and multiply.
And now I'm going to rearrange terms so that
corresponding terms are on top of each other.
So I'm going to write negative four to the
n plus one over negative four to the n times
x minus eight
to the
to quantity n plus one, that's the same thing
as two n plus two, over x minus eight to the
two n. And then I'll write the N and N plus
one. So that's n over n plus one. Once I cancel
terms, I get the limit of negative four times
x minus eight squared times n over n plus
one. Now, as n goes to infinity, n over n
plus one is going to one, and the absolute
value of negative four is just four. And the
absolute value of x minus eight squared is
just going to be x minus eight squared, since
this expression is always positive, so we
have our limit. And the ratio test says the
series will converge where this limit is less
than one. So next, let's set four times x
minus eight squared to be less than one and
solve for x. In other words, x minus a squared
is less than 1/4. Now we can't solve this
quadratic inequality by taking the square
root of both sides, that would lead to something
like x minus eight is less than plus or minus
the square root of 1/4, which doesn't even
make any sense. And it's not true. What we
can do instead is solve the quadratic equation,
x minus eight squared is equal to 1/4. And
then use some logic to figure out the inequality.
So now that we have an equation sign, we can
take the square root of both sides to get
x minus eight is is equal to plus or minus
the square root of 1/4. In other words, x
minus eight is plus or minus one half. So
in other words, x is equal to eight plus one
half, or eight minus one half. That's either
17 halves, or 15 halves. Now let's go back
to the inequality that we're interested in.
Since we know that x minus eight squared is
equal to 1/4. At x values of 15 halves and
17 halves, we can test to see whether x minus
eight squared is bigger or smaller than 1/4.
by plugging in values in between these numbers,
so when x is less than 15, half just by plugging
in a sample value like zero, we can see that
x minus eight squared will be bigger than
1/4. Well, when x is between 15 halves and
17 halves, say the value of eight, the plug
in eight and 4x, and see that eight minus
eight squared, which is zero, is going to
be less than 1/4. And finally, plugging in
a value of x over here, maybe something like
10 for x, we're going to get a value of x
minus eight squared, that is, again, bigger
than 1/4. So putting this together, we can
see that x minus eight squared is less than
1/4. When x is between 15 halves, and 17 halves.
So by the ratio test, our series converges.
For x between 15 halves, and 17 halves the
ratio test also tells us the series diverges.
When this expression is greater than one in
order other words, x minus eight squared is
greater than 1/4. In other words, for x values
less than 15 halves are greater than 17 halves.
Now the only thing we still need to figure
out is what happens at the endpoints of the
interval 15 halves to 17 half's recall that
our series was given by this formula. So when
x is equal to 15 halves, we have negative
four to the n 15 halves minus eight to the
to n over n, which is equal to negative four
to the n, negative one half to the two n over
n, which I can rewrite as negative one to
the n times four to the n times negative one
to the two N over two to the to n divided
by n, which is the same thing as negative
one to the n four to the n, negative one to
the two n divided by n times two squared to
the N. Since two n is always even negative
one to the two, n is always equal to one.
And since two squared is four, this four to
the n on the denominator cancels with the
four to the n on the numerator. So I'm left
with the alternating harmonic series, which
we know converges. So the series converges
for x equal to 15 halves. Now at x equals
17 halves, we can go through the same computation,
just using 17 halves in place of 15 halves,
that changes the negative one half here to
a positive one half. And now we have a positive
one to the two n, which is still always one,
everything else works the same. And so we
still have a conversion series. So going back
up to the top, we know that the series actually
converges for x greater than or equal to 15
halves and less than or equal to 17 halves.
That is our interval of convergence. closed
bracket 50 and a half to 17 halves close bracket.
That is that the interval of convergence has
length one, because 17 halves minus 15 halves,
the difference of the two endpoints is two
halves, which is one also, the interval of
convergence has center of eight because the
average of the endpoints 17 halves plus 15
halves
over two
is equal to eight. This should come as no
surprise, because our original series was
centered at eight. So if we draw our interval
of convergence on the number line, it's centered
at eight, and extends out a total distance
of one unit. In other words, it extends out
by half a unit on either side. And so the
radius of convergence is the length of the
interval divided by two, or one half. So we
found the radius of convergence. And we found
the interval of convergence, which was this
closed interval here. And so that completes
the problem. In this video, I'll prove some
of the key facts about convergence of power
series. My ultimate goal is to prove that
there are only three possible options for
convergence, a power series could converge
only at its center, it could converge for
all real numbers. And if these two options
don't hold, then there must exist a number
are
such that the power series converges for all
x, within our units away from the center a
and the power series diverges.
for all x,
his distance from a is greater than our first
I'll prove some preliminary facts. I'll start
with this one. If a power series converges
when x is equal to b, for some nonzero number
B, then it also converges for any x whose
absolute value is less than the absolute value
of b. To prove this fact, let's assume that
the power series converges when x is equal
to b, that is, the sum of c sub n times beats
to the n converges.
If a series converges, then the limit of its
terms has to equal zero. Since if the limit
of the terms is not equal to zero, the series
would have to diverged by the divergence test.
Therefore, by the definition of limit, for
any epsilon, there exists a number capital
N, such that c sub n times b to the n is between
zero plus epsilon, and zero minus epsilon
for little n bigger than or equal to capital
N. In particular, if we pick epsilon equal
to one, this says there exists a capital n
such that negative one is less than c sub
n times b to the n is less than one for little
n bigger than or equal to capital N, I can
rewrite this statement as the absolute value
of c sub n times b to the n is less than one
for little n bigger than or equal to capital
N. Now, if x is any number, with absolute
value less than the absolute value of b, we
can write the absolute value of c sub n times
x to the n as the absolute value of c sub
n times b to the n times x over a b to the
n, just using algebra, I can rewrite this
as c sub as the value of c sub n times b to
the n times the absolute value of x over b
to the n.
For little n bigger than or equal to capital
N, we know that the opposite value of c sub
n times b to the n is less than one.
So this expression has to be less than the
absolute value of x over b to the n. Now if
the absolute value of x is less than the absolute
value of b, this means that the absolute value
of x over b is less than one. So the series
The sum of X absolute value of x over b to
the n is a geometric series, whose ratio has
absolute value less than one, so it's a convergent
series. Now, the ordinary comparison test
tells us that the sum of the absolute value
of c sub n, x to the n also converges, because
we know that the terms of that series are
less than the terms of our convergent geometric
series. Therefore, our original series The
sum of c sub n, x to the n converges absolutely,
and therefore converges. So we've proved the
first statement. The second statement says
that if the power series diverges when x is
equal to d for some nonzero number D, then
it also diverges. Whenever we have an x whose
absolute value is greater than the absolute
value of D. The statement follows directly
from the first statement, because suppose
we have the sum of c sub n times d to the
n diverges. If the absolute value of x is
bigger than the absolute value of d, and the
sum of c sub n x to the n converged, then
by part one, the sum of c sub n, d to the
n would have to converge, since the absolute
value of d is less than the absolute value
of x. But this contradicts the assumption
that the sum of c sub n times d to the n diverges.
And therefore, we know that the sum of c sub
n times x to the n must diverged after all.
That's all for the proof of facts about convergence
of series. In this video, we'll talk about
power series as functions. Consider the function
defined by f of x is equal to the sum from
n equals zero to infinity of x to the n. This
can also be written as one plus x plus x squared,
and so on. When we think of this as a function,
the variable x becomes our independent variable,
or input variable. So to figure out the values
of f, we can plug in numbers for x and evaluate.
Please pause the video and calculate F of
1/3. f of 1/3 is equal to one plus a third
plus a third squared, and so on, this is a
geometric series. So it adds up to the first
term one divided by one minus the ratio of
1/3. And that simplifies to three halfs. Next
question, what's the domain of f of x, we
can think of the domain of a function as the
values of the input variable x, that give
us a real number as output? Please pause the
video to write down your answer for the domain
of f of x. The series, the sum of x to the
n converges when x is between negative one
and one. So for these values of x, we get
a finite real number as our answer for f of
x. Also, the series diverges for other values
of x. So we don't get a real number answer
when we plug in values of x less than or equal
to negative one or greater than or equal to
one. Therefore, the domain of f of x is the
set of X values for which negative one is
less than x is less than one, or an interval
notation, we can write this as the interval
from negative one to one.
And in general, the domain of a power series
is exactly the set of values where it converges.
By a closed form expression for f of x, I
mean an expression that doesn't involve a
summation sign,
I can write the sum of X to the N, without
the summation sign by using the geometric
series formula, first term is one divided
by one minus the common ratio of x. This holds
for all x values between negative one and
one as usual, where the geometric series converges.
Therefore, I can write f of x as one over
one minus x for x values in that interval.
Notice that if I just looked at the function,
g of x equals one over one minus x out of
context, it would have domain spanning from
negative infinity to one together with the
interval one to infinity. Because this function
g of x is defined for all x values that are
not equal to one. So f of x and g of x are
not exactly the same function. They have different
domains, but they are exactly equal on the
interval from negative one to one. And we
say that the function g of x is represented
by the power series, the sum from n equals
zero to infinity of x to the n. If we want
to be more precise, we can say it's represented
by this power series 4x between negative one
and one. We can think of the partial sums
of this series sum of x to the n as a way
to approximate the function, one over one
minus x with polynomials. Please pause the
video and write out the first few partial
sums, your answers should have Xs. S sub zero
is just the zeroeth term one, S sub one is
one plus x, and so on. s sub n is one plus
x plus all the way up through x to the n,
an nth degree polynomial. In this figure,
I've drawn the function one over one minus
x in blue. And I've drawn the first partial
sum the linear function one plus x in orange.
Notice that these two functions are close
to each other when x equals zero, but get
farther away from each other when x is far
from zero. In this graph, I've added the next
partial sum s two, which is a degree two polynomial,
a quadratic. Here I've got partial sums through
s four. And here I've got partial sums through
about s 12. The original function one over
one minus x is here in blue on mark over
Ed.
And you can see that these partial sums are
becoming very good approximations to that
original function on the interval from negative
one to one. Now outside that interval, for
example, for x values below negative one,
our partial sums deviate wildly from our original
function. I want to show one more graph. In
this graph, the function one over one minus
x is shown in blue. And the graph of the power
series, the sum of X to the N is shown in
orange,
the blue function is actually obscured by
the orange function because the two functions
are identical for values of x between negative
one and one. The only difference between these
two functions, as discussed before, is that
the function one over one minus x is defined
for all x values except for the x value of
one. And that's why we can see the blue graph
even when x values are less than negative
one. However, the function given by this power
series has domain in between negative one
and one, and so it only exists here in between
those x values. In this video, I talked about
representing the function one over one minus
x with the power series, the sum from n equals
zero to infinity of x to the n. These two
progressions are equal for x values between
negative one where the power series converges.
I also used a graph to give an idea of what
this equation means. The partial sums drawn
in various colors give excellent approximations
to the original function drawn in blue on
the interval of X values between negative
one and one. Since the partial sums are polynomials,
this gives us a way to approximate this rational
function with simple polynomial equations.
The idea of approximating functions with polynomials
is a very important idea that we'll see again
and again. This video is about rewriting functions
in terms of power series. All the examples
that we'll do in this section will be based
on the formula for the geometric series, the
fact that the sum from n equals zero to infinity
of x to the n is equal to one over one minus
x. For x between negative one and one. We
want to express the function two over x minus
three as a power series. And we want to do
this by using the geometric sum formula. The
trick here is going to be to rewrite to over
x minus three, so it looks more like one over
one minus something, then we can treat whatever
that something is as x and plug into the formula
to get a power series. So that's the idea.
Now I'm starting with two over x minus three.
And I don't really like the X minus three,
I'd rather This was three minus
x because that reminds me more of one minus
x. So I could rewrite it like this, but my
two expressions now are equal. This one's
the negative of this one, so I can fix that
by just sticking a negative sign out in front.
Now my two expressions are equal, because
I've just multiplied my first expression by
negative one over negative one. To get this
expression, but I still don't really like
the three minus x, I wish that were one minus
x, it'd be nice if I could just divide the
three by three to get one. But in order to
leave the expression on change, I'm going
to need to divide everything by three, both
the top and the bottom. This gives me negative
two thirds, divided by three minus x over
three, which I can also write as negative
two thirds times one minus x over three. Now
if I bring the negative two thirds out front,
I have negative two thirds times one over
one minus x over three. Using my geometric
sum formula, this is the same as negative
two thirds times the sum from n equals zero
to infinity of x over three to the n, I'm
just plugging in x over three 4x. In this
formula, I've now found a power series representation.
But I'm going to clean it up a little bit
and make it look more standard, bring the
negative two thirds into the summation sign
and distributed my exponent to get x to the
n over three to the N. And now I can rewrite
this as negative two over three to the n plus
one, times x to the n. To figure out the interval
of convergence for this power series, there
are two different approaches that I could
take. First, I could do a standard computation
using the ratio test. I'll let you work out
the details yourself. But you should get that
the radius of convergence is three, and the
interval of convergence is from negative three
to three.
A second approach to finding the interval
of convergence is to look at the history of
how we made the power series.
Our basic template power series was the sum
from n equals zero to infinity of x to the
n, which converges when x is between negative
one and one. We then plugged in x over three
for x. Well, this good should converge when
x over three is between one and negative one.
In other words, when x is between three and
negative three, finally, we multiplied that
series by negative two thirds. This doesn't
change the interval of convergence. So the
interval of convergence for our final power
series is the interval between negative three
and three, just like you could have gotten
from the ratio test. As a second example,
let's find a power series representation of
x over one plus 5x squared. Again, we want
to use the geometric series summation formula.
So we want to make this expression look more
like one over one minus something. Well, one
plus 5x squared is the same thing as one minus
minus 5x squared. So if I just wanted a power
series for one over one plus 5x squared, I
could do that easily by using the geometric
sum formula, and getting the sum from n equals
zero to infinity of minus 5x squared to the
N. All I'm doing here is plugging in negative
5x squared for x in this formula. Since I
want a power series for x over one plus 5x
squared, instead, I can just multiply everything
by x. Again, I'd like to clean things up and
make this expression look more like a standard
power series. So I'll drag the x inside the
summation sign, I can do that because the
summation is over n, which has nothing to
do with x. Now I can use my laws of exponents
to rewrite this as negative one to the n five
to the n times x to the two n. Now, x times
x to the two n is equal to x to the two n
plus one. And so this gives me a good power
series representation for my function. Although
the problem didn't explicitly ask for it,
it's a good idea to compute the interval of
convergence to see for what values of x
this equation actually holds. I'll use the
history approach. We started with our old
familiar power series, which converges when
x is between one and negative one
with plugged in net Get a 5x squared for x.
So that converges when negative one is less
than negative 5x squared is less than one,
which is equivalent to the inequality 1/5
is greater than x squared, which is greater
than negative 1/5. Notice that I had to flip
around the inequality signs when i divided
by negative five. Looking at a graph of y
equals x squared, I can see that x squared
is between negative 1/5 and 1/5. For x values
corresponding to this section of the graph
that I'm drawing here in green, or this interval
of X values on the x axis that I'm drawing
in pink. To find the endpoints of this pink
interval, I just need to find where x squared
is exactly equal to 1/5, which is when x is
equal to plus or minus the square root of
1/5. So the x values that satisfy me and equality
are the x values in between these two values,
I have negative the square root of 1/5 is
less than x is less than the square root of
1/5. Now the last step in my history is when
I multiplied everything by x, this doesn't
change my interval of convergence, which remains
this interval here. In this video, I represented
several functions with power series using
the geometric series summation formula. Although
only a limited class of functions can be handled
using this formula, some of the techniques
that I used in the process, like multiplying
my whole power series by x or plugging in
an expression for x, some of those techniques
can be used in a much broader context to represent
many different kinds of functions as power
series. As we'll see. Up to now, we've only
been able to calculate the sum of a few various
specific series like geometric series and
some telescoping series. In this video, we'll
see how to use Taylor series to find the sums
of other series. Let's start by finding the
Taylor series for arc tan of x centered at
x equals zero. Since arc tan of x is equal
to the integral of one over one plus x squared,
one easy way to find the Taylor series for
arc tan of x is to build it up, starting with
the formula for a geometric series, one over
one minus x is the sum from n equals zero
to infinity of x to the n. Now, one over one
plus x squared is equal to one over one minus
negative x squared. So I can plug negative
x squared in for x in this power series. And
I get the sum from n equals zero to infinity
of negative x squared to the n, which simplifies
to the sum from n equals zero to infinity,
negative one to the n x to the two n. Therefore,
arc tan of x, which is the integral of one
over one plus x squared dx is going to be
equal to the integral of this power series,
at least up to a constant, I can integrate
this power series term by term to get the
sum of negative one to the n, x to the two
n plus one divided by two n plus one plus
a constant. To figure out the constant C,
I can plug zero in for x on both sides of
my equation. Since all of my powers of x involve
a positive power of x, even when n equals
zero, I've got x to the one, so there's always
at least one copy of x there. So if I plug
in x equals zero, all of these terms go to
zero, and arc tan of zero is also zero. So
plugging in x equals zero gives me zero equals
the sum of a bunch of zeros plus C. In other
words, the constant is zero. Therefore, this
expression right here gives me a Taylor series
representation of arc tan. Let's take a moment
to figure out which x values this equation
is actually true for. We know that the geometric
series formula holds for x values between
negative one and one not including the endpoints.
Therefore, when I plug in negative x squared
for x, I get In the equation that holds for
negative x squared between one and negative
one, which is equivalent to saying that x
is between one and negative one.
And when I take the integral of both sides,
I still get an equation that holds true for
x between negative one and one. So I'm guaranteed
that this equation up here holds for x values
between negative one and one. But in fact,
it's not hard to check that this series actually
converges at the endpoints of negative one
and one. This follows from the alternating
series test sets when we plug in x equals
negative one, or x equals one. Either way,
we get an alternating series that converges.
So this series converges on the closed interval
from negative one to one, and it's equal to
arc tan on that open interval. In fact, it
turns out that is equal to our tan
even on the closed interval. In particular,
the equation holds for x equal to one. When
x is equal to one, that I plug into the equation
to get the arc tan of one is equal to the
sum from n equals zero to infinity, negative
one to the n times one to the two n plus one,
that's just one over two n plus one,
I can rewrite that. Now, arc tan of one is
the angle whose tangent is one. So arc tan
of one is going to be pi over four. In other
words, I now have a series that sums to pi
over four, let's write out the first few terms
of this series and see what it looks like.
The first term is one, the next term minus
a third, plus a fifth minus a seventh plus
a ninth, and so on. In other words, multiplying
both sides by four, we get that pi is equal
to four minus four thirds plus four fifths
minus four sevenths, plus four ninths, minus
4/11, and so on, if you've ever wondered how
to generate digits for pi, here's one way
we found the sum of kind of a natural series
to look at. And we found a beautiful formula
for pi.
For the next example, let's start by finding
the Taylor series for f of x equals ln x centered
at x equals one, we can write out the pattern
of the function and its derivatives. And we
soon notice that the nth derivative will have
negative one to the n minus one times n minus
one factorial times x to the n. Since we're
centering at x equals one, we'll plug in one
and get the nth derivative of f at one is
equal to negative one to the n minus one times
n minus one factorial. Therefore, the Taylor
series for ln of x will be the sum from n
equals zero to infinity of f to the n at one
over n factorial, times x minus one to the
n. Since this pattern for the nth derivative
of f really only works, starting with the
first derivative, not with the zeroeth derivative,
I'm going to split out the first term, which
is just going to be ln of one, which is actually
zero. And then all the other terms follow
the same pattern. And we have negative one
to the n minus one, times n minus one factorial
divided by the n factorial times x minus one
to the n. This simplifies to ln of x is equal
to the sum from n equals one to infinity of
negative one to the n minus one times x minus
one to the n over n. Since the n minus one
factorial cancels with almost all the n factorial
leaving just the factor and in the denominator,
so I now have a formula for the Taylor series
for ln of x. It's easy to check using the
ratio test that this power series has a radius
of a convergence of one and so it converges
when x minus one is between one and negative
one. It other words when x is between zero,
and two. And although I won't prove it here,
it turns out that this Taylor series really
does converge to its function ln of x. And
in fact, it converges to ln x on the interval
for x greater than zero and less than or equal
to two. Now, if I plug in x equal to two into
my equation, I get something interesting.
I get that ln of two is equal to the sum from
n equals one to infinity of negative one to
the n minus one of two minus one to the n,
well, that's just one to the n, which is just
one. And so I get ln f two is equal to the
sum of negative one to the n minus one over
n. That should be looking familiar to you.
And yes,
it's true. This is just the alternating harmonic
series, one minus one half, plus 1/3, minus
1/4, and so on. So Taylor series has given
us the sum of the alternating harmonic series,
and it is ln of two. In this video, we use
Taylor series to find the sum of the alternating
harmonic series.
We also used Taylor series for arc tangent,
to find that the sum of a different series
is actually equal to pi. As you get more familiar
with Taylor series, you'll be able to
calculate the sum of other series by recognizing
them as the series that you get by plugging
in a certain value of x into the Taylor series
of a particular function. For example, if
you see the series one, plus one over two,
plus one over three factorial, plus one over
four factorial, and so on, you might recognize
that as the number one plugged into the formula
for the Taylor series of either dx, in other
words, this series is equal to either the
one which is e. for any function f of x, whose
derivatives all exist, we can write down the
Taylor series for f of x centered at x equals
a, by using this formula. But just because
we can write the Taylor series down, doesn't
guarantee that the Taylor series actually
converges to the function we started with.
In this video, we'll address the questions
of When can we be sure that the Taylor series
converges to its function? And when the Taylor
series does converge? How good is the approximation
by taylor polynomials? or partial sums? In
other words, how big is the remainder? The
answer to the question, does the Taylor series
always converge to the function that's made
from is unfortunately, no. Sometimes the radius
of convergence is zero. And sometimes, even
though the radius of convergence is large,
or even infinite, the Taylor series converges,
but it converges to the wrong function. Here's
an example of the second situation. If we
look at this piecewise defined function, g
of x is defined as e to the minus one over
x squared, if x is not zero, and is defined
so that it's continuous at zero to be zero,
when x equals zero, it's possible to work
out the value of g prime is zero, using the
limit definition of derivative, g prime of
zero is the limit as h goes to zero of g of
zero plus h minus g of zero over h, which
is the limit as h goes to zero
of e to the minus one over h squared minus
zero over h. I'll rewrite this as the limit
as h goes to zero of one over h
divided by e to the one over h squared. as
h goes to zero from the positive side, this
is an infinity over infinity indeterminate
form. And as h goes to zero from the negative
side, is a negative infinity over infinity
indeterminate form. In either case, we can
use loopy talls rule to replace this limit
with the limit of the derivatives, which simplifies
to a zero over infinity kind of limit,
which is equal to zero.
In a similar way, it's possible to prove that
the second derivative of g zero is also zero,
and so is the third derivative, and so are
all the derivatives of G at zero. Therefore,
if we write out The Taylor series is just
the sum of a bunch of zeros or the zero function.
Certainly this Taylor series converges for
all x, but it converges to the constant zero
function. And that's different from the function
that we started with. In fact, the function
that we started with g of x is not zero for
any x,
except x equals zero. So the Taylor series
only matches the function at the single point
x equals zero and nowhere else. We found an
example where the Taylor series converges,
but not to its function g of x. Fortunately,
this behavior doesn't happen for most of the
functions that we typically deal with. To
understand better, which Taylor series are
guaranteed to converge to their functions,
let's take a look at the idea of remainders.
For a function f of x as Taylor series T of
x, the remainder is written r sub n of x equals
f of x minus T sub n of x, where T sub n of
x is the nth degree Taylor polynomial. This
can be expanded out as follows. Previously,
when we looked at remainders for series,
we wrote that the remainder was the infinite
sum, which I'll call s infinity, minus the
nth partial sum. The analogous expression
for Taylor series might be the entire Taylor
series, minus the first terms up through the
degree and term. But that's not what we define
the remainder to be for Taylor series. Instead,
the remainder for Taylor series is the difference
between the function and the first terms up
to the degree and term. The reason it's defined
a little bit differently is because for Taylor
series, we're super interested in the Taylor
series converging to its function. And it's
of less interest whether or not the Taylor
series happens to converge to its infinite
sum. Because we define the remainder as the
difference between the function and its Taylor
polynomial, it follows directly that the Taylor
series for f of x converges to f of x and
an interval around a if and only if the limit
of the remainders is zero in this interval,
to see this, just note that the limit as n
goes to infinity of the Taylor series equals
f of x, that's what it means to converge to
f of x. If and only if f of x minus this limit
is equal to zero. We can rewrite this as the
limit as n goes to infinity of f of x minus
the limit as n goes to infinity of T n of
x equals zero. Since the limit as n goes to
infinity of f of x is just f of x, there's
no ends in this expression. Using limit laws,
we can rewrite this again, as the limit of
the quantity f of x minus t and f of x equals
zero. But that's just the same thing as saying
that the limit of the remainders is zero by
definition of remainders. So we restated the
question about when does a Taylor series converge
to its function? As a question about when
does the limit of the remainders
equals zero?
tailors in equality gives us a bound on these
remainders that can help us answer the question
of when the remainders limit to zero. This
bound can also be a useful way to answer the
question of how close is the approximation
when we use taylor polynomials to approximate
a function. Here's some details about when
this bound holds. Suppose there's a number
capital N, such that the n plus one derivative
of X has magnitude less than or equal to capital
N, for all X's within a distance d of the
center a as a graph, this means that there's
a number capital M. And for all X's within
a distance d of the center a, the graph of
the n plus one derivative
of f
lies between negative m and m. So if such
a number M exists, then the remainder r sub
n of x of the Taylor series satisfies the
inequality that the magnitude of r sub n of
x is less than or equal to this bound capital
M divided by n one plus one factorial times
the absolute value of x minus a to the n plus
one to power for all x's in this interval.
of length two D that we're talking about.
Now, in the statement of Taylor's inequality,
the number m can be chosen just to work for
a particular derivative. But really nice things
can happen if we are able to choose the same
number of M to work for all derivatives for
our values of little n. In fact, if all derivatives
are bounded by the same value capital M, then
we can guarantee that the Taylor series converges
to the function. That gives us a nice practical
convergence criterion that I'll show you on
the next slide. The practical convergence
condition says that if there's a number capital
M, such that the magnitude of the nth derivative
at x is less than capital M, for all numbers,
x and a certain interval around the center.
And for all numbers, and then the Taylor series
for f of x converges to f of x 4x is in that
interval. I represent the convergence condition
visually. This time, we're agreeing that all
the derivatives are within this bound. So
the original function lies within this bound,
and its derivative lies within this bound,
and the second derivative lies within this
bound. These are not necessarily accurate
representations of the derivatives. But that's
the idea. So as long as the bound holds for
all the derivatives, then the Taylor series
converges to the function. And it's not too
hard to prove this practical convergence criteria.
From Taylor's inequality. Remember that Taylor's
inequality says that, because of this bound,
the nth remainder is bounded by M over n plus
one factorial times the absolute value of
x minus a to the n plus one. But it's a fact
that the limit as n goes to infinity of M
over n plus one factorial, times the absolute
value of x minus a to the n plus one is equal
to zero. And it's not hard to prove this fact,
by looking at the series.
And using the ratio test, to show that the
series converges, I'll leave that as an exercise
for the viewer. Therefore, by the divergence
test, we know that the limit of the terms
has to be zero, which is what we want.
Now, because the limit of this expression
is zero, by the squeeze theorem, the limit
of the our ends has to be zero as well, which
means that the Taylor series converge to the
function. This practical convergence criterion
is a very good way to show that Taylor series
converges to their function. But even if it
doesn't hold, it's still possible that the
Taylor series may converge to its function,
or in some cases, it may not. Let's use this
practical convergence condition to prove the
Taylor series for sine x converges to sine
x. Recall the Taylor series for sine x is
given by this equation. And recall also that
any nth derivative of x for f of x equals
sine x will have to be of the form sine x,
or negative sine x, or cosine of x, or negative
cosine of x. That's simply because when we
take repeated derivatives of sine and cosine,
the values cycle around in between those four
possible answers. Now, since the absolute
value of sine x is always less than one, or
equal to one and same thing for cosine, we
know that the nth derivative of our function
has to be bounded by one, so we'll let m be
one. And this bound holds for all x values,
all real numbers. Therefore, we know that
the Taylor series converges to the function
sine of x. for all values of x. We've used
the practical convergence condition with M
equals one to prove this. In this video, we
defined the nth remainder for a Taylor series
as a difference between the function and its
nth Taylor polynomial. We also gave a bound
on the size of the nth remainder. It's always
less than or equal to M over n plus one factorial
times the value of x minus a to the n plus
one where M is a bound on the size of the
n plus ones. derivative of x for x within
some distance d of a. Because of this formula
for the remainder known as Taylor's inequality,
we can show that
if the
nth derivative of x is always bounded by the
same M for all x within a certain interval
around a, and for all values of n, then the
Taylor series converge to its function. This
video introduces the idea of parametric equations,
instead of describing a curve as y equals
f of x, we can describe the x coordinates
and y coordinates separately in terms of a
third variable t, usually thought of as time.
so we can write x as a function of t and y
as a separate function of t. This is especially
useful as a way to describe curves that don't
satisfy the vertical line test, and therefore
can't be described traditionally as functions
of y in terms of x. A Cartesian equation for
a curve is an equation in terms of x and y
only. parametric equations for a curve give
both x and y as functions of a third variable,
usually T. The third variable is called the
parameter. That's our first example, let's
graph the parametric equations given here
on an x y coordinate axis. We'll do this by
finding x and y coordinates that correspond
to the same value of t. For example, when
t is negative two, you can calculate that
x, I plug in negative two for t gives you
five and y, when you plug in negative two
for t gives you eight. Please pause the video
for a moment and fill in some additional values
of x and y. For some additional values of
t. Your chart should look like this. And when
we plot the XY pairs and connect the dots,
we get something like this. It says this point
over here corresponds to a T value of negative
two. And this point over here corresponds
to the t value of two. So if we think of t
as time, we're traversing the curve in this
direction, to find a Cartesian equation for
this curve, we need to eliminate the variable
t from these equations. One way to do this
is to solve for t and one equation, say the
first equation. So two t is equal to one minus
x, which means that t is one half minus x
over two, then we can plug that expression
for t into the second equation and get y equals
one half minus x over two squared plus four,
which simplifies to the quadratic equation,
y equals 1/4 X squared minus one half x plus
17 fourths. Let's try some more examples.
A table of values for the first example helps
us draw the familiar graph of a circle of
radius one. This should come as no surprise,
since the equations x equals cosine t and
y equals sine t, are familiar from trig as
a way of describing the x and y coordinates
of a point on the unit circle. Notice that
when t equals zero, our curve lies on the
positive x axis. And as t increases from zero
to two pi, we traverse the curve once in the
counterclockwise direction. A Cartesian equation
for this unit circle is given by the equation
x squared plus y squared equals one. This
follows from the trig identity cosine squared
t plus sine squared t equals one by substituting
in X for cosine t, and y for sine t. Please
pause the video for a moment to graph the
second curve and rewrite it as a Cartesian
equation. The table of values should help
you see that the graph is again a unit circle.
But this time, as t increases from zero
to two pi, we actually traverse the circle
twice in the clockwise direction. I'll draw
this with a double arrow going clockwise The
Cartesian equation for this graph is still
x squared plus y squared equals one. And so
we found two different parameterizations.
For the same
graph on the x, y axis. Let's take a look
at the third equation. There's no interval
value specified for t here. So let's just
assume that t can be any real number.
Now as T ranges from negative infinity to
infinity, our Y values, which are given by
cosine t, oscillate between one and negative
one, our x values are always the square of
our Y values. So the graph of this curve has
to lie on the graph of x equals y squared,
which is a sideways parabola. But a parametrically
defined curve doesn't cover this whole parabola.
Remember that y is given by cosine of t. So
y can only range between negative one and
one. And so we're only getting the portion
of the parabola that I shade in here. As t
varies from say, zero to pi, I traverse this
parabola one time. And then as t goes from
pi to two pi, I go back again in the other
direction. And as T continues to increase,
I traverse this parabola infinitely many times.
The Cartesian equation for this curve is the
equation x equals y squared, with the restriction
that y is between negative one and one. We've
seen several examples where we went from parametric
equations to Cartesian equations. Now let's
start with a Cartesian equation and rewrite
it as a parametric equation. In this example,
y is already given as a function of x. So
an easy way to parameterize. This curve is
to just let x equal t. And then y is equal
to the square root of t squared minus t, substituting
in T for x, the domain restriction in terms
of x just translates into a restriction in
terms of t. I call this the copycat parameterization.
Since we have successfully introduced the
new variable t, but T just copies, whatever
x does. In the second example, we could try
setting x equal to t, then we get 25 t squared
plus 36, y squared is equal to 900. and solving
for y, we'd have y squared equals 900 minus
25 t squared over 36. So y is plus or minus
the square root of this quantity. This is
a very awkward looking expression. And fact,
why is that even a function of t here because
of the plus and minus signs. So let's look
for a better way to parameterize this curve.
Because of the x squared and the y squared,
this equation is a good candidate for parameterizing
using sine and cosine. In fact, if we divide
both sides of the equation by 900, we get
25x squared over 900 plus 36, y squared over
900 is equal to one, which simplifies to x
squared over 36 plus y squared over 25 is
equal to one. If I rewrite this as x over
six squared plus Y over five squared equals
one, then I can set x over six equal to cosine
of t, and y over five equal to sine of t.
And I can see that for any value of t x over
six and y over five will satisfy this equation
simply because cosine squared plus sine squared
equals one. This gives me the parameterization
x equals six cosine of t, y equals five sine
of t, which is a handy way to describe an
ellipse. As a final example, let's describe
a general circle of radius r, and center HK.
For any point, x, y on the circle, we know
that the distance from that point x y to the
center of the circle is equal to r. So using
the distance formula, we know that the square
root of x minus h squared plus y minus k squared
has to equal Are squaring both sides. This
gives us the equation for the circle in Cartesian
coordinates. So for example, if our circle
has radius five, and has Center at the point
negative 317, then its equation would be x
minus negative three, that's x plus three
squared plus y minus 17 squared is equal to
25. One way to find the equation of a general
circle in parametric equations, is to start
with the unit circle and work our way up.
We know that the unit circle with radius one
centered at the origin is given by the equation
x equals cosine t, and y equals sine t. If
we want a circle of radius r centered around
the origin instead, then we need to expand
everything by a factor of R. So we multiply
our x and y coordinates by R. If we now want
the center to be at HK instead of at the origin,
then we need to add h to our x coordinates
and add K to all our Y coordinates. This gives
us the general equation for a circle in parametric
equations. to match the Cartesian equation
above,
we can write
our same example circle and parametric equations
as x equals five cosine t minus three, y equals
five sine t plus 17. In this video, we translated
back and forth in between
Cartesian equations and parametric equations
with a special emphasis on the equations for
circles. This video is about finding the slopes
of tangent lines,
for curves to find parametrically. To find
the slope of the tangent line, for a curve
y equals p of x, given an ordinary Cartesian
coordinates,
we just take dydx or equivalently, we calculate
p prime of x. If the curve is defined parametrically
by the equations, x equals f of t, y equals
g of t. To find the slope of the tangent line,
we still want to find dydx. But since our
curve is given parametrically, we don't have
ready access to the y dx. Instead, we'll need
to calculate it from the Y DT and dx dt, which
are easy to get from our parametric equations.
to relate dydx to d y DT and dx dt, we just
need to use the chain rule. Recall that the
chain rule says that d y dt is equal to d
y dx times dx dt. So rearranging, we know
that dou y dx is equal to d y DT divided by
dx dt. And that's how we'll calculate the
slope of our tangent line, we can write this
formula equivalently as d y dx is equal to
g prime of t over f prime of t. Now let's
use these formulas in an example. For the
list as you figure given by these equations,
and drawn below, let's find the slopes of
the tangent lines at the center point with
x&y coordinates of zero. And let's find the
way the tangent line is horizontal. The slope
of the tangent line is given by dy dx, which
is d y DT divided by dx dt. Now d y dt is
going to be cosine of two t times two and
dx dt is going to be negative sine of t. Taking
the ratio, we see that dydx is twice cosine
of two t over negative sine of t. Now we want
to calculate this slope not when t is zero,
but when x and y are 0x
is
01. cosine of t is zero, which is when t is
pi over two and three pi over two. Those are
the only two values that work in the interval
of t values that we're interested in. And
it's easy to check that when T has these values,
then y, which is sine of two t, is also going
to be zero. So we want to calculate d y DT
at t equals pi over two, and at t equals three
pi over two. plugging into our formula for
dydx, we get twice cosine of pi divided by
negative sine of pi over two, which simplifies
to positive two. And when t is three pi over
two, we get twice cosine of three Pi over
negative sine three pi over two, which simplifies
to negative two. So our tangent lines at the
origin have slopes positive two, and negative
two. Next, let's find where the tangent line
is horizontal. From the figure, there should
be four places. If we set d y dx equals zero,
we get that two cosine of two t over negative
sine of t needs to be zero, which means that
we need cosine of two t t equals zero, or
two t, two equal pi over two, plus some multiple
of pi. Solving for T, we get that T has to
equal pi over four, plus some multiple of
pi over two. There are indeed four such values
of t in the interval from zero to two pi.
And those are pi over four, three Pi over
four, five pi over four, and seven pi over
four, we can find the x and y coordinates
of these points simply by plugging in these
values of t into our original equations. Here
are the XY coordinates of those four points.
In this video, we saw that for a curve given
by parametric equations, the slope of the
tangent line is given by D y dX, which is
d y d t, divided by dx dt. In this video,
we'll find the area under a curve defined
parametrically. Recall that the area under
a curve y equals p of x defined in usual Cartesian
coordinates is just the integral from x equals
a to x equals b of y dx. Or, in other words,
the integral from a to b of p of x dx. If
instead, the curve is given by the parametric
equations, x equals f of t and y equals g
of t, the area is still going to be the integral
of y dx. But now y can be written as g of
t, and dx is going to be f prime of t dt using
differential notation.
Therefore, the area is going to be the integral
of g of t, f prime of t, dt. And since we're
integrating with respect to t, now, our bounds
of integration
have to also be t values, I'll still call
them a and b, but I want them to represent
t values here. It's important to note that
this is still the area under a curve. In other
words, in between the curve and the x axis.
Let's use this formula to find the area enclosed
by this list as you figure given by these
equations. by symmetry, it's enough to compute
the area under one segment of the lisu curve,
and then multiply that area, which I'll call
a bye for now, a is equal to the integral
of y dx. And using our parametric equations,
we know that y is sine of two t, and dx is
the derivative of cosine. So that's negative
sine of t dt. the rightmost point of the section
of curve that we're interested in Then right
here happens when x is one and y equals zero,
it's easy to check that that occurs when t
equals zero. The leftmost point of the section
of curve occurs when x and y are both zero,
setting both our equations equal to zero and
solving for T, we see this happens when t
is pi over two,
plus any multiple of pi. So the first time
we reach this point, after the t value of
zero is when t is simply pi over
two.
So we'll set our bounds of integration as
from t equals zero to t equals pi over two.
plugging this information into our equation,
we get that the area is the integral from
zero to pi over two of sine of two t times
negative sine of t dt. Let's pull the negative
sign out and use the double angle formula
to rewrite sine of two t as two sine t cosine
t, multiply that by the sine t dt,
we can pull the two out and rewrite this as
sine squared of t cosine t dt. And then I
use substitution will allow us to compute
the integral
we get negative two times the integral from
u equals zero to one of u squared d u, which
integrates to negative two u cubed over three,
evaluate between one and zero, which is negative
two thirds. Notice I get a negative answer
here. And that's because I accidentally integrated
from right and point to the left endpoint
instead of from the left to the right, I accidentally
followed the t values in increasing order
when I should have integrated in the other
order in order to make the x values in increasing
order. In any case, I can correct this by
switching my bounds of integration, or more
quickly just by sticking a negative sign in
front and changing my sign. Now I can figure
out the total area inside the list of geo
figure just by multiplying by four. In this
video, we saw that the area underneath the
curve given in parametric equations, is given
by the integral of y dx, which if x is f of
t and y is g of t, this is just the integral
of g of t times f prime of t dt, our bounds
of integration need to be t values.
In this video, we'll calculate the length
of curves given by parametric equations. As
a warm up, let's calculate the length of this
curve graph below. Since it's piecewise, linear,
we can just calculate the length of each linear
piece using the distance formula.
For example, the length of the first segment
is given by the square root of y two minus
y one squared, that's three minus two squared
plus x two minus x one squared, that's two
minus one squared, which gives us the square
root of two. Similarly, the second piece has
length given by the square root of five minus
three squared plus three minus two squared,
which is the square root of five, we can make
similar calculations for the length of the
third segment and the fourth segment. adding
these together, we get a total length of twice
the square root of five plus the square root
of two plus two. We can use the same process
to approximate the length of any curve by
dividing it up into and small pieces, approximating
each piece with a straight line and using
the distance formula to find the length of
the line segments. If the curve is given by
the parametric equations, x equals f of t
and y equals g of t. Then we can write each
of these points along the line in terms of
f and g. For example, P of i minus one, we
can write as the x coordinate F. Have t minus
one and the y coordinate g of t minus one.
And similarly, p II is going to be x coordinate
f of t AI, y coordinate g of t AI. If we think
of t as time, then this is just saying that
T sub i is the time at which we get to point
a piece of AI. Now, the distance formula tells
us that the length of the line segment from
P sub i minus one to P sub i is going to be
given by the square root of x two minus x
one squared. That's f of t sub i minus f of
t sub i minus one squared plus y two minus
y one, that's g of t sub i minus g of t sub
i minus one
squared.
Now, the total length of the curve, which
is called the arc length, is going to be approximately
equal to the sum of the length of these segments.
This is starting to look a bit like a Riemann
sum, but it's missing the delta t. So I'll
fix that by multiplying the numerator and
the denominator by delta t. If I suck the
delta t from the denominator, inside the square
root sign, it needs to become a delta t squared,
and I get the following expression. If I break
up my fractions, I can rewrite this. Now there's
something kind of exciting going on this quotient
here looks a lot like a slope. In fact, it's
exactly the expression for the slope of the
secant line for the function f that we get
if we were calculating the derivative of f
with respect to t. And similarly, this expression,
and here is exactly the expression for the
slope of the secant line, we'd get if we were
calculating the derivative of g with respect
to t. Because these quotients here, are approximately
equal to f prime and g prime, or more rigorously,
because of the mean value theorem, I can replace
my expression with f prime of t i star squared,
and g prime of t star squared, where ti star
is some time in the if time interval. Now
exact arc length is going to be the limit
of this expression, as the number of intervals
goes to infinity. As usual, I can replace
the limit of this Riemann sum with an integral
where the bounds of integration are the t
values that get me from the start of the curve
to the end of the curve. This arc length formula
has an alternative form, which is the integral
from a to b of the square root of dx dt squared
plus d y dt squared, dt. And these are my
two versions of this very useful
formula for arc length. Now let's use this
formula to set up an integral to express the
arc length of this list as you figure
since dx dt is given by negative sine of t.
And the Y dt is given by two cosine of two
t, our Clank is given by the integral of the
square root of sine of t squared plus two
cosine of two t squared dt, we do still need
to figure out the bounds of integration in
terms of t. That will make us wrap around
this curve exactly one time. It's easy to
check that when t equals 0x is equal to one
and y is equal to zero. So we're at this point
right here.
The next time that we get to this point, with
an x coordinate of one, we need x equal cosine
t to equal one. So the next time will be when
t equals two pi.
Therefore, our bounds of integration are going
to be from zero to two pi. It's easy to set
up This integral, but it would be very difficult
to actually integrate it. And that's often
the case with our clients. But we could use
a calculator or a computer to get a numerical
approximation of about 9.4. In this video,
we derive an equation for arc length. This
video introduces the idea of polar coordinates.
Polar Coordinates give an alternative way
of describing the location of points on the
plane. Instead of describing a point, in terms
of its x and y coordinates, those are the
Cartesian coordinates of the point. When using
polar coordinates, we instead describe the
point in terms of radius r, and an angle theta,
r is the distance of the point from the origin,
and theta is the angle that radius line makes
with the positive x axis. Let's plot these
points given in polar coordinates. So the
eight here is the value of the radius, and
the negative two thirds pi is the value of
the angle theta. The negative angle means
that I need to go clockwise from the positive
x axis, instead of counterclockwise like I
normally would for a positive angle. So here,
a negative two thirds pi means that I need
to go to this line right here. And the eight
of for the radius means I need to go eight
lines out from the origin. So my point should
be around right here. The next point has a
radius of five and an angle of three pi. The
angle of positive three pi means that I go
counterclockwise starting at the positive
x axis, here, I've gone around by two pi.
And here, I've got an extra pi to make three
pi. Now the radius of five means I need to
go five units out from the origin. So that
puts me about right here. Notice that I could
have also labeled this point with the polar
coordinates
of five Pi, there's more than one way to assign
polar coordinates to a point.
The next point has an angle of pi over four,
and a radius of negative 12. The negative
radius means that I need to jump to the other
side of the circle before I plot the point.
In other words, instead of plotting the point
at an angle of pi over four and a radius of
12, which would be about right here, I go
to the opposite side of the circle, and plotted
at the same distance from the origin, but
180 degrees or pi radians around the circle
over here. Now I could have also labeled this
point using a positive radius of 12. And using
an angle of pi over four plus pi, or five
pi over four. And in general, a point with
polar coordinates of negative r theta means
the same point as the point with polar coordinates
r, theta plus pi. Adding pi just makes us
jump around to the opposite side of the circle.
To convert between polar and Cartesian coordinates,
it's handy to use the following equations.
First, x is equal to r cosine theta, y is
equal to r sine theta r squared is equal to
x squared plus y squared, which means that
R is plus or minus the square root of x squared
plus y squared. And tangent theta is equal
to y divided by x. Let's see where these equations
come from. If we draw a point with coordinates,
x, y, and draw lines to make a right triangle,
the height of that triangle is y. The length
of the base is x. And the high partners has
length R. Theta is the measure of this interior
angle. From trig, we know that cosine theta
is equal to adjacent over hypotenuse, so that's
x over r, which means that x is equal to r
cosine theta. Similarly, sine theta is opposite
over hypotenuse. That's why over R, which
means that y is equal to r sine theta. That
gives us the first two equations the batang
orien theorem tells us that x squared plus
y squared is equal to r squared. And that
gives us the third equation. Finally, tangent
theta is opposite over adjacent. So that's
y over x, which is the fourth equation.
To convert five, negative pi over six, from
polar to Cartesian coordinates, we just use
the fact that x equals r cosine theta, and
y equals r sine theta. So in this case, x
is equal to five times cosine of negative
pi over six, that's five times square root
of three over two, and y is equal to five,
sine negative pi over six. So that's equal
to negative five halves, did convert negative
one negative one from Cartesian to polar coordinates,
we know that negative one and negative one
are x and y values. So we need to use the
fact that r squared is x squared plus y squared,
that is r squared is negative one squared
plus negative one squared, or two. Also, tangent
theta is y over x, so that's negative one
over negative one, or one. Now there's several
values of r and theta that satisfy these equations
are could be squared of two, or negative the
square root of two, and theta could be Pi
over four, or five pi over four. Or we could
add multiples of two pi to either of these
answers. But not all combinations of r and
theta, get us to the right point. The point
with Cartesian coordinates negative one negative
one lies in the third quadrant. But if we
use a theta value of say pi over four and
an R value of square root of two, that would
get us to the first quadrant. So instead,
we need to use the polar coordinates
of square root of two
and five pi over four. Or if we prefer, negative
square root of two, and pi over four. We could
also add any multiple of two pi to either
of these values of theta, and get yet another
way of representing the point and polar coordinates.
This video talked about polar coordinates
and converting in between Cartesian coordinates
and polar coordinates using some familiar
equations from trig.